Nahesu was late coming home from work.
The girl stood at the front door. She
opened it and heard a strange noise in
the depths of the flat. Nahu saw with a
sinking heart the strange woman's shoes
at the entrance. On unsteady legs, she
went to the source of the moans. Nahu
peeked through the doorway and saw her
husband with another woman. Nahesu woke
up from a nightmare. She dreamed her
husband cheated on her in their house.
Her break's almost over. Time to get
back to work. Nahesu's boss called out
to her. Like she asked, he gave her her
paycheck up front. Nahu thanked him. The
boss really appreciates her as an
employee, so he's always happy to help
her out. He asked how she was doing on
her debts. Had her husband found a job?
Nah. Su thanked the boss and said they
were doing well. Soon her husband will
get a full-time job and things will be
easier for them. The man admonished her
not to let her husband sit on her neck.
A young girl like her shouldn't have to
work from morning till night. Nahesu
served the tables one by one. She passed
a table where a guy was worried about
his girlfriend's diet, saying she needed
to eat better. Nahesu listened and
thought about how wonderful it is to be
in love. How wonderful it is to be taken
care of, just like in the novel. She was
thinking that love is beautiful when
people are young. Does that mean her
life has faded and will never be the
same? Nahesu listened to her coworker's
indignation at being called an ajuma.
She's still so young even though she's
married. The girl kept insisting that
Nahesu is very attractive. Even though
she doesn't wear makeup, she also has a
wonderful personality and is a pleasure
to work with. After her friend's words,
Nahu walked home in a good mood. She was
pleased to observe a young and energetic
colleague. She thought she was beautiful
and secretly envied her. There's nothing
beautiful left in Nahu's life. Her
husband's always complaining about her.
He complains about her appearance and
the fact that she is tired all the time.
He says he hates coming home to such an
unkempt wife. Nahesu really hasn't
allowed herself to spend extra money in
a long time. Because of her exorbitant
debts, she doesn't have time to think
about makeup. She thought of their love
and life withering away like a
dilapidated moldy basement. Her life is
like hard labor as she has to work to
pay off their debts. Her husband told
her that the sight of her made him lose
his appetite. Nahesu was feeling wilted.
Nahesu's work schedule was terrifying.
She has to combine three jobs. A
co-orker who happened to see her
schedule was shocked. Nahesu told her to
stop wondering and get to work. The girl
began to carefully trim the flowers.
Then, while arranging the flowers,
Nahesu thought about the fact that all
she had done all her life was work. When
she was younger, she worked to make a
family life for herself without help
from her parents. Until one day, a
terrible thing happened. Her husband,
who promised her a trouble-free life,
ran up debts in her name and couldn't
pay them off. She forgave him and
promised that together they'd work it
out. Her husband tearfully promised that
things would work out, they'd pay off
their debts and live happily ever after.
Nahesu thought that if you worked hard
and persevered, everything would be
fine. But as time went on, it became
harder and harder to hold back the
tears. Debts continued to grow and love
withered. The ringing of the doorbell
snapped Nesu out of her thoughts. A
handsome young man entered the store.
Nahesu's coworker said that he comes
everyday and buys a bouquet of roses.
She volunteered to serve him because she
liked him. The girl greeted the young
man and asked what kind of bouquet he
was interested in. Handsome looked
around. After a moment, his gaze stopped
on Nahesu. Unsuspecting, the girl
continued to do her job. Unexpectedly,
the young man tapped the counter in
front of Nahu. He asked her to take his
order. Nahesu went to the checkout,
bypassing her upset coworker. She
thought he was acting pretty weird. Nahu
inquired if his order would be a bouquet
of roses. A smile played across the
boy's face. He said he was glad she
remembered his preferences. Chapter 2.
Nah. Su is picking up a bouquet and
thinking about how in the world there
are those who are always the center of
attention and those who no one cares
about. At first glance, it was clear
that this guy is very popular. Nahesu
thought of herself as unremarkable. When
the bouquet was ready, she held it out
to the young man. At that moment, she
caught herself thinking about him a lot.
She couldn't understand why he was so
tightly lodged in her head. Her coworker
told Nahesu that this guy comes exactly
on her shift and only wants to be
serviced by her. She's sure he likes
Nahesu. Nahu admitted that she noticed
him for the first time. The friend was
shocked. How could she have overlooked
such a handsome man all this time? Nahu
was uncomfortable that she didn't
recognize a regular customer. It's not
surprising with her work schedule. She
was very tired. Her friend kept assuring
her that the guy liked her. Nahesu
thought that a woman like her couldn't
be interested in such a handsome man,
especially since she was older than him.
In response, the friend replied that now
it's fashionable to date someone older.
And that guy didn't take his eyes off
her. At this time, the guy was looking
at the bouquet and thinking about how
beautiful the girl who gathered it was.
Nahu had very low self-esteem, so she
didn't believe her friend's words. She
wondered how a stranger could compliment
her while the man she lives with thinks
she's ugly. Her coworker kept
encouraging her and saying that they
would look good together with that guy.
Nahesu admitted that she already has a
man. She remembered him coming home
yesterday. Without even saying hello, he
started demanding food and complaining
about how tired he was. He headed
straight for the shower on the way,
throwing his clothes around. When he
came out of the shower, Nahu had already
laid down to rest. Fed and clean, he lay
down beside her. He thought about the
fact that despite her appearance, she
had a rather attractive figure.
Suddenly, he began to kiss her neck and
began to cuddle up to her, hinting that
he missed her, but Nahesu remained
motionless. The man tried calling out to
her, asking if she was asleep. Nahesu
replied that she was very tired. Then he
started complaining that she was always
tired and didn't pay enough attention to
him. He got angry and started calling
her frigid. Said she's being dramatic
because of work. Everyone works and is
tired, but they have time for their
husbands. Then he turned his back and
went to bed. Nahu exhaled with relief
and fell asleep. Nahu's mornings always
started early. Although she doesn't have
to go to work so early, she gets up in
time to make Mcho's breakfast. Since he
doesn't like to eat the same thing, she
makes fresh food every morning. Then
before she can eat anything, she runs
off to work. Regardless, she comes to
work with a smile. She changed her
clothes and decided she'd hold off on
the food until lunch. The ringing of the
doorbell announced the arrival of a
client. Without taking her eyes off the
monitor, Nahesu said hello to the
customer. When he answered, she looked
up and immediately recognized the
handsome regular customer. Nahesu
offered to pick him a bouquet of roses
as usual, to which the guy replied yes
with a smile. While she was punching the
check, she caught herself thinking that
only now she noticed what a beautiful
voice he had. A low tamber and a polite
tone. His voice excited her. She pushed
the check towards him. At this moment,
Nahesu's stomach made a rumbling sound.
The guy looked surprised for a second.
He reached for the check. Their fingers
almost touched. The girl became
uncomfortable. She hoped he didn't hear
the sound her hungry stomach made. At
this time, the guy texted his driver. He
sat down in a chair and waited for his
order to be placed. After a while,
Nahesu's coworker spotted a handsome man
in the window. He was standing in the
street talking to some man. When he
turned around, he looked like a model
sipping a drink through a tube. She
thought he was really tall and hot. The
girl couldn't stop admiring him. He took
his bouquet and left. Nahesu noticed
that he left his sandwich on the
counter. A man was walking down the
street when he heard his name being
called. Nahesu caught up with him and
told him he forgot his sandwich. The
young man looked at her with interest.
He said he bought it for her. When he
had already turned around, Nahu grabbed
him by his jacket. She thanked him and
said she couldn't accept it. Because you
don't want to eat it dry. He handed her
his cup. I took a sip. So, there's
definitely no poison in it, the guy said
with a chuckle. That charming young man
stood and held out his cup to Nahu.
Looking at him, she couldn't refuse him.
Chapter 3. When Nahu came back, she
didn't know what to think. Her friend
said that the guy really liked her since
he bought her a sandwich and gave her
his
coffee. Jesu looked at herself in the
mirror and saw an exhausted woman with
wounds and no makeup. She looked so
pitiful that she mistook his actions for
pity and charity rather than a show of
interest. She looked at the food and
thought, "What if he was interested in
her after
all?" Then she needs to immediately draw
a line between them. Anyway, it's just
her fantasy. So, she decided her friend
couldn't stop saying how lucky Jesu was
to have such a handsome man paying
attention to her. She wondered if she
was going to pay attention to him. Since
the coworker didn't know, Nah Su said
she was married. The friend apologized.
She didn't know, but Nah Su had a reason
for not spreading it around. Her husband
won't let her tell outsiders about their
relationship. They had to divorce
because of debts, and he wants to hide
the fact that they live together from
everyone. In the office, the workday is
in full swing. Someone called Mchel. A
young, beautiful girl handed him a
coffee. The cup had a sticker on it
wishing a good day. Mchel was pleasantly
surprised. The girl walked away humming
a little song to herself. During a smoke
break, Mitchell's older coworker was
telling him about Ari, how young and
beautiful she was, how lucky he was that
she liked him. They started making lewd
jokes about young girls. Mchel thought
that she was really young and hot. The
man told him to take advantage of the
opportunity while he's young and
handsome. Ary clearly has a crush on
him.
He asked if Mchel was free. That's when
Ari and her friend walked past them.
Mchel looked at the girl interestedly
and replied that he is single. Later at
home, Mchel watched TV while Nahau put
things in order. She asked how he was
doing at work, which made the man angry,
saying he was tired and that she
shouldn't bother him. The girl replied
that she was just worried about him. She
hopes that when he gets a permanent
place, they will be able to pay off
their debts faster and get married
again.
Talking about marriage pissed him off.
He told her to stop nagging him. He said
that Nahu couldn't live a day without
him, so she shouldn't push him.
Suddenly, the man remembered something
and decided to appease her. He starts
asking her for money for perfume. Does
she want her man to smell bad now that
he works in the office? When Nahu said
that they can't afford to spend too much
this month, Mchul got angry and started
saying that he deserves a nice expensive
perfume. He said she was just greedy,
turned around, and went to rest. The
next morning, Nah Su was calculating how
much Mchel spent on himself to look
decent coming to work. She understood
that a young man wanted to look
well-groomed. But no matter how much
they worked and saved, they were still
in a lot of debt. To please him, she
decided to take extra shifts at work.
Nahesu left him money for perfume.
She'll have to work overtime for a
while, but Mitchell will be happy. Then
she went to work. Late at night, two
young men were standing in an alley
smoking. One of them was surprised at
the sudden invitation to dinner.
Normally, bomb taiha can't be dragged
anywhere. The guy usually shies away
from noisy places, but his friends
always happy to hang out. A guy asked if
he could invite a couple of girls with
him. Bomb Taiha was fine with it. His
friend thought it was strange. The guy
never went to cheap eeries, much less
called anyone for company.
The young men finished their cigarettes
and headed for the
establishment. Bomba looked happy and
excited. It was a cheap diner that
served beer and fried meat. A group of
drunken men were discussing how a woman
should behave so that her husband would
not leave her. They said that a wife
should be affectionate, not to cross her
husband and in everything to please,
then any man will try for her. Nahesu
thought at this moment that despite her
best efforts, she was only hearing
reproaches from her husband.
There was a time when he could be
affectionate and attentive. She wondered
if it was her fault what their
relationship had become or time.
Suddenly, a group of young men entered
the
establishment. Jesu wondered how many
there would be. Among them, she
recognized the handsome man from the
flower store. She was so startled by his
arrival that she was
speechless. Chapter 4. The guys were
happy to all get together for dinner.
The cute girl in the center said they
needed a table for four. Nahesu led them
to their table. While the young people
were studying the menu, Nahu came to her
senses. She thought it was strange that
this handsome man came to the place
where she worked. Her friend's words
about that handsome man being interested
in Nahu came to mind. But she couldn't
believe it, and she wasn't interested
either. She was embarrassed that he had
bought her breakfast and now tried not
to look in their direction.
The girl sitting next to Bum Taiha tried
to strike up a conversation with him.
While Nah Su was wondering if they were
dating, the guy kept his eyes on her.
The girl asked him who he kept looking
at. His friend laughingly told Hiji that
she wasn't Bomb Thai's girlfriend. No
need to bother him with questions. The
girl didn't like the guy's remark. They
started arguing.
Donuk, your meat is on fire. The guy
interrupted their argument. The guy
calmed down and started eating. Hiji
watched Bomb Taiha and realized that he
kept looking at their waitress. She
asked if he knew her personally. The guy
cracked a smile and said yes. Hiji was
jealous. How could such a handsome man
be acquainted with an unattractive
Ajuma. Nahu was cleaning up as usual
when she noticed that her coat was torn.
She thought Mchel would be angry with
her because she had just bought it
recently. Mchel was having fun on his
phone.
He asked if Nah Su was going to go to
bed. Mchel noticed that Nahu was going
to sew. He snatched the item from her
and accused her of pulling it out in
front of him on purpose. He started
yelling at her for dressing like an old
woman, that this rag should be thrown
away, that she was pathetic and no man
would look at her. Nahu remembered again
how the handsome man had bought her
breakfast and realized that it was out
of pity. Menchol felt a little ashamed
of himself for snapping at her. He
pulled her to him and told her that even
though no one wanted her, he was still
with her. Nahu was sure at that moment
that she only had him. She realized she
was living a very unhappy life. The next
morning, Nahu made Mchaw's breakfast as
usual. Since rain was forecast for the
day, she started looking for an
umbrella. There was one whole umbrella.
She checked the old umbrella. It was a
little broken, but still worked. Jesu
left a whole umbrella for Mchole so he
wouldn't get wet on the way home. Ary
smiling headed for the coffee. She knew
she'd find Mchel there. The girl tried
to draw his attention to herself. She
started looking for coffee on the top
shelves. Suddenly, the girl screamed and
clung tightly to Mchel. Suddenly, the
girl screamed and clung tightly to
Mchel. She said she saw a big bug and
she was terrified. When Mchel offered to
chase him away, the bug was gone.
Mchel was pleasant around Ahri. He felt
courageous. Meanwhile, at the flower
shop, Nahu's friend was sighing and
waiting for handsome Bomb Taiha to
appear. Finally, she saw him from
outside the window. Nahu felt
uncomfortable. She asked her friend to
take care of the clients while she
herself worked in the back room. The
young man was surprised at how quickly
Nahu ran away. He thought it was pretty
interesting.
The guy decided not to embarrass her
further and placed an order with her
coworker. He didn't even look at her,
hoping to see Nah Sue. The workday is
over. It was pouring rain outside and
the girls said goodbye. Nah, Sue thought
about how stupid she was for running
away today. Tomorrow, she would try to
behave normally. Suddenly, her umbrella
literally fell apart. She tried to think
of what she should do. She couldn't run
home in such a heavy downpour. If only
she had bought a new umbrella in time,
but she always feels bad about spending
extra money. If she called Mitchell, he
would definitely get mad at her. She
thought about waiting out the rain under
the awning. Suddenly, someone covered
Nahu with an umbrella. When she looked
up, she saw the handsome Bomb Teha,
"Where do you live?" The young man asked
her. Nahu was embarrassed, for her
concern, and said there was no need to
help her out. She thought he'd turn
around and walk away, but the guy didn't
move. He kept his eyes on her. He really
wanted to be with her for a while. Let's
take shelter under my umbrella together.
Chapter 5. Nahesu was astonished. Heaven
must be laughing at her and pushing her
into this guy over and over again. The
handsome guy stood looking confidently
at the girl. Nahesu decided it would be
awkward to refuse him, so they went home
under his umbrella. They stood at the
stoplight in awkward silence. Contrary
to her expectations, the guy didn't try
to make conversation. The sound of the
rain made Nahai Sue feel comfortable
walking with him under the same
umbrella. Bum Taiha kept his eyes on the
girl, careful not to let the raindrops
hit her shoulder. The girl noticed that
despite his tall stature, the guy tried
to walk slowly, adjusting to her pace.
Nahisu thought about the fact that with
Mchaw, she always had to run and walk
behind him. Then she remembered that she
had seen the handsome man with a girl at
their diner. She asked if his girlfriend
would mind him walking under the same
umbrella with another woman. Bomb Teha
looked at her interestedly and asked why
she thought he had a girlfriend. Nahu
admitted that she remembers him having
dinner with friends and a girl sitting
next to him. The guy was amused. He said
she was wrong. He doesn't have a
girlfriend. He said it was just his
friends. He moved closer to Nahu.
It's a true. Please believe me. Hey Jes
felt strange, said she believed him.
Suddenly, a headlight came around the
corner and a car horn honked. The guy
grabbed the girl's shoulder and abruptly
turned her around to face him. A passing
car dowsed him from a puddle while Nah
Su remained completely clean and dry.
The girl snuggled her face into his
broad chest, feeling safe beside him.
Bomb Taiha apologized for scaring her.
He was afraid the car would hit her.
Nahu felt uncomfortable. She was pleased
by the guy's concern. Suddenly, she
realized they were standing tightly
pressed against each other. He covered
her completely with his body. I'm big,
right? Said the guy. Nahu stared at him.
I mean, my height. I'm tall. I covered
you from getting splashed on. Nahu
looked at him in confusion. She thought
that maybe he was interested in her, but
why else would he behave like that with
her? As they continued walking, the girl
ventured to ask why he was so kind to
her. She couldn't believe someone would
behave like that without ulterior
motives. You found me out. I have my
motives. I just want to get to know you.
The guy smiled. When Nahu said it was
impossible, the guy smiled
condescendingly. He wondered why she
didn't want to get to know him better.
Hi Su replied that he's young and
popular with young girls. He shouldn't
waste his time on an Ajuma like her.
When they arrived at her house, she
thanked him for his help. The guy asked
if she was sure she didn't want to get
to know him better. Nahu suggested that
they remain strangers. There's no need
to complicate things. Bombaya promised
to do as she asked. He wished her the
best and went home. The girl stared back
at him with a sense of bitterness. He
was tall and sturdy, and deep in her
heart, she was hurt that he had backed
down so easily. But a line had to be
drawn between them. When Nahu returned
home, she noticed that Menchall had
forgotten to bring an umbrella. She
remembered the words of the men at the
diner that a woman should take care of
her man. Nahu grabbed an umbrella and
decided to head out to meet her husband
from work. She hoped he would appreciate
her concern. Finally, she approached his
place of work. People were leaving the
building. one by one, but Menchaw did
not appear. His phone was off and he
didn't read her message. Jesus thought
he might have left by now. Suddenly, she
saw him walking under the same umbrella
with a pretty young girl. Nahu froze in
place. She felt jealous. Finally, the
couple noticed her. Mchel was confused
and the girl looked suspiciously at
Nahau. The man told Ari it was his
family member came to meet him because
of the rain. Jesu didn't like that Mchel
introduced her simply as a relative.
Mchel said she shouldn't have come after
him in this weather. He would have
gotten there on his own. He waved
goodbye to Ari and tried to get Nah Su
away quickly. He then proceeded to
berate the girl. He wasn't happy that
she came. He didn't want them to be seen
together. When Nah Su asked what kind of
girl it was, the man got even angrier.
He didn't like that she was
interrogating him. She was just his
coworker who decided to help him out.
Minkl said she wouldn't understand since
she has no friends or co-workers. A
memory of a handsome guy wanting to get
to know her better surfaced in Jesus's
mind. She experienced a sense of guilt
in front of
Mchaw. The girls were very tired, so
they got a very large order. They were
sitting there exhausted when Jesus's
coworker started complaining that her
arms hurt. Nahu offered to work on her
own while her friend rested for a while.
Suddenly, a new client appeared in the
doorway. The handsome man looked around
the store. The girl was in anticipation.
She hoped that today he would order from
her and not
Nahu. Nahu said hello and was about to
ask if she would make him a bouquet as
usual. To her surprise, no sooner had
she finished speaking than the guy
walked past her as if she hadn't even
existed. The girl felt cold and shocked.
Chapter 6. It's been 2 weeks.
Mchel started staying at work more often
and even going out on
weekends. Life went on as usual. Nahu
continued to work. Bahama no longer
approached Nahu, pretending they didn't
know each other as she had requested.
Jesu was offended by his behavior even
though she herself asked for it. She
must have mistakenly thought that he was
in love with her. Maybe it's for the
best. If his feelings were true, it
might hurt. Mchel didn't respond to
Nahes's messages. She would fall asleep
before he got home from work and leave
while he was still asleep. Nahesu served
the table where the man was celebrating
his divorce. He had already had a few
too many drinks and was bragging about
how well he was going to do now. Now he
can hit on young girls. His friends
congratulated him. There were dirty
jokes at the table and the company was
having a good time. Suddenly, the
drunken man glared at Nahu. He thought
to himself that she had an appetizing
figure and a pretty face. Since he was a
regular customer, she must have known he
had his own business. He thought his
attention would be flattering to her. He
called Naisu very loudly and demanded
that she pour him a drink and drink with
him herself. The girl was a little
frightened. She was not comfortable with
this attitude. She politely declined.
The man started yelling at her,
threatening to complain and have their
eery shut down. The owner of the diner
came running out screaming. He was
trying to figure out what was going on.
Nearby visitors began to defend Nahu,
saying that the man was hitting on her.
The drunk man shouted that he was a rich
and regular customer and that he had to
be served the way he wanted to be served
or else he would stop coming to the
place. The owner of the diner
apologized, offered dinner at his
expense. That wasn't enough for the
scumbag. He told Nahau to kneel down and
apologize.
While the owner of the diner was arguing
with the man, the girl knelt down and
apologized for being rude. She didn't
want her bosses to have problems because
of her. The boss reached out to her,
asking her not to do this because it
wasn't her fault at all. After work, the
boss scolded Nahai Su for giving in to
this impedent person. He didn't want her
to be humiliated because of him. He was
worried about her because he knew she
already had a hard life.
There are a lot of people out there who
can be hurtful. Jes Sue was pleased by
the boss's concern. She assured him that
everything was fine, making sure their
diner didn't lose a regular customer.
She has worked hard and faced hardship
since her youth. She gradually stopped
taking such incidents to heart. Boss
offered to give her a ride home, but it
turned out that Nah Su was leaving for
her next job. The man was concerned.
When does she rest? He didn't mean to be
rude, but he asked if she really had
that much debt. Nahu remembered the
first time debt collectors came to them
and trashed their apartment and
threatened their lives. She was broken.
Mchel tearfully promised that they would
pay off the debt and live happily ever
after again. She simply answered yes.
Now she lives in fear of debt collectors
everyday. A drunken man was walking home
and talking about how nice it was for
him when the waitress knelt in front of
him. figured she'd be nicer next time,
that now she knows not to piss him off
and will do as she's told. In his
drunken ramblings, he didn't realize
someone was following him. From behind
came the sound of
footsteps. The man got his ass kicked,
flopped to the ground, and yelled, "Who
dared touch him?" The stranger grabbed
him by the hair, and lifted his head up.
"Do you want to die?" came the voice of
a stranger. He told the man to hit him
first and quickly. The man got angry and
started shouting that he would teach the
guy a lesson. The man swung his hand and
slapped the guy in the face. The young
man rubbed his lip with pleasure. He
asked the drunk man if he knew who he
was. The man roared that he didn't know
him. Don't you? This is your chance to
find out. The guy said, and blood
spatter flew in different
directions. This evening, Nah Sue was
working a shift at a convenience store.
Even though it was late at night, there
was still plenty of work to do. She was
tired, but she knew it wasn't usual for
customers to be out this late. Her eyes
closed from exhaustion, and she dozed
off. Suddenly, she woke up to a slight
noise. She had already started to say
hello when she realized she knew the
man. It was the handsome guy from the
flower shop. Nahesu wondered if it was a
coincidence that he was coming to the
flower shop and the diner where she
works and now to the shop. Despite the
awkwardness, there's no one to serve him
but her. The young man put only a packet
of band-aids on the counter. Nahu looked
up and saw the wounds on his face. She
was worried about what had happened to
him. The guy stood staring at her
intently. His gaze was
expressionless. Chapter 7. Nahesu looked
at the horrible wounds on his face and
wondered what kind of monster could have
done this to him. She was genuinely
upset, but she didn't know if she had
the right to ask him what had happened.
Even though they had decided to remain
strangers last time, the girl couldn't
just ignore him. "If you just put a
bandage on without applying any
medicine, it will get worse," the girl
said. Bum Taiha was surprised that she
spoke to him. The girl thought she might
be minding not her own business. After
all, they decided not to keep in touch.
The young man broke out into a smile. He
was pleased with her concern. Suddenly,
he leaned on the counter and loomed over
the girl. His eyes were full of
mischief.
Then, what should I do? Please teach me.
Nahu was embarrassed by the way he spoke
to her, how close he leaned to her. He
looked at her again with interest and
was surprisingly polite. Nahu decided to
talk to him informally since she was
older than him. She told him to follow
her. Bomb had decided if she was
informal with him, it was a good sign.
He liked it. Let's sit outside and I'll
help you. The girl called him to follow
her. The guy followed her as if on a
leash. Nahesu handed him a healing
ointment, but the guy said he didn't
know how to use it. The girl grumbled
and said that she would do it herself.
Suck it up even if it stings," she said
and began to treat the wounds. "Um" the
boy shuddered. Nahu wondered if he was
in a lot of pain. She was very worried
about him. "It is a little ticklish," he
said. He enjoyed her touch. Jesu asked
how old he was, but the guy only said he
was adult. "A grown kid is running
around fighting," the girl
inquired. Bum Taiha said it wasn't his
fault.
It's just the way life is. There's not
much joy in it and he has problems at
home. Those words echoed in Nahi Su's
heart. She remembered herself as young
and joyless. It seemed to her that their
situations were similar. She couldn't
ignore his words. She looked into his
deep eyes and saw
sadness. His words touched her and she
made a decision.
Last time you asked if we could be
acquainted. Okay, let's get to know each
other. He asked if he could call her
Nuna, to which the girl flatly refused.
Since she is older, he should address
her as
Ajuma. The guy grinned
contentedly. He was very happy that Nahu
sympathized with him. He later thanked
her and asked her to add him to her
contact list. The evening turned out
well. One evening at a company party, a
group of colleagues stayed late. Mchel
had lost track of what he'd drunk. He
didn't feel like going back to their
shabby apartment. Boss kept pouring Ari
drinks even though she was already
drunk. She looked into her glass and did
not understand what she was drinking,
but it was indecent to refuse the boss.
Suddenly, Mchel discreetly swapped her
glass for a glass of water. Ary didn't
expect this. She was grateful to him.
Colleagues drank and chatted happily.
They started asking Menchel type of
women he dislike. He said he can't stand
a Jumas who are perpetually tired and
neglected. He likes young girls who wear
nice lingerie and take care of
themselves. Mchel immediately thought of
the unattractive Naisu. To be honest, it
was her type that annoyed him.
Colleagues started teasing him. He
described the image of the Ajumas in
such detail as if he was living with one
of them. Maybe that's the kind of girl
he'd really like. Mitchell snorted,
saying that he prefers beautiful,
well-groomed, and young girls. This
conversation began to irritate him. Ary
listened to their conversation and
realized she was quite his type. She
liked Mchel. She would like him to pay
attention to her. Mesu stood staring at
her phone. Earlier, she and Bombayha had
exchanged contacts. She decided that she
would try to get to know him better. He
immediately started texting her. She
thought he had an unusual name. At the
same time, Mitchell did not answer her.
The girl decided not to distract him
because he was working so hard and he
was having a hard time right now.
Menchel decided to walk Ari home as they
got very drunk. The girl was barely on
her feet. Said there was no way she
could make it on her own. Suddenly Ary
clung to Mchel and started saying that
he was not like all the men around.
Embarrassed, the girl confessed that she
had liked Minkl for a long time. She
reached for him and offered to go to her
house.
Chapter 8. Mchel didn't reply to Nahu,
so he must have gotten home late and
gone straight to sleep. That's what she
thought, but Mchel was actually spending
time with Ari. Nahesu worked the night
shift and was heading home. She was very
tired. She hadn't even sat down to rest
all night. She wanted to go to bed as
soon as possible. The girl walked
quietly into the house so as not to wake
up
Mitchell. Suddenly, she froze. Mchel
wasn't home at this time. The man was
sleeping sweetly in the arms of his
young
mistress. Later that morning, Mchel
called Nahi Sue to say that the
corporate party had gone long and he was
spending the night at a nearby bath
house. He was annoyed that she was
worried. He said he was going straight
to work and hung up the phone. Nahu felt
guilty for making a scene. She believed
her husband's words. She didn't even
realize that he could lie to her.
Mitchell, hugging Ari, happy with the
night, went to work without
hesitation. A lonely guy was going about
his business and looking under his feet.
Suddenly, someone appeared in front of
him and called his name. The boy
recognized Bomb Taiha and said hello. He
wondered what he wanted from him since
they hadn't talked to each other in
years. The guy was surprised that he
remembered him. They went to school
together, but Bomb Taiha was popular in
school and always sat behind, while Jimu
was the nerd and sat in the first desk.
Despite this, Bomb Thai had a good
reputation. He was not a bully, so Jimmu
was friendly and asked what he could do
for him. Bomb Taiha smiled and asked him
to switch shoes in a rather friendly
manner. Jimu was surprised. His cheap
sneakers didn't compare to Bomba's
expensive sneakers. He wondered if he
was joking with him, but finally he said
yes. The boys exchanged shoes. Jimmu
thought it was a favorable exchange for
him. Bum taha thanked the acquaintance.
The guy went on about his
business. Bombaya sat alone and listened
to music. Suddenly, Hiji came over to
him and asked him what he was listening
to. He let her listen. It was an old
band's love song to Ajuma. Hiji was
surprised. No one listens to that kind
of stuff anymore. Bombha looked happy,
said he liked it. The girl turned her
attention to the guy's shoes. She
thought it was strange that he was
wearing such old cheap sneakers. She
asked what was wrong with his shoes, to
which the guy cheerfully replied that he
liked them like that. At this time,
their friends were passing by. They were
jealous that all the girls were always
hitting on Bomb Ta. Don said the girls
like his face, that's all. His friends
started teasing him about Bum Taiha
stealing Hiji away from him. He noticed
that Hiji was interested in Bum
Taiha. Jealousy and anger read in
Donuk's eyes. The girl sat waiting for
customers. Nahu's coworker was saying
that she must have been mistaken that
the handsome man liked her because
lately he didn't want Nahu to serve him.
She sighed dreamily and wondered if this
handsome guy would come to her for a
bouquet today. Jesu remembered last
night, but she decided not to tell her
friend. At that time, a familiar pretty
face appeared in the doorway of the
store. Bum Taiha immediately looked at
Nahau with a confident gate. The man
walked right up to her counter. Nahu's
colleague was shocked who dared to
disfigure such a beautiful face. I'm
here to buy flowers. Bomb Tayah pulled
himself closer to the girl with a slight
smile. Nahu was embarrassed. He was too
close. She asked what kind of flowers he
wanted to buy. You know what I'm going
to order? We know each other now, the
guy said
playfully. Nah Su started picking a
bouquet of roses. A guy stood next to
her and watched her. The girl observed a
strange picture. The handsome man was
joking ambiguously with Nahu, asking if
she would make a discount for her good
acquaintance. From the outside, it
looked like the two were flirting.
Suddenly, Bomb Taiha asked if Nahu was
free after work. The girl was
embarrassed. She asked if Bomb Taya
wanted her to scold him. "Uh, I do want
to be scolded," the guy thought to
himself and smiled
contentedly. "Capter nine." Nahu
finished her work at the flower store.
Bomb Taiha was waiting for her at the
entrance. The girl had her next job
waiting so she could spend time with
him. The guy said he remembered that she
worked at the meat counter. He offered
to walk her to work. Bomb Taiha joked
that they just met and she doesn't have
time for him anymore. He was upset that
she was working so hard. Said being an
adult was boring. Jesu was noticed that
the guy although young, he is very tall
and broad. Bombha noticed that the girl
was considering him and asked what she
was thinking about. Jesu replied that
the guy was very tall. So she thought
about his height. The young man smiled,
said she was good at it. He was even
jealous. Nahu was surprised. What was
there to be jealous of since she was
shorter than him? The guy smiled
indulgently. He thought to himself how
honest and naive she was. He said it
would be his pleasure to walk her to
work. Nahu didn't mind. Nahu turned her
attention to his worn sneakers. Even
though they're old, they look good on
him.
The girl asked why he buys flowers
everyday instead of buying more
practical things. Bumha looked at her
thoughtfully and replied that there was
little joy in life, so why not make
yourself feel good? Nahu was touched by
his words. They were said so quietly and
heartily. She thought about how there
was little joy in her life either. This
guy turned out to be very wise. She felt
ashamed that at first she had condemned
his actions.
She had spent so much time picking
bouquets for other people that she
didn't even think flowers could make her
happy. She thanked Bomb Taiha for
keeping her company. If you're grateful,
then let's see each other often in the
future. The boy smiled sincerely at her.
The lunch break had started in the
office and Ari was looking for Mchel.
Suddenly, she heard one of her
co-workers discussing her with Mchaw.
The man told Mchel about Ari being
seemingly arrogant. He said that all
women get mercurial as they get older,
so he should take advantage of them
while they're young. Ary listened. She
wondered what Mchel would say, but he
didn't say anything, and then the man
continued to ask him if they had had
anything yet. This kind of talk was not
to Mitchell's liking. He decided to
teach that jerk a lesson. He said the
man had been with the company for quite
some time, but had never attained a high
position. Instead of wasting his time
talking, he should be doing his job.
Mchel walked right up to him and told
him to finish cracking up. He looked
like an idiot. Then he turned around and
walked away. Mchel was standing on a
flight of stairs. A coworker had angered
him with his talk. Ary suddenly appeared
and wrapped her arms around him. She
heard their conversation, afraid that
Mchel was just playing with her
feelings. But it turned out he was a
good guy. The girl was afraid that after
a night together, he would forget about
her. But she was wrong. Ary was very
happy. She decided she would never let
him go. A carefully prepared dinner was
waiting for Mitchell at home. The man at
this time was having a carefree dinner
in the company of his mistress and had
no intention of returning home. Nesu
worked the night shift at the motel
today. She received encouraging texts
from Bomb Ta. He showed attention and
care towards her. Jesu was very
pleasant. She thought he was young and
romantic.
Bomb Taya was directly across the street
from her work at this time. That guy had
his own secrets. A very drunk man
entered the lobby. He was barely
dragging his feet. The man asked for a
number and then started demanding that
some girl be called to have some fun.
Nahu politely asked for his card to pay
for the room. The drunk handed her the
driver's license and began to hustle.
The girl didn't know how to talk to him
so as not to cause problems.
Suddenly, another man appeared in the
lobby. He asked if there were any rooms
available. The man handed her a card and
told her he was buying out all available
rooms for that night. Nahesu was
shocked. This had never happened
before. Bomb Taiha stood sheltered in
the shadows. He checked his phone and
got a message saying, "Problem solved."
The drunk was walking and cursing that
he couldn't get a motel room. Bomb Taiha
was pleased with himself. The motel
manager was amazed that all the rooms
were booked. She was happy to let Nahu
go home. The girl was overjoyed. She
thought that luck had smiled on her. In
a good mood, she walked home and was
glad that she would be able to get a
good night's sleep tonight. When she got
home, her heart sank. The food left for
Mchel was untouched and he himself was
not at home. Chapter 10. Nahu continued
to receive caring texts from Bomb Tea.
He showed attention, worried about her,
wished her a good day. Throughout the
day, he texted her
periodically. Nah, Su thought it was
because he was still very young. She
enjoyed his attention and felt better
every time he wrote to her. Regardless,
she never once answered him. She just
didn't know what to write him. Bomb
Taiha smiled enigmatically and thought
to himself how to get her to answer him.
Donic asked why his friend was always
smiling and looking at his phone. She is
ignoring me, replied the guy, smiling.
The guy wondered what kind of girl could
ignore Bomb Teha. He was even more
surprised that his friend was texting a
girl. Nahu was standing at the stove as
usual, cooking Mincchel's favorite dish.
He was in good spirits after his
meetings with Ari. Suddenly, he felt
like saying something nice to
Nahu. The girl blew on her spoon and
gave him a taste of the dish. He said
she cooked so good her food is to die
for. Mchel didn't feel guilty about
cheating. He just felt sorry for her
today. He thought that cheating was even
good for a long-term relationship. He
thanked Nahu for the money she gave him
for the perfume. Suddenly, an idea
popped into his head. Menchaw thought to
himself that her figure was more
appetizing than Ahri's. He got excited.
He bit her ear and whispered that it had
been a while since they'd spent time
with each other.
The man began to caress her and bite
down on her neck. The girl asked to be
let go because she was late for work.
Mchel let the girl go. Jesu worried if
he was offended. The man assured her
that it was
fine. Mchel didn't expect anything else
from her. He lay down and started
texting Ari. He enjoyed their relaxed
conversation. Ari suggested they get
together. He was thinking of going with
her and picking out his perfume. He
remembered how they usually went
shopping with
Nahu. She always chooses the most
unattractive and cheapest clothes.
Mitchell noticed that she glances at
beautiful things, her eyes always full
of regret at that moment. But every time
he asked if she liked something or
offered to buy it, she refused. She
always felt bad about spending money on
herself. It pissed the man off. He
decided to go with Ahri because Nahu
doesn't know how to shop and is boring
with her. Bomba met his subordinate in a
dark
alley. The young man gathered
information about Nahu's husband. He
made sure that such a bastard didn't
belong with her. He held up a lighter
and the fire began to consume the photo.
His eyes were full of grim pleasure. The
guy was determined to act. Nahesu's
shift at the motel was coming to an end.
Her eyes were closing from exhaustion,
but she had a shift at the meat diner
ahead of her. Suddenly, there was a text
message from Bomb Tahha. He wanted to
see her for a little while after work.
The girl didn't mind. She was happy to
spend time with him. Bomb Taiha stood at
the entrance to the motel waiting for
Nah Su. The girl came out and stared at
him. Bomb Taiha looked so handsome and
confident. She complimented him. She
thought to herself that he was actually
more mature than she had originally
thought he was. Nahu said she didn't
have much time because she was in a
hurry to go to another job. Bomb Taiha
was happy to have a short meeting and
said he would see her off. The young man
said that this alley was very dark and
dangerous. She must be scared to walk
here alone. But the girl assured him
that she was not scared. I'm scared. The
guy tried to flirt with her and gave her
a sly
smile. You're so big it's like you're a
barrier. A walking barrier. Nesu stared
at him. Haha. The boy laughed heartily.
Then shall I walk behind you like this?
Bombha stood behind her so tall and
smiled. Jesu threw back her head and
their eyes met. It was nice to feel
secure around him. The girl sighed, told
him to go and keep quiet. Bombaya slowed
his step and looked closely at the
girl's figure. She looked so fragile and
delicate. He wanted to protect her. His
gaze fell to the back of her head and
became icy cold. The guy saw the bite
mark on her neck. Jealousy boiled up in
him and he reached out a hand to the
girl. He pulled Nahesu to him and leaned
over
her. Chapter 11. Nahu asked what
happened. In a low voice, Bomb Taiha
said that she must have been bitten by
an insect. The young man gently wrapped
his fingers around her neck and stared
at the bite sight. Nahu was surprised.
Insects were rare at this time of year,
and she didn't feel any discomfort
either. It definitely made the insect,
the guy said a little
strangely. Nahesu couldn't understand
where the bite on her neck could have
come
from. Suddenly, the girl remembered what
had happened since morning, and that
Mchel might have left this trace. The
girl felt ashamed that Bomb Taiha had
seen this. She
blushed. Yes, I think it was a bug. I
think I got bitten by a bug. The girl
tried to cover her neck with her hand.
I knew it. Bomba breathed out into her
ear. He ran his finger gently over the
bite sight. Jealousy and anger fought in
him, but he decided to pretend he
believed the girl, didn't want to
embarrass her. Bomb Taiha said he had to
put a band-aid on the wound to heal it,
and started rummaging through his
pockets. Nahu exhaled, thinking the guy
believed her. The guy very gently and
with care put the band-aid on and
smoothed it out a bit. Jesu felt a
strange emotion. She was embarrassed.
Suddenly, he asked why the girl wasn't
responding to his texts.
I'll get sad if you don't reply. There
was sadness in his words. Nahu had never
received a text like this before. She
wasn't cared for, so she didn't know
what to reply to him or if she should.
Then she remembered how sad she was when
Mitchell didn't reply to her texts and
she realized how Bombaya felt. She
experienced intense feelings of guilt
and
apologized. She had never communicated
like that with anyone. She did not want
to offend him. Said he must be bored
with her. The girl wanted to socialize
with him for she had no friends. She was
happy to know that someone was
interested in her. Bomb Taiha fixed her
collar. He said she didn't have to
apologize because he wanted to write to
her and insisted on communicating with
her. "I was just throwing a tantrum like
a little kid," the guy leaned in and
said. He asked her not to apologize or
try to please anyone to her own
detriment. "Nah, Jesu, do as you wish,"
he said
fondly. The girl heard such a phrase for
the first time in her life. It was the
first time someone had told her to do
what she wanted to do. Nahu was in a
good mood. She asked her boss if she
could buy one flower for
herself. The boss offered to pick up the
flower for free because Nahu is working
hard, but the woman insisted that she
would pay for it. She decided to give
herself a gift and was very happy with
it. It was the first time a girl had
ever let herself buy something for her
own
pleasure. She decided to come home
before her next job to put a flower in a
vase so it wouldn't wilt.
She poured water into a small vial and
placed the rose in it. There was joy in
the girl's soul. Nahu decided to share
this event with Bomb
Taiha. She took a picture of the rose
and sent him a message. At this time,
Mcho decided to stop by the house for a
little while, too. He was surprised,
asked why she was at home and not at
work. The girl replied that she had come
in for a short while and was leaving
soon. Nesu thought he was already back,
but Mchel said he would quickly change
his clothes and go to work overtime.
Suddenly, the man noticed the rose and
asked where it came from. Jesu replied
that she had bought one rose just to
please
herself. Something came over him. He
felt so sorry for
Nahu. He wanted to caress her just
because she looked so pitiful. Suddenly,
he realized that the thought of fooling
two women tickled his nerves, and he
decided to caress Nahu. He wanted to do
it quickly and leave to meet Ari. But
suddenly, the girl protested and said
that she was going through a dangerous
period. When he heard that, he got angry
and grabbed her chin and growled
disappointedly that she would never get
pregnant anyway. He said she screwed up
as usual, got up and left. The girl was
left lying on the floor in torn
feelings. Bum Taya stood and looked at
the message from Nahu. He was very happy
that she had texted him. Suddenly, some
girls he knew approached him. They
didn't believe it was him at first. It
was a poor neighborhood. What would he
do here? The girls said it was a big
coincidence that they met in such a
place. Bomb Taiha smirked. He didn't
believe in
coincidences. Behind every seemingly
plausible coincidences, there are
hundreds of
inevitabilities. Some inevitabilities
are intertwined one after
another. For that one coincidence that
will reach you.
The guy smiled and replied that there
were no
accidents. Nahu was folding clothes when
she came across Mcho's shirt. The girl
noticed a lipstick imprint on his
collar. Her head rumbled. Her heart
began to beat
desperately. Chapter 12. Mchel was
waiting for Ari in the parking lot. The
girl smiled when she saw him. She asked
where they would go this evening, but
Mchel was angry after the incident with
Nahai Su and didn't answer anything. The
man swung open the car door and tore the
girl toward him. Still angry after the
incident with Nahu, he took advantage of
Ahri's plability, who, unlike his wife,
didn't refuse him. Nahu was distracted.
After discovering lipstick on her
husband's shirt, she couldn't get over
it. Everything fell out of hand.
Suddenly, the girl dropped the glass and
it shattered into small pieces. The
thought of a lipstick mark had been on
her mind since she had never used makeup
herself.
She didn't rule out the possibility that
it could be a misunderstanding. She
tried to convince herself that she was
making it up. The girl was afraid that
her suspicions were unfounded and she
would upset Mitchell. And although she
held back unshed tears, she decided not
to worry and hoped that everything would
be fine. By an unfortunate coincidence,
Nahu witnessed a client's telephone
conversation. She supported her friend
whose husband cheated on her. From the
conversation, she realized that her
husband cheated on her because they had
not been able to have a child for a long
time. Usually at work, Nahu was
distracted from thinking about her life.
But today, everything reminded her of
the worst of times. The girl remembered
what had been the last straw for her,
the hardest loss of her life. Every time
she had a hard time, she tried to think
of the good things, the best things
ahead. But right now, she wasn't sure of
anything. didn't know what was going on
between her and Mitchell. Bombha rode
his bike up to the store where Nah Su
worked. He saw her through the window
sitting with her head bowed and upset
about something. The guy thought about
the fact that the more he tried to
distance himself from her, the more he
was drawn to her with destructive force.
Without removing his helmet, he walked
straight toward her with a confident
gate. Nahesu was so absorbed in her
thoughts that she didn't immediately
notice the customer.
The girl thought he was weird, came in
silent, and didn't buy anything. Then
she noticed his tall stature. A thought
flashed through her mind that he looked
like someone else. Suddenly, the guy
held out her phone with a message on the
screen. And finally, everything fell
into place. Bomb Taiha was flirting with
her again. Nahu sighed. At least it
wasn't a strange
stranger. Do you want to be scolded?
Bomb Taiha opened his helmet, a chuckle
red in his eyes. Jesu asked why he was
wearing a helmet and the guy took it
off. He said he came to see her from
work. The girl assumed he worked in
delivery and Bomb Taiha didn't deny it.
She said he should be careful on the
roads. "Uh, are you worried?" he said
with a smirk. Nahu calmly motioned for
him to stand up and raise his helmet
above his head as punishment for his
jokes.
She was just kidding. But the guy
actually complied. The girl was
speechless. Bomb Taiha stood there and
smirked. Even in this situation, he
looked very
attractive. Nahesu asked why he came and
the guy said he hadn't had dinner yet.
He wanted to buy something. The girl was
worried that he was hungry. Reprimanded
him. Said that he should change his job
if he didn't have time to eat at this
one. Bum Taiha was amused by her
concern. He was pleased. The guy
remembered what he was doing that night.
Thought about watching her bastard
husband with his
mistress. He was disgusted to realize
that this man was next to
Nahau, but he was patient. Suddenly, the
guy stood up close to Nahu and said he
couldn't quit because he was doing a
very important job. The girl remembered
that he mentioned problems at home. She
believed that he had to work hard and
given his large frame, he also needed to
eat well.
She said she would treat him to dinner
tonight. Nahesu told him to pick what he
liked and she'd give him a treat. The
guy didn't expect her to do that. All
I'll take from you is your heart. I can
afford to buy a meal, said
Bombha. The guy stretched out his arm
and rested it against the shelving unit.
He asked Nahu to just help pick out the
most delicious things they have in the
store. The girl was embarrassed. She
thought he was joking like that again.
She felt his back. He was big and
strong. His presence excited her. Nahu's
gaze fell on his wrist. She saw the
beginning of the sentence in the form of
a tattoo. Chapter
13. Nahu turned to Bombha and asked what
it was on his wrist. The guy looked at
her. For a moment, he thought maybe she
didn't like
tattoos. Maybe she thought they made him
look like a thug. He rolled up his
sleeve so she could see.
Do you hate it? Then I'll erase it, said
Bomb Tea confidently. Nahesu grabbed his
hand in a soothing gesture, her voice
trembling.
Tell me, why do you have a scar like
this? She raised her eyes full of alarm
at him. Bombaya was surprised by how
worried she was about him. With what
trepidation, she squeezed his wrist. For
a second, he remembered how the wounds
bled under the black ink. Nihei Su
thought about this young man's life, how
many hardships he had to endure, whether
he had done this to himself. She wanted
to know what was behind his sad eyes.
Bomb Taiha realized everything from her
face full of sadness. He was pleased
that she sympathized with him and it was
funny. He felt a kind of pleasure in her
expression, so he thought about teasing
her some more. The guy gently ran his
hand over her arm and said the scars
were from the accident.
Nahesu was surprised by his answer and
looked at him anxiously. She reacted
exactly as he thought she would. Bumha
was pleased with himself. She is naive
and he likes it. He said it wasn't worth
her trouble. The guy started picking out
food. Jesu thought that he had lied to
her very skillfully, but since the scars
were old, she decided not to press him
with questions for now. The girl helped
the guy choose a delicious meal, saying
since she was treating him, he should
trust her.
Nahesu sat the guy down to eat dinner
and went back to the counter herself.
Bomb Taiha shown a smile. He was pleased
that the girl cared about him. He tried
to be at ease with her. Nahu was
confused as usual. She thought that this
guy gave her conflicting feelings, but
she definitely liked him. She liked that
she could temporarily escape from her
drab life and problems with Mitchell.
Bomb Taiha seemed like a strange guy to
her, covered in scars and wounds with a
suspicious job. Everything about him
seemed strange and tempting at the same
time. Mchel and Ari were lying around
talking. The girl laid her head on the
man's chest and suddenly confessed that
she wanted to marry him. Mchel instantly
tensed up. Arie pouted and asked why he
reacted that way. Said she hadn't
thought about marriage before she met
him. Mchel was tensed by such talk. He
tried to joke that the girl was still
too young to think about marriage. Ary
jumped up and started to get indignant.
She said that Mchel was old enough to
think about getting married and since
she was his girlfriend, it was okay. The
resentment in her voice was
palpable. Mitchell pulled the girl to
him and continued to convince her that
she was still too
young. He said that all young girls are
in a hurry to get married. Isn't it
silly to waste your youth on one man?
While Ary looked at him with resentment
and incomprehension, the man continued
to convince her that it was too early
for them to think about
marriage. Mitchell thought about almost
getting caught. He thought they were
just having fun, but he didn't think
she'd take their relationship so
seriously. He thought that the girl must
be from a wellto-do family, judging by
where and how she lived. Ary dressed
well, has her own car, is wellgroomed,
and most likely grew up in a loving
family. Mchel thought she was the
opposite of Nihisu and he liked it. The
girl didn't stop and asked the man how
he sees his family when he gets
married. Mchel thought about it and
replied that he wanted a cozy apartment,
a car that could accommodate the whole
family and one child. Ary was touched by
his revelation. She asked if he really
wanted
kids. The man recalled an unpleasant
moment from the past. When he had a
chance to have it all, he was saddened
when he found out that Nah Su was so
weak that she couldn't have
children. But now he's glad the
circumstances are the way they are. A
child is a great luxury for them. He
told Ari that it's expensive and hard to
raise a child, so he's not ready for
that yet. Ary could hear the notes of
bitterness in his voice. She wanted to
support Mchel in some way. She clung to
him tighter and told him that his dream
would definitely come true. The couple
continued to lie there, each thinking
about his own
thoughts. Night shrouded the city. A
lone figure stood on the roof of a
skyscraper and stared into the distance.
Bum Taiha stood on the roof and recalled
a recent conversation with his
subordinate. They were sitting in the
passenger compartment of an expensive
car. Bum Taiha held out his wrist to the
man and asked what he saw. The man
assumed a Buddhist saying was tattooed
on his wrist.
Bomba smirked. He was once again
admiring Nahu.
How can that be? How can anyone notice
the white scars beneath the black ink
before seeing the ink first? He
pondered. The man stood there thinking
how amazing she
was. He stood and thought about how he
wished he could wait for her. Wait for
her relationship to end like an adult.
But of course, it won't be like that.
He realized he was too impatient. And
even though she'd done nothing, he'd
already lost his freedom. The source of
all suffering is
attachment. Baham Taiha took a deep
breath and realized that his suffering
had already begun. The attachment
overwhelmed him. He couldn't and
wouldn't resist it. Nahu was late
returning home as usual and was absorbed
in her
thoughts. Suddenly, she recognized the
man walking towards her. It was the
drunk man who had been harassing her at
their diner. The girl tensed up,
thinking he was about to start hitting
on her again. To her surprise, the man
saw her and froze in horror. He turned
and ran down the first alley without
saying a word to her. Nahu was
surprised, not realizing that it was
just now, but she was glad that she
could get home safely. When she got
home, Mchel was already asleep. She
undressed quietly and lay down to rest,
too. The girl was surprised that her
husband fell asleep so early. She
thought that he really worked hard and
was tired. She was worried that he was
overworked. Suddenly, Mchel's phone
began to vibrate. The girl's name lit up
on the display. Nahu's heart skipped a
beat. Fear and anxiety gripped her.
Chapter
14. Nahisu had been at a loss all day.
She wondered if she should have answered
that call to find out what that young
girl wanted from Mitchell.
A sense of jealousy demanded that she
ask her if she and Mchel were really
just co-workers at work. The man slipped
soundly while Nahu went over all the
questions she wanted to ask this girl in
her head. She never decided to answer
and the call stopped. The girl was
afraid that she would not be able to
bear the answer. She consoled herself
with the thought that this girl was
calling him on work matters. At work, a
co-orker started showing her pictures
from her friend's wedding. The girl was
very excited. It was the first time she
had been to a wedding and she was very
happy about it. She told her how she
dreamed of one day meeting a nice man
and wearing a white dress. The girl
remembered that Nahu was also married
and started asking her if she had a hard
time planning the wedding, what kind of
dress she had, and where they spent
their honeymoon. Jesu had nothing to
reply to. All these questions made her
plunge into her memories. She and
Mitchell just filed the papers. There
was no grand
ceremony. They were both surprised at
how quickly it was
processed. Having registered the
marriage, the couple left the building
as if nothing had happened. Mitchell
suggested going to a diner and eating
meat. Despite the man wanting to lighten
the mood, Nahu tried to object. They
needed to save money, but eventually
agreed. Mitchell hugged the girl tightly
and said that in a year's time, they
would definitely hold a lavish marriage
ceremony. He promised that she would
wear a beautiful wedding dress, that
they would give each other diamond rings
and be sure to go on a honeymoon to
Hawaii. Nahesu listened to him and
believed him. She believed every word he
said. The man kept telling her how good
they would live and that everything
would be perfect for them. The girl
continued to blush and believe, and
Mchel teased her that she was blushing.
Though Mshaw didn't keep any of his
promises, they both laughed and were
happy that day. That day shone brighter
than any
diamond. Cars drove down the road one
after
another. Biamaya checked his phone again
and again. She stopped responding to his
messages again. He really wanted to get
close to Nahau, thinking about how he
could do it. If I had known it would
turn out this way, maybe I should have
taken a few more hits that day, he
thought. Suddenly, a lighted lighter was
brought to his face. His new bodyguard
suggested he light a
cigarette. Bumha stared at him intently.
He was unhappy that he had been pulled
out of his thoughts. He said it wasn't
necessary and showed that it was just
candy. The bodyguard faltered. He
apologized, said he'd like to give him a
light if he smoked. Bomb tea handed him
a lollipop and said that if he wanted it
so badly, he could light his candy. He
said he hadn't seen him before. The man
replied that today was his first day.
Bomb Taiha asked with an impenetrable
gaze if he had ever buried a person
before. The young man was thinking about
what he should do since the girl doesn't
answer him and what he would like to do
with her loser husband. The newly minted
bodyguard didn't know what to say. He
said he'd never had to do this before.
The man said if his master took care of
him and paid him well, he would try to
do whatever he was told. Bum Taiha
handed him a lighter and told him to
relax. He was just kidding.
The man stood there and didn't know what
to think. He couldn't tell from the look
on his new master's face whether he was
joking or not. He asked the second
bodyguard, to which his colleague
replied with a shrug. Bomb Taiha stood
on the bridge and continued to think
about his. At this time, his new
subordinate was thinking that anything
could be expected of him. Bomb Taiha
looked just like his father, the
chairman, and it was even scary.
Nahu witnessed a conversation between
two friends. One of them was complaining
that her husband was having an affair at
work. While she was working several jobs
and counting every penny, her husband
was spending money on a
mistress. Everything was falling apart.
Memories of Mchel's strange behavior
resurfaced in her mind. Jesu had doubts.
What if Mchel really cheated on her? She
panicked, thinking what would happen to
her if it was true. Growing anxiety
squeezed her heart. The girl found it
hard to breathe. A passing supervisor
noticed that she wasn't feeling well and
asked her what was wrong. The girl
replied that she was not feeling well.
Nahu gasped and asked to leave work
early. The boss immediately agreed to
let her go, saying he was worried about
her, so let she rest. The man asked if
she needed to go to the hospital, but
Jesus said she would rest and it would
go away. She thanked him and headed out.
The girl ran down the street without
remembering herself. Her head was
buzzing, her legs carried her on their
own. Tears covered her eyes, and it was
at that moment that a gentle, familiar
voice sounded in her head. The voice of
the man who had once told her that she
should do what she wanted. That calm
voice made the ever submissive Nahu find
herself at Mchel's work. Once inside,
the girl began to hesitate. Mitchell had
said he would work at night, but she had
never been here before and didn't know
where to find him. Suddenly, a guard
called out to her. The man said no
outsiders were allowed in here, asked
her what she wanted. Nah, knew that
Mchol hid their relationship from
others. She said that she was his
relative and she urgently needed him.
The guard thought for a moment and said
that he didn't remember Mchel staying at
work that night. Nah Jesus's eyes
darkened and for a second she thought
she would lose consciousness, but
suddenly the guard offered to escort her
and help her find him. The man led the
girl to the right department and loudly
asked if Mchel was there, saying he had
a visitor. Nahu clutched the strap of
her bag tightly, her eyes darting around
the office looking for her
husband. Chapter
15. The office was full of employees
working overtime.
Ary heard that someone came to Mitchell
and immediately recognized the girl who
greeted him with an umbrella on a rainy
day. Mchel appeared from behind his desk
asking who might have come to see him.
Seeing Nahai Su, the man froze. There
was an awkward pause in the air. The
girl stared at him and clutched the
strap of her bag tightly with
excitement. The man jumped up and said
that he needed to go out for a while.
Ari looked at them with interest.
Mchel roughly grabbed Nahu's arm and
dragged her away from the office. He
gave the girl an annihilating look and
told her to follow him. The man dragged
her roughly all the way even though Nahu
asked him to calm down saying that her
arm hurt. The man pinned her against the
wall, clutching her wrists tightly. He
started yelling at her, asking her what
the hell she was doing here. Mitchell
became very angry, saying that she was
disgracing him. Suddenly, he noticed
that the girl was numb with fear,
trembling and mumbling that she was
scared. Suddenly, it hit him. Mkel bent
down to her face and asked angrily if
she was afraid of him. Nahu tried to
refuse, but that only made Mchel even
more angry. He squeezed her wrists even
tighter and shouted in her face. How
long would she keep reminding him of the
past? The girl didn't want to remember
it. But because of the events of the
past, the girl was frozen with horror
every time she heard the screams. Her
body was shaking and her heart was
racing. Her eyes filled with tears and
Minkl gloatingly asked why she was
crying. Suddenly, Bomb Taiha's voice
came back into her mind and she forced
herself to ask her husband whose
lipstick mark she had found on his
shirt. Mchel didn't expect the ever
submissive Nahu to do such a thing. He
even asked her again. She said she never
wears makeup. So she wanted to know how
he got lipstick on his shirt. And though
she was trembling with fear, she
demanded an answer from him. Mchoil
sighed. Everything became clear to him.
He smiled evily and said she was
jealous. Deep down, he felt the
satisfaction of that. He told the girl
that she was acting like a psycho out of
jealousy. The man said she was crazy to
come to his workplace for such a trifle
and make a scene. Nahu was in a stuper.
She didn't know what to say. She didn't
want it to turn out like this. Mitchell
said he probably just bumped into
someone. He said Nahu disgusted him,
turned around and walked away. The girl,
frightened and humiliated, remained
standing against the wall. Her legs
could hardly hold her. She felt very
guilty. Nahu wandered around the street
in a semi-conscious state. She didn't
even notice the people around her. She
accidentally grazed the shoulder of a
passer by and didn't even turn around.
She looked strange from the outside.
Suddenly, the same passer by was
shoulder bumped by a very tall and
sturdy man. The stranger tried to swear,
said his shoulder was dislocated. Did he
run into a phone pole? Watch where
you're going. Bomba threatened him. The
young man walked silently behind her,
shortening the distance and counting the
remaining steps to her. He himself did
not notice how there were no more than
10 steps between them. Bomb Taiha looked
sadly in her wake and thought that she
should have noticed his presence by now.
It saddened him to realize that if there
had been three steps between them, she
still wouldn't have noticed him because
she didn't want to. All her attention
was focused on her loser husband, and
this made him very angry. Bumaiha
pretended to be a nice guy, trying to be
patient, but he wanted Nahu to notice
him. He wanted her to turn around right
now and scold him for his wicked
intentions. Bomba continued to write to
her even though she didn't answer him.
He warned her that the forecast said it
would snow today. He'd want her to be
happy for the first snow, but she was so
jaded she'd forgotten what it was. So,
they walked all the way to her house.
Mom Taiha took out his phone and typed
the next text message that it would rain
after the snowfall. He hoped the sound
of the phone would bring her back to
reality. Nahisu silently stood outside
her house, hanging her head. Soon, a
downpour fell from the sky. Nahu
continued to stand and stare blankly at
nothing. The water ran down her face,
and the coldness permeated her entire
body. She tried to comprehend everything
that had happened that evening. What was
she thinking when she rushed to Mchel's
workplace?
The girl bent in half, dropped her head
to her knees, and sobbed bitterly, as
loudly as if the noise of the rain could
drown out her suffering. Bombaya stood
around the corner, his heart breaking
with pain for her. He thought that she
should have realized what kind of man
her husband was. He dropped his umbrella
and set his face to the jets of rain. He
wanted to take all her pain for
himself. The young man was fighting
himself because he was having a hard
time staying a good person with her. He
remembered how she empathized with him,
tried to support him. She said he was a
good man and he would be fine. But she
was wrong. He wasn't good. He was a fool
for believing that her unhealthy
relationship would soon end on its own.
In fact, he'd been willing to do
terrible things for her. And today was
the last time he'd let her cry. The next
morning, Nah Su came to work with puffy
eyes. Her friend was worried about her
and asked her if she was okay. She said
she just ate too much ramen for dinner.
There were still 10 minutes left before
the workday started. Jesu said she'd be
gone for a while. Muel never came home
last night. Nahu cried and waited for
him until morning. She wanted to make up
with him. The girl was thinking that
their wedding anniversary was coming up
and she would like to go to a restaurant
with him, hoping things would work out
for them. Suddenly, something warm
touched her face.
You're slacking off. The suddenly
appearing Bomb Taiha loomed over her.
Chapter
16. Nihi Su just stared at the handsome
young man for a while. Bomb Taiha
started making fun of her puffy eyes and
the fact that she was sherking work. The
girl was embarrassed, said she wasn't
amused. The young man brought her coffee
and told her to be careful as it was
still hot. Nahu thanked him. The guy
asked if she would scold him for coming
to her, even though she didn't respond
to his
texts. The girl was very pleased that he
had taken care of her by bringing her
coffee. She thought that the more she
scolded him, the more insistent he
became, so she said she wouldn't scold
him. Nahesu was embarrassed, but still
asked a question. Are you into that sort
of thing? Bombayha innocently inquired
as to what she meant. The girl clarified
if he liked being scolded. Bum Taiha
laughed heartily, even covering his face
with his hand. Nah, Su was very sweetly
indignant and asked him not to laugh at
her. The young man looked at her
languidly and said, "Uh, well, actually,
I'm not into that sort of thing, but I'd
be okay with anything from Nahu." It
sounded very exciting, and he looked
very seductive at that moment. Nahu
thought he was messing with her again.
Baham said that from now on he would
come to her without warning. The girl
did not mind, but she said not to look
for her on Friday. He asked why, and
Nahu replied that she and her husband
would be celebrating their wedding
anniversary. The guy was very surprised
and
displeased. The girl apologized that she
didn't have time to tell him that she
was married, but she thought that he
himself had already guessed. The young
man imagined her reaction if he told her
that he knew everything about her life,
that she was divorced. He gently took a
strand of her hair and only said that he
was a little confused.
If it were me, I think I'd hate it.
While Nahu was listening to him
attentively, Bum Taiha kept his eyes on
her. He said that if he were her
husband, he wouldn't let another man do
all the things he did for her. He would
always take care of her himself. The man
seemed to mesmerize her with his gaze.
He almost touched her lips with his
fingers when he asked if her husband
wasn't jealous of her. Jesu was
pleasantly stirred by his words, but she
didn't want to show it to him. She just
said that he was still young and didn't
realize that there is a friendship
between a man and a woman. Baham looked
at her and thought how naive she was.
While her husband sleeps with a young
mistress, she is so kind, hesitant about
him, afraid to get too close to him. The
guy smirked and said he wouldn't bother
her. He wished her a good day and a good
time with her husband. As he walked
away, he cast another glance at her.
Nahisu didn't have time to say anything.
She was a little embarrassed, wondering
if she had offended him. She liked being
with Bombha, but her conscience didn't
allow her to cross the line. Mchel once
again stayed overnight at Ary's house.
She sat on the edge of the bed and
thought back to a recent conversation
with her friend. The girls were sitting
in a cafe and Ari was telling to friend
how beautiful Mchel was. She was very
happy in her relationship with him. She
bragged that even though he's in his
30s, they spend a lot of time in bed.
Suddenly, a friend asked her a question.
Is it strange that for all his virtues
at his age, he still hasn't gotten
married? That alarmed Ary. The girl
turned to the man and stated that she
wanted to finally be in his house.
Mitchell tried to wrigle out of it. He
said she had a nicer house than he did.
He thought about how lucky she was to
live in a prestigious new house not far
from work. He wished he could live in a
house like that. The man thought about
the fact that if he left Nahu for Ari,
she would still stay in their shabby
house and always wait for him because
she loves him. But he didn't know if he
loved her. Mchel thought about Nahu
being cold and emotionless like a doll.
She doesn't look like a real woman.
While he was indulging in his thoughts,
Ari started to get
angry. Suddenly, Mitchell grabbed Ary
and started kissing her. The man
admitted to living in a shabby apartment
with a relative Ari had seen before.
Mitchell said he came from a poor
family, no education. He was afraid if
Ary saw how he lived, she'd leave him.
Suddenly, Ari hugged him tightly and
told him that none of this matters. She
accepts him for who he is.
The girl was touched that he opened up
to her. Tears welled up in her eyes
because of her love for him. Mchel
invited her to come to his house. Nahu
was preparing breakfast as usual early
in the morning when Mchel suddenly
appeared. She was surprised. He didn't
usually get up this early. The man
replied that he had a lot of work to do
today. The girl asked if he would be
late for work. Mitchell said he didn't
know yet. She didn't want to think that
he had forgotten their
anniversary. Jesu took an evening off
from work. She decided that she would
tell Mitchell later that she was free
and they could spend time together. All
day long, the girl worked
tirelessly. As she left work, she
anticipated how happy Mitchell would be
that she was able to free up her
evening. Suddenly, she got a text
message from her husband. He said he
would be working all night, but since
she was also working tonight, it was no
big deal. Of course, he forgot. She
texted him that she was on her way to
work, too. The girl stood in the middle
of the street and thought how stupid she
was. Once again, she was deceived by her
expectations. Jesu decided to go to work
after all. At that time, a man was
watching her from around the corner.
Mencho hugging Ari led her to his house.
The girl was overjoyed, glowing. Now she
could rest assured that if he was taking
her home, they were definitely serious.
The man warned her that she might not
like his house, but Ary assured him that
she didn't care as long as she was near
him. Ary took his hand and pressed
herself against him. She said she'd do
anything for him. The couple slowly
headed home. Mchel was touched by her
words, so he said that he would also do
anything for her. She is very dear to
him. Ary was genuinely pleased and
smiled at him. She said she felt that
they were going to be fine. Mhel was
happy to be near her. The young people
were so absorbed in each other that they
did not notice how Biamha was watching
them. He thought to himself that Nahu
would also be fine with him by his side.
The guy called his driver and asked him
to pick him up soon. He needed to change
his clothes. It's time to put his plan
into action. Bomb Taiha's face lit up
with a sly smile. Chapter 17. Mchel
brought Ari to his and Nahu's apartment.
He was embarrassed, so he told her not
to freak out too much. Arie was
surprised to see the apartment, saying
it was very clean and cozy. The girl
praised the man. Mchel felt embarrassed
because it was all Nahu's merit. The
girl began to freeze. The living room
was very cold and Mchel suggested going
to the bedroom. He said the girl might
get sick, so they should meet at her
house.
Ary hugged him tighter and replied that
he could keep her
warm. Hearing this, Mchel immediately
pressed the girl against the door and
kissed her. A memory of Nahu shivering
in the cold nights flashed through his
mind. She never asked him to keep her
warm. Every time he tried to get closer,
she remained cold and distant. So as
time went on, he lost the desire to take
care of her. He didn't even remember
that today was their anniversary. Bomb
Taiha reached home and began to change
his clothes. The man was well-b built,
his muscles rolling over his back.
Today, he was going to put his plan into
action, so he was confident and
determined. The ringing of a bell caught
the salesman's
attention. A very tall and handsome guy
entered the store. Bomb Taiha stood with
a basket in his hands and picked out the
goods. The girl looked at the strange
customer and didn't understand what was
going on.
Bomb Tea placed a full basket of warming
packets on the counter. The guy smiled
innocently while the girl checked out
the purchase and wondered what he needed
so many warming packs for. Bomb Taiha
thanked the girl and went on his way in
good spirits. Late at night, a woman
took a smoke break in the back of a
restaurant. Suddenly, an unfamiliar
young man approached her. I'm sorry, but
could you call Nahu for me? He looked
unwell, spoke in a breathy voice. A
woman came running to Nahau, saying
there was someone waiting for her
outside. Nahu wondered who could be
waiting for her at this hour. She hoped
it was Mitchell. The girl rushed to the
back door full of hope that her husband
hadn't forgotten about their
anniversary, had decided to surprise
her. Her heartbeat faster with
excitement. She looked outside and
called out to Mitchell. The courtyard
was empty. She wondered if her coworker
was playing a joke on her.
Suddenly, she was rad into a bear hug
from her back. Big, strong arms wrapped
around her body. She felt so small and
fragile. Bomb Taiha hugged her like
something very precious. His face was
very close to hers, and the girl felt
his breath on her face. "Nuna," the guy
exhaled. Nahu was embarrassed, saying he
should call her Ajuma, otherwise
outsiders would think something wrong.
The girl said she'd definitely scold him
next time. The young man smirked and
continued to hug her. It felt so good.
She was soft and warm. Suddenly, Nah Su
turned to face him and asked him with a
concerned look if he had hurt himself
anywhere.
Come here. The girl carefully ran her
hand under his hood. Gentle fingers ran
over his face and her eyes studied him.
Bontea's heart raced and he couldn't
take his eyes off her lips.
Her face was so close he could feel her
breath and that look in her eyes again.
The guy leaned even closer. He was
thrilled by her closeness. But he had to
be patient. Nahesu suddenly realized
that he had a fever. She was afraid for
him. Bomb Taiha said he didn't want to
bother her, but he had nowhere else to
go. He said he wasn't feeling well. When
Nahu said he had to go home for
treatment, the guy said he couldn't go
there. Jesus's heart snapped in
frustration as she remembered that he
had said he was in trouble at home,
always bruised and wounded. The girl sat
him down and asked him to wait for
her. Bum Taiha did not want to let go of
her hand and looked at her hopefully.
I'm not leaving you behind. I'll ask the
boss to take some time off. The girl
calmed him down. Oh, then I'll wait for
you. He was pleased with the way events
were unfolding.
Soon the girl came out, held out her
hand to him and led the way. They walked
in silence. Nahu thought about giving
him medicine and resting for a couple
hours while Mitchell was out of the
house. The girl glanced at Bomb Taiha
every now and then, thinking that he was
so big that he might not fit in their
small old apartment. A guy noticed a
girl staring at him all the time. He
smiled sincerely and broadly at her.
Jesu asked why he smiles so often, to
which Bomb Taiha replied that he was
just happy to see her since they hadn't
seen each other for a long
time. Then, since the kid I used to see
all the time on my way to and from work
isn't around, I'm feeling a bit bored,
too. Unexpectedly, the girl confessed.
Bomb Taiho was surprised to hear her say
that. He thought she wouldn't admit that
she was attracted to him.
Okay, I'll come to see you everyday from
now on. The guy smiled sincerely at her
again. He was very happy around her.
Nahu looked at him and thought that she
liked it when he smiled at her. She
realized that she couldn't take her eyes
off him, unable to turn away from him.
Finally, they came. The girl had warned
him that the apartment was small and
old, but at least he would be able to
take a break. Nahesu approached the door
and stopped.
She thought it was strange that there
was a light on in the apartment. Bomb
Taiha stood behind the girl and felt
satisfied. Everything had turned out
just as he had wanted. A woman's
laughter came from the apartment. Nahu
heard Mcho having fun with a girl in
their
apartment. She reached out a trembling
hand to the door knob. Bum Taiha stood
quietly and waited to see how Nahu would
act. The girl hesitated for a moment.
Chapter 18. Nahu stood there thinking
about how Mitchell's cheating had ruined
everything. Their love, their memories,
and their time together. She stood
listening to the other girl laughing in
their house and couldn't decide what to
do. Bomba stood behind her and said
quietly, "Don't run away." The young man
put a hand on her shoulder in a calming
gesture. Nahu was as if she was in a
trance. She was thinking that her
relationship was over. The cold voice
brought her back to reality. Nahu
suddenly realized that their love had
ended long ago. Her relationship and
marriage kept her shackled to her past
and did not allow her to breathe freely.
While her husband was happy on the side,
she suffered alone. Nahisu tried to
break free from Bomb Taiha's tight grip.
The guy tried to hold her down, telling
her to calm down. Let go of me.
Suddenly, there was fire in the quiet,
malleable girl's eyes. She broke free
from his grasp. The girl pulled the door
open and burst into the
apartment. Bum Taiha stood stunned for a
while. The young man looked at his hand
and smiled. He was pleasantly surprised
that Nah Su didn't run away. She was
braver than he thought. Mchoel and Ary
were lying in bed when there was a
noise. A furious Nah Su burst into the
room. Kang Mchual. A frightened Ary
pulled the blanket over himself and
yelled why his relative was barging in
on them. Mitchell was shocked and asked
why Nahu had come home. Nahesu stood
with eyes full of tears. In her heart,
she had known the truth for a long time,
but she just didn't want to accept it.
She asked her husband who she was to
him. Mchel didn't care. He was even glad
she caught them. He said that now is not
the time to sort things out.
The girl grabbed him by his shirt,
trying to stop him and find out
everything now. Mchel nonchalantly
dressed and waved her off. Are you
saying that after living together for 13
years, I'm just relative? The girl
trembled with anger and
resentment. Ary, who was watching them,
suddenly realized said Mel was a freak
and left. The man rushed to catch up
with her, asking her to listen to him.
He said that they had been divorced for
a long time and that this woman was
absolutely nothing to him. Those words
broke something inside Nahu. She got
really angry. The girl threw up her hand
and pulled Mitchell's hair with all her
might. She didn't even expect to have so
much strength in her. The man tried to
escape her grip, shouting that she was a
psychopath. Nahu continued to pull him
and call him names. Mchel swung around
and hit her. The girl fell to the floor
with a great thud. The man screamed like
crazy that he was sick of her. He found
a young and beautiful girl and started
cheating on her with her. He said that
Nahi Sue couldn't leave him anyway. He
left the girl lying on the floor and
himself rushed to catch up with Ary. The
girl sat
devastated. She looked at the broken
vase and the rose on the floor. She
thought the same thing happened to her.
Nahesu clutched her chest that was
bursting from the inside. Tears flowed.
She wailed
frantically. Mchel caught up with Ari
and asked her to stop and talk to him.
The girl told him to stay away from her.
But the man kept telling her that he was
divorced and just didn't want to upset
her with his past. Bomb Taiha stood
around the corner and listened to the
man say that Nahu was just obsessed with
him, that in fact he was sincere with
Ahri. Anger began to boil within the
young man.
He thought about killing the bastard.
Mchel went to get Ari and Bomb. Taiha
thought about how much he's been
torturing Nahu all this time. He thought
that death was too easy a punishment for
him. He'll make sure Mchel suffers. The
guy will make him pay harshly for what
he did to
Nahu. Bombaya remembered the pleasure he
felt looking at her as he followed her.
In his heart, he was glad that on this
day she would finally learn her
husband's dirty secret. He wondered what
she would do about it. He was glad that
today was the day she'd finally leave
her loser
husband. But now he was in pain. His
goal accomplished, her relationship
destroyed. Now seeing her so broken, his
heart achd and was bruised. He didn't
want to hear her tears ever again. Bomba
headed toward her. Tell me, what do you
want? If it's you, I'll listen to
anything.
If there's something you want, I'll give
it to you. If there's something you want
to do, I'll do it with you. If there's a
place you want to go, I'll take you
there. If you asked me to kill, then
I'll do it. Bomba headed toward her. All
the way there, he thought about her, but
he knew she wouldn't
ask. Bomb Taiha gently stroked her head.
He decided that he would protect her
even though she continued to stare at
her husband.
he would be by her side. He thought that
his first love tied his hands and feet
and tortured him. Bomb Taiha gently
called Nahai Su by name, asking her to
calm down. He kept stroking her back,
worried that she would get sick from
crying so much. The young man was
genuinely worried about her. Suddenly,
the sobbing
stopped. Nahesu fell on Bombaya's chest
and lost consciousness.
Chapter
19 Bomb Teha sat by Nah Su's bed and
watched her every breath. The girl was
breathing heavily. He reached out and
carefully tucked a curl behind her ear.
The young man, without taking his eyes
off her, thought about how he slowly,
step by step, without missing anything,
will erase every unpleasant moment from
her life. He will be there for her every
time she needs it. Eventually, her
wounds will heal. Bomb Teeha didn't want
to, but he had to leave her for a while.
The bodyguard expressed relief that no
serious illness was found in her. After
an antipyetic injection and good sleep,
she will feel better. Bombjo was very
worried about her. He said that a high
temperature is not a joke. The man said
that she had not been well long before
this situation. He did not understand
why she did not go to the doctors
earlier. He couldn't imagine how anyone
could live at such a rhythm. Even if he
was forced, he wouldn't be able
to. The man admired her strength and
stubbornness. Bomba didn't answer. He
just grinned
tiredly. He told the man to follow him.
They have business at the flower shop.
The man stared at the gentleman's back
and thought, "What else did he come up
with?" Hearing Bomb Thai's plan, the man
was stupified.
The guy said that he would work Nahu's
shift on his own and decided to let him
go. The man replied that he would rather
wait and stay nearby. Bomb Taiha liked
his tenacity and
dedication. Entering the store, he saw a
girl out of breath. She asked the client
to wait since they were not open yet.
The girl raised her head and stared at
the first client. She recognized the
handsome man who came every morning to
pick up roses. He looked great today,
too.
I'm here to cover for Nahu, said the
handsome man. The girl thought she heard
wrong. She became worried and started
asking what happened to Nahau. She had
never missed work
before. Was everything okay with her?
But what was more interesting was what
kind of relationship they were in. That
this handsome guy was replacing her at
work. Bomba saw the girl's interest and
just grinned. The girl and the owner of
the flower shop were thinking about what
to do. The woman offered to send him
home and work on her own, to which the
girl said that such a handsome man
should not be sent away. He could help
attract more clients. While they were
deciding what to do with it, Bum Taiha
stood and looked at the store. He was
pleased to think that he would help
Nahu. The store owner offered to put a
mascot costume on the guy to stand
outside and attract customers. Han was
against it. said it was a crime to hide
such a pretty face under a costume. At
last, they made a decision and the girl
turned to Bomb Teha. The guy asked if
they were done discussing what was
required of him. The girl smiled very
slightly and contentedly, handed him a
sign, and told him to listen to her
carefully. A woman and her daughter were
walking down the street when something
caught the girl's eye. A very handsome
and tall young man stood outside a store
and offered passers by to buy flowers.
He noticed the girl was looking at him
and approached them. A young man sat
down in front of the girl, said hello,
and very sweetly asked if she liked
flowers. The girl asked if the store
sells everything, to which Bomb Taiha
replied affirmatively and asked if she
liked anything. The girl immediately
took the guy's hand and told her mom she
wanted to buy this opa. Bomb Taiha was
surprised and smiled. The woman blushed
and began apologizing for her daughter's
behavior. The guy just smiled and
marveled at the little girl's
determination. "I'm sorry, I've already
been sold. Some lady already bought me."
Bum had tried to explain to the girl,
but she was not taken aback and said
that there was nothing wrong with it.
She also bought one boy in kindergarten,
and he told her that now he must marry
her. Bomb Taiha burst into laughter. The
girl's mom stood and blushed even more.
The man stood and watched the unfolding
picture.
Suddenly, he remembered something
important. His file was on the
chairman's desk. Li Jay stood in the
chairman's office with his head bowed.
He didn't know why he had been invited.
The dangerous man sat relaxed in his
chair, playing with a glass of hard
liquor. Setting down his glass, he stood
up and started the conversation. He said
that his son often did things that even
he, his father, found hard to
understand. A man wanted to know
immediately when his son was doing
something weird. He was so dangerous
that LJ didn't dare to raise his head.
And now he was looking at the sky and
thinking about how everything he was
doing looked weird. The man didn't even
know what exactly to tell his father.
The bodyguard thought it would drive him
crazy. Nahesu lay there delirious in her
sleep, begging Mchol not to leave.
Suddenly, the girl came to her senses in
horror.
She realized she was in the hospital,
tried to remember how and when she got
there. Jesu looked at what time it was
and was horrified. She was shamelessly
late for work. She grabbed her phone and
started calling her employer. The girl
with tears in her eyes apologized to the
owner of the flower shop for not coming
to work and said that something had
happened to her. The woman told her not
to worry, thanked her for the
replacement. She said they sold out the
entire store because of it. She wished
Nahu the best and said she had to run
away. The girl sat in a stouper. She
couldn't understand what kind of
replacement she was talking about. Bomb
Taiha's phone vibrated. When he read the
text message, he thought that he had
hoped Nahu would sleep longer and
finally get a good night's rest. Li J
asked if she was awake, to which the guy
said yes and said he had to go see her.
Bombaya asked him if he had ever worked
in a butcher store. The man immediately
understood what the young gentleman was
getting at. He asked him to work a shift
for extra pay, and the bodyguard agreed.
The bodyguard couldn't figure out
whether this guy was driven by
curiosity, caprice, or just plain fun.
Nahes Sue sat in her hospital bed and
got
dressed. Though her head was full of
frowning thoughts, she decided to tidy
herself up. Suddenly, gentle fingers
touched her forehead possessively.
Nahu's body was covered in goosebumps.
She's not used to being taken care of.
Jesu looked up and saw Bomb Tahha
standing behind her, smiling sincerely
as usual. Her chest felt warm. Let's
see. Dear auntie, has the fever gone
down? Chapter 20. Out of surprise, the
girl didn't know what to say. Bum Taiha
suggested standing like that for a
while, he said that she seemed to have a
slight fever.
Jesu replied that a long stay in the
hospital would not speed up her
recovery. The young man asked if she was
going to go back to her home. When she
said yes, he asked, "What about her
husband? And should he keep calling that
man that?" Jesu replied that she
honestly doesn't know what to call him
now. She didn't even know how she would
cope on her own. She felt strange,
couldn't shake the feeling that this
wasn't over. Their love had lasted so
long that she had never imagined how it
would end. Once she thought they'd be
together forever, no matter what the
adversity in her life of misery, he was
the only ray of sunshine and
encouragement to move on. Nahu knew that
it was over between them. Their feelings
had shattered like a vase and could not
be glued back together. The girl shook
with anger and wondered if she should be
angry with herself and how much for such
stupid thoughts. She turned to Bomb
Taiha and admitted that it sounded
pathetic and stupid. Nahu asked him what
she should do. Her eyes were full of
fatigue. The man could see she was ready
to burst into tears. He looked at her
and listened
intently. Strangely enough, the guy
understood her feelings. Bomb Taiha
reached out and gently stroked her
cheek, stopping an unsolicited tear from
rolling down her cheek. He said that if
these feelings could be thrown away so
easily, it wouldn't be love at all. Nahu
was soothed by his gentle voice. She
said he was
strange. The guy was surprised and asked
why she thought so. The girl replied
that in the most difficult moments, he
always says exactly the words she wants
to hear. Suddenly, the guy started
fixing her disheveled hair as if nothing
had happened. But he was interrupted by
the sound of a vibrating phone. Bomb
Taiha took out his phone to check who
was calling him. Nahesu noticed the
girl's name on the screen and she was a
little interested. The guy didn't want
to answer. He put the phone back in his
pocket and sat down on the hospital bed.
Nahu crouched down next to him and asked
why he wouldn't answer. But the guy said
that the call was not important. He
wasn't interested in anyone but her. The
girl looked at him carefully and thought
that she had recently witnessed a
similar call. When someone calls for
such a long time, it indicates a longing
and desire to hear a favorite voice.
Bombaya looked at the girl carefully. It
was obvious that she was thinking about
something sad, and he realized that she
was unhappy that some girl was calling
him. The young man dropped the call and
smilingly told Nahu not to worry,
suggested they talk about something.
Suddenly, Nahu said that the girl who
called him liked him. She sounded sad.
Vum Taiha asked why she thought so to
which she replied that there was no such
thing as friendship between a man and a
woman. What about us then? He moved his
hand over and began gently stroking her
hand with his thumb. Then he sat down
close to her, leaned over and asked her
who they were if they saw each other
every day, and he walked her home from
work. Nahu said he was still very young.
The young man grinned and said that the
girl Mchel cheated on her with was much
younger than him, too.
The girl asked him to stop joking. She
didn't believe that anyone could fall in
love with someone like her because even
the one who once loved her was tired of
her. She turned away from the guy,
afraid that she would cry when suddenly
he said that he liked her. It's not a
joke. I like you. Without taking his
eyes off her, Bomb Taiha said. His voice
was calm and gentle. He brought his face
closer. Nahu was shocked by what she
heard.
She felt his breath on her lips. Bomb
Taiha was magnetically drawn to her. The
girl jumped up sharply from the bed. Her
heart was pounding against her ribs. She
knew the guy was serious, but she wasn't
ready to discuss it now. She had mixed
feelings. Trying to turn away so Bomb
Teha wouldn't see her blush. She said
she was tickled by his whispered words.
The young man looked smug. He noticed
how she blushed and became embarrassed.
He wondered how long she could pretend
she hadn't heard what he said. She
didn't refuse, and that was a good sign.
When Nahu left the hospital, she was
worried about how did he pay her medical
bill, to which the guy replied that he
had some savings. The girl said she
would pay him back for sure. Bomb Taiha
started joking that he would come and
remind her of her debt everyday.
Suddenly, the girl remembered that she
had to go to work at the meat
restaurant, but the guy calmed her down
and said that there was someone to
replace her today.
Meanwhile, in the restaurant, the
waitress was thinking about how to get
all the trash off the table. Li Jay
showed up and took all the bottles away
at once. Visitors were delighted with
how skillfully he cooked meat on the
grill. He could easily and quickly quiet
noisy customers with just his
appearance. Dongwuk asks Hiji if she's
upset about Bomb Taiha. He's nice to
everyone, but there are always a lot of
girls around him. She should not think
that he is interested in her. The girl
got angry that Bomb Taiha didn't answer
the phone and told Dong Wuk that he was
happy to attract the attention of any
girl because a few of them were not
interested in him. Hiji left the guy and
walked away typing another text to bomb
Taiha. Mchel stood in front of Ahri's
house and tried in vain to call her. The
girl turned off the phone. He was afraid
that she would spill the beans at work
and he had nowhere to spend the night.
He did not want to return to Nahu's
house. Suddenly he was distracted by
something. Bomb Taiha stood on the
bridge in a good mood. Li Jay asked what
the young master was doing that made him
look so happy. He texted Nahau Su and
smiled. He couldn't wait to see her
again. H I'm collecting debts. The guy
grinned. He was very pleased with
himself for finally getting Nahu's
donkey of an ex-husband out of the way.
Suddenly, the bodyguard leaned over to
him and said he had received an
important message. Chapter
21. Biam Taiha has been informed that
his older brother will be arriving in
the country soon. The chairman asked to
tell him that the whole family should
gather to greet the eldest young master.
The guy couldn't believe it had been a
whole year since they had seen each
other. The Taiha grinned and asked with
a sneer, "Since when did the chairman
care about sibling bounds?" He looked at
Jay, laughed, and said that when his
brother saw his face, he'd get all the
food stuck in his throat. The bodyguard
only grinned
nervously. While Jay pondered the
tremendous tension between the two
brothers, Bomha kept joking, asking
hopefully if the plane his brother was
coming on would crash. The young man
shifted the lighter between his fingers
and pondered. When the bodyguard asked
what he planned to do, the guy said they
could tell his brother that he was dead.
He was sure it was his big brother's
greatest wish. Biamha's gaze became
mischievous and cold at the same time.
He said with a chuckle, "Let's give him
a sweet lie as a welcome gift." Mchel
stood in front of Ari's house and kept
calling her, but the girl didn't pick
up. Suddenly, something hit his back. He
lowered his gaze and saw a small bag of
chips on the ground.
Ary stood across from him with her head
down and said in a tired voice that he
was a jerk and asked why he was here.
Mchel reached for her hand, but the girl
waved it away and yelled for him not to
touch her. The girl trembled with rage
and resentment and told him not to dare
to touch her with the hands he used to
touch another woman while he was dating
her. The man stated that he had not
slept with his wife since he started
dating Ari. The girl started pounding
his chest furiously with her fists and
screaming that he was a liar and she
didn't believe him. Mitchell stood
still, giving her a chance to blow off
steam. The man was calm and began to
tell her that he did live with his
ex-wife, but only because he had nowhere
else to go. He said that he really
hadn't slept with her since he started
dating a girl. They'd been divorced a
long time and living as roommates, and
it was true. Ari stood there listening
to him in disbelief. Mitchell kept
saying that he had brought her home,
knowing that if she knew the truth, she
would immediately leave him, but he
wanted to be honest with her. The man
reached out and stroked the girl's
cheek. He said he wouldn't bother her
again. The girl stood looking at him
with baited breath. He said he had come
just to apologize to her. Mchel noticed
her grocery bag and told her not to
drink too much because she can't
tolerate alcohol well. He also advised
her to eat soup in the morning to cure
her hangover. In the end, he wished her
to find a good boyfriend, not like him.
Ary stood with her eyes red and swollen
with tears. The man said he was sorry he
was the one with no opportunities,
nothing to offer her, and a dark past.
Mitchell turned around and began to
slowly walk away. The girl stood there
silently torn by conflicting feelings.
Her eyes filled with tears. She knew
with all her being that every word he
said was a lie. Suddenly, despite this,
she rushed forward and hugged the man
from the back, started shouting for him
not to leave. Tears poured down her
cheeks. She shouted curses at him, but
continued to embrace him. Mchel smirked
slightly, thinking to himself that he
knew she would act like that. Nahu
returned to her miserable home, where
everything was waiting for her in the
same manner in which she had left it.
She stood with a devastated look and
contemplated her dwelling. Picking up
the scattered condoms, the girl thought
that she'd like to ask her 20-year-old
self if she ever thought she'd be
cleaning up Mitchell's infidelity in her
own home. Nahu thought about how stupid
she was when she promised to love him
forever. She kept trying to hold on, but
time after time, she just fell apart.
She cleaned the whole apartment, packed
up all his stuff to throw away for good,
but she couldn't bring herself to do it.
The girl was sitting on the floor with
her head down on her knees when the
phone lying next to her started ringing.
She thought it was the debt collectors,
thought they were the only ones who
could be so
persistent. The phone kept vibrating and
it gave her a sense of
foroding. Jesu thought that such a long
call is an indication that either
something urgent has happened or someone
who loves you is calling. She picked up
the phone and saw Bombaiha's name on the
screen. The young man stood naked to the
waist and rubbed his neck nervously. The
muscles in his big broad back were
rolling. He was relieved to say hello
when the girl answered his call. He sat
on his bed and said he couldn't wait to
hear her voice, so he wanted to call and
hear her. Bum Taha inquired how she was
and why she was awake. The girl replied
that she didn't know if she could even
sleep in her house after everything that
had happened. Nahu started apologizing
to him for having to see all this,
regretting that she couldn't take care
of him. She admitted that things were
actually even worse now that she was
back at home. Bomha sat with a serene
look, reveling in her concern, thinking
how naive she was. The guy said he was
fine, joked that even his cold got
scared and went away. The girl smiled
weakly and replied that there was
something to be afraid of. She felt
lighter when she talked to him. Bam
Taiha's gaze became serious and he asked
sincerely how she was feeling. The girl
replied that she was fine, but he asked
incredulously if that was really the
case.
Nahu was silent for a moment, then
sighed and replied that she wasn't fine.
In fact, it was even hard for her to
breathe. Every time she remembers what
happened, it becomes harder and harder
to breathe. Mitchell's footprints all
over the apartment hurt the girl deeply.
Life had made her stronger, but her
feelings were defenseless against the
one she loved. Bomb Taiha listened
intently to the girl and offered her to
break free. The girl asked him what he
meant. The guy asked her to have fun
just as her husband cheated on her with
a young girl. He fell silent and waited
with interest for her answer. The girl
was silent and then Baum Tahha asked if
there was anything she wanted to do but
for whatever reason did not dare to do
it. Something came to Nahu's mind. It
was quite late when the girl was in the
store thanks to the
incitement. As she stepped outside, she
held a pack of cigarettes and a lighter
in her hands.
Jesu thought it might look like she was
acting like a rebellious teenager. She
ran out to buy cigarettes even though
she couldn't afford them. In fact, she
had always wondered why people smoked.
She remembered that Mchel hardly ever
parted with his
cigarettes. The first time they met, she
thought it was hooliganism, but he
looked cool. Later, he always made sure
to throw away his cigarettes when a girl
was near him, even if he was just
starting out. He said that his wife
shouldn't breathe smoke and Nahu
childishly admired him for it. 13 years
later, the acrid cigarette smoke was
something he easily exhaled right at
her. In especially cold weather, she
would look at that white smoke and
wonder if it brought
comfort. She wondered if the sadness in
that white smoke dissipated like a sigh.
The girl stood looking around for a
place to smoke. She found a secluded
spot around the corner. Jesu decided to
smoke at least one cigarette because
they were so expensive. She was sorry to
waste the money. The girl took the
cigarette in her mouth. Her hands were
shaking. She felt like she was doing
something illegal. She held up the
lighter, but nothing happened. The
cigarette wouldn't light. There was the
sound of footsteps behind the girl.
Suddenly, familiar hands with graceful
long fingers took the cigarette from her
mouth. Nah Su exhaled in surprise.
Behind her, Bomb Deha stood behind her
with a smirk. That's not how you do it.
Chapter 22. Arie's house was quiet. Only
the clothes scattered around the room
were evidence of what had recently
happened. Earlier, she stood in tears
and begged Mitchell not to go back to
his ex-wife. Said she would forgive
everything and offered to stay alive
with her. The man contentedly lay with
the girl sleeping next to him and
thought about how easily he had managed
to deceive her, even too easily. He even
laughed at how naive she had been. He
thought of her as young and naive, fun
to have fun with for a while, but no
more. Mchel really thought about moving
in with her, but he didn't want to. Ari
looks the same as Nahu, so it's just
going to be the same story. He thought
about whether he should feel any desire
to leave Nahu and settle down with
another woman, but he decided that would
never happen.
Ary was snuggling up to him in the dream
and he was thinking about staying with
her for a while until Nahu realized how
hard it was for her without her husband.
He wanted her to miss him. Mchel knew
that the girl would be angry at first.
But he knew her and knew that she would
never leave him. He knew that even if he
hurt her time after time, she would just
heal it and forgive him. It wasn't just
self-confidence, but he knew that Nahu
would always be like that.
At this time, the girl asked Bomb Taiha
in surprise how he found her. The guy
replied that it was quite easy because
she had said she would go to the store
and it was the closest to her house. He
reached out and flicked on a lighter.
The young man held up a lighted lighter
and offered Nahu a smoke. The girl
looked at him with interest and thought
she had never smelled cigarettes on him
before. She asked if he smoked since he
had a lighter. Biam Tahha smirked and
replied that he didn't smoke and the
lighter belonged to his friend. He saw
the girl's look of disbelief and said he
wasn't lying to her. Nahu sighed tiredly
and said that adults aren't supposed to
behave like this to rebel like this. She
also heard that men don't like women who
smoke. The guy pulled close to her and
told her it wasn't. He said he didn't
care if she smoked or not. Everything
she did was fine with him.
But if she decided to smoke because of
that person, then he'd be against it. He
moved even closer and hovered over her,
thinking to himself that she looked
pretty cute when she was trying to smoke
so ineply, and that was the problem.
Everything Nah Sue did was fine. He
looked at her intently and said in a low
voice, "I'll teach you. Ask me again."
He put the cigarette in her
hand. The girl stood and studied his
face intently.
Nahesu was slightly embarrassed, tucked
a loose curl behind her ear and took a
cigarette into her mouth. He gently
brought the dancing fire to her face.
The girl crouched down. The fire touched
the cigarette. She covered her eyes in
anticipation, but nothing happened. The
girl started mumbling that the cigarette
wasn't
working. Baum Taiha burst into loud,
hearty laughter, even covering his face
with his hand.
Nahu stood there not understanding what
she had done wrong, telling him not to
laugh. The guy slowly took the cigarette
out of her mouth and told her to watch
him closely. The girl stared at him in
shock and embarrassment because he was
about to put her cigarette in his mouth.
Hold it on your mouth and while the
flame is there, take a breath like this.
You need to inhale for it to catch fire.
Bum Taiha clamped the cigarette between
his teeth and covered his eyes. A soft
light illuminated his face. The tip of
the cigarette lit up. The guy exhaled
some smoke and said it wasn't hard. At
this time, all the girl's attention was
fixed on his long fingers and languid
eyes. Jesu was so mesmerized by his
appearance that she didn't immediately
realize she was staring at him, her
cheeks blushing slightly. At this
moment, he looked very seductive, and
she couldn't take her eyes off his lazy
but confident movements. The girl
realized, lowered her head, and tried to
cover her burning face with her hand.
She stammered and told him not to do it
again because he looked like a
delinquent. Bomb Taiha laughed low and
said he wouldn't. He thought to himself
that she had it written all over her
face. Nahu took out a new cigarette and
decided to try again. She thought back
to what the guy had told her. The girl
immediately coughed, her eyes watering.
She started wailing about how anyone
could smoke at all. Bom Taiha stood
beside her and patted her on the back.
He took the cigarette from her and told
her she should stop. The girl tried to
protest saying that she was sorry for
the money spent to which the guy said
that her health was more
important. The guy said that she should
not force herself to do harmful and
unpleasant things just because she is
sorry. He asked if there was anything
else they could do and approached her.
He wrapped his arm around her hand with
his and reached for a pack of
cigarettes, wanting to throw them away.
His fingers traveled down her. He
pressed the girl against the wall, their
noses almost touching. He could feel her
breathing hard, her chest heaving as she
pressed against him. "There are many
better things than cigarettes."
Nahesu's heart was pounding frantically.
She felt that she had nowhere to run.
The memories of his confession from the
hospital came to mind and for a second
she wanted to give in to temptation. But
then she restrained herself, cursing
herself for thinking such a stupid
thing. The girl came to her senses and
uttered, "Stop saying weird things with
that face. Do you think I am 19-year-old
girl who would feel my heart flutter for
a young kid who looks like he has a lot
going on?" She yanked her hand away from
his. Bomb Taiha pulled back a little and
said bitterly that in that case he
wished she was 19 so he could make her
heart flutter. When Nahu heard this, she
told him to find a young girl, to which
he flatly refused. The girl got
uncomfortable and said that if he didn't
like 19year-olds, he could find a
20-year-old girl. The guy hovered over
her again and said he preferred older
women. She looked up at him. He was
standing too close and the conversation
was taking too dangerous a path.
She couldn't find any more
excuses. The sudden tension was
interrupted by the ringing of the phone.
Nahu managed to notice Dohi's name on
the screen before the guy dropped the
call. She remembered the girl and
thought that since she called the guy so
often, maybe there was something going
on between them. She felt uncomfortable
and asked if he had accidentally dropped
her call. Bam. Taiha rested his hand on
the wall behind the girl and brought his
face close to hers. He looked her
straight in the eye and said that he had
done it on purpose. The guy was a few
centimeters from her lips again and
exhaled. I'm with someone I
like, so I don't want to be disturbed.
His gaze was full of tenderness and
hunger at the same time. She couldn't
resist him. The girl realized that he
had left her no avenues of retreat. A
little more, and all her resolve would
surely crumble. Nahesu frantically
started jibbering, asking why he even
liked her. After all, she was married
and almost had a child. Bamha looked at
her carefully and calmly replied that
none of this was important to him. He
said that people often called him a
dirty rag. The girl stood in
embarrassment, asked if it was true. The
guy smiled slightly and asked her what
she thought, to which she replied that
he did look a bit promiscuous.
H, that's a bit unfair. The young man
still smirked and ran his fingers over
his lips. At that moment, he looked very
attractive.
I'm more innocent than you might think.
He looked at the girl again with a
serious gaze. Suddenly, he jerked
forward and pressed himself against the
girl with his whole body. He leaned in
close to her ear and said, "But if
that's the kind of man you like, I'll
come to you. Even I get worn out."
A group of young people were having fun
at a restaurant. Dongwuk stared at the
door, still waiting for Dohi to return.
At that time, their friends started
discussing that the girl had left as
soon as she realized that Bomb Taiha
wouldn't be with them today. The girls
judged her for chasing after him and
eventually being rejected. He always was
especially nice to her, but probably
because she was prettier than the
others.
Dongwuk was slowly becoming furious as
he listened to how much dirt they were
talking about Duhiji and
Biamonta. They were saying that he
probably slept with a lot of girls while
pretending to be a nice guy. The guy
dropped his beer glass on the table with
a clatter and growled for them to shut
up. He said they're [__] and talked
trash about their friends. As he left,
he told them that none of them had the
courage to say it to their faces. But
behind their backs, they weren't afraid
to yell at the top of their lungs.
Duhiji stood around the corner and
smoked. The girl was staring tirelessly
at her phone. Dongwuk came up to her and
said he was worried that she was
standing outside for so long because she
might freeze. He noticed the phone in
her hands and asked if she was still
sending messages that she wouldn't get a
reply to. The girl was indifferent to
him, kept texting and asked him what he
meant. The guy said he was just sorry to
see her ignored, to which the girl
replied that what happens to her is none
of his business.
Dongwuk was offended and blurted out
that he knew everything. He knows why
Biam Taiha was especially nice to her.
The girl looked up at him. Chapter 23.
Dongwuk looked at the girl and asked
with a sneer if she had any pride at all
and why she was clinging to a man who
didn't care about her. Duhiji got mad
and told the guy to stop acting like a
jackass and stop talking about what he
didn't know about. The guy replied that
she was the only one here who was acting
like a fool, always chasing after Baum
Taiha and ruining everyone's mood with
her behavior. He admitted that he didn't
like Bum Taiha from the first time he
met him. Even though he was older than
Dong Wuk, he always asked to treat him
informally as a friend, but it wasn't
because he was so friendly. It was
because he didn't care about people like
them, so he didn't care how they treated
him. Even though Baum Taiha tried to
seem nice, the guy often noticed that he
had a creepy look in his eyes. Dongwuk
started shouting that all the girls look
at Bayum Taiha and see that he is
intelligent and seems more mature with a
special aura, but in reality, he is just
a man like the others, just a little
older than his friends. The guy was
yelling that he's just as good as him.
The girl listened to him silently and
then said with disdain that he was just
a pathetic bastard. When the guy heard
that, he pushed the girl back against
the wall and told her not to call him
names. But Hiji said that he was a total
jerk. And the young man gritted his
teeth and said that Beum Tha is a total
jerk. He continued to hold the girl and
said he knew why Bum Taiha treated her
better than the others because her
brother is disabled and she takes care
of him in her spare time while her
parents work to pay the hospital bills.
He just pies her for her attachment to
her sick brother who can't even go to
school. Because he's a dumbass who
didn't go to school for a long time
because he's a sick
bastard. Suddenly, Hiji interrupted the
guy's tirade with a ringing slap. The
girl was very angry and told the guy to
shut his filthy mouth and called him a
bastard. Dongwuk swung around in a fit
of rage and was about to hit the girl,
yelling at her for daring to hit him.
Then he stopped, exhaled, and said that
even if he hit her, it wouldn't change
anything. He said he wasn't going to
waste his time on someone like her. The
guy took out a cigarette and lit it,
muttering that if he ever decided to
take care of her again, he'd be a dog
instead of a man. Suddenly, a tall, dark
figure appeared behind him. Biamha put
one hand on the guy's shoulder and took
the cigarette out of his mouth with the
other. He grinned and asked why the guy
was smoking in the street. He looked
like a delinquent. He looked at the guy
expectantly. Dongwuk noticed that he was
looking at him with that same creepy
gaze. Bum Taiha said suspiciously calmly
that there were no ashtrays around and
lowered his hand with the
cigarette. After a moment, Dongwuk felt
a burning sensation on his wrist. This
psycho put out the cigarette on his
hand. While the guy bent in half and
screamed in pain, his friend looked down
at him and said that whoever was smoking
should put out the cigarette. He looked
at him like he was dirt, his eyes full
of ice. Duhiji stared at the guy in
bewilderment. He walked past her as if
nothing had happened. The girl started
to call out to him, but the guy kept
walking without turning around. Then she
shouted at him not to ignore her and to
stop. She demanded that he tell her if
he had a girlfriend. There was anger and
resentment in her eyes. Baom Taiha
smirked and answered in the affirmative.
He said he had someone he really liked a
lot. So he asked the girl not to try to
contact him again from now on, turned
around and walked away. Nahesu was about
to go to bed when she pulled out her
phone and decided to text
Bomha. A guy was walking down the street
when he heard a text message
notification. He stopped and looked at
his phone. Nahu texted him that she
would believe him that he doesn't smoke
and asked him not to do it anymore. Byam
smirked after reading it. He was amused
by her naivity. He texted her back that
he promised not to do it again and
contentedly went on his way. The next
day, Nahu was picking a bouquet of
flowers to order while Hua Jang was
looking at her intently and then
suddenly said that she had long wanted
to ask what kind of relationship the
girl had with the handsome rose
customer. She noticed that lately he'd
been picking the girl up from work
almost every day, and when she was sick,
he'd even filled in for her. Nah, Su was
staring at her coworker in shock. Wajang
suddenly felt a sense of jealousy. She
asked Jesu if he really feels sympathy
for her. Maybe he doesn't know that the
girl is married. Nahu blushed and tried
to make a joke, saying there was no
chance he could like her. Jung became
serious and said that she was just
kidding. She doesn't really think that
that guy could like Ha. It's not
possible. She reasoned that even though
Jesu is very cute and looks younger than
her years, there's still a big age
difference between her and this guy. Why
would he want her when there are plenty
of younger girls around? The girl
assumed that they were connected by some
old hidden history like in Dramamas, as
if she had saved his life a long time
ago. And she laughed. Anyway, the world
has changed and their relationship is
not possible because now even love at
first sight is possible only between
people of the same level. While Hua Jang
argued about the impossibility of such a
relationship, Biam Taiha looked at the
pack of cigarettes taken from Nahu and
reminisced about her. Later at her
second job, Nahu couldn't get the girl's
words out of her head. She was thinking
about that. At one point, she even felt
sad. Had she really thought too much? A
colleague pulled her out of her thoughts
and said that an acquaintance had come
to see her. Nahisu looked out the window
and saw Biamha sitting on a motorcycle.
He caught her gaze so hopefully that the
girl thought he looked like a puppy that
had finally found its owner. The woman
told her to hurry up and go to him. Jesu
was embarrassed and asked if she could
take off work for a while, to which the
colleague said she would be happy to
fill in for her without a problem. The
girl hurriedly got out. The young man
leaned loosely against the motorcycle
and looked straight at her. "Hello,
auntie." By Taiha said hello to her and
smiled. The girl asked him why he had
come and he said he was just passing
through on business and wanted to see
her. Nahu remembered that he was working
late and asked him if he was hungry. He
said he had eaten dinner earlier. The
girl thought that he would probably be
hungry after work. She suddenly turned
around and asked him to wait for her for
a while. The guy stared at her in
surprise, not sure what she was up to.
The girl ran into the restaurant counter
and got her hands full of candy. She
turned back to the young man and held
out her hands. He was surprised and
smiled and asked why she was giving him
candy. The girl said that it's nothing
special, but it helps a bit when he's
having a tough time. He was very touched
and pleased by her concern. Biamha
smirked slightly and raised his hands,
showing them to the girl. You're wearing
gloves. It's fine. Don't take them off.
I'll feed you. Nahu unwrapped the candy
and thought that Hua Jong was probably
right. It's impossible to fall in love
with someone you're not on the same
level as. Biam Taiha looked at the girl
in anticipation. He didn't think she
would offer to feed him. The girl
continued to think that this guy with a
kind look and infinitely warm heart most
likely has not romantic feelings for
her, but interest or perhaps even pity,
especially after all he had seen. She
held out the candy straight to his
mouth. The guy froze for a moment and
then exhaled, feeling a rush of arousal.
He opened his mouth and without taking
his gaze from the girl's eyes, ducked
down and lightly bit into the candy
along with her fingertips.
Nahisu was confused and blushed
slightly. She didn't expect it to be so
embarrassing, and the feeling of his
teeth sliding lightly across her fingers
made her heartbeat faster. The guy
noticed her reaction, and it amused him.
He picked up the candy and ran the tip
of his tongue over her fingers, licking
them. He liked embarrassing her. Nahu
felt his wet tongue on her fingers and
was even more embarrassed. Her mind
started to think of different things.
Beaom Taiha was in no hurry to let her
go, still staring into her eyes, and the
sight of him excited the girl's
imagination even more than the last time
he'd taught her how to light a
cigarette. As her heart pounded
frantically, and inexplicable pleasure
flowed through her veins, her mind
frantically tried to find an explanation
for what was happening. Chapter 24.
Nahesu was sleeping very restlessly. She
had a nightmare about Mchel cheating on
her. At the same time, the girl felt the
bitterness of betrayal and tears began
to well up in her eyes. Suddenly, a male
silhouette appeared behind her back. The
young man reached out with his hand and
stroked her cheek. He gently wiped away
a tear and the girl opened her eyes. She
felt the warmth of his body behind her
and his gentle hands. The girl wondered
if it was Kang Mitchell who had come
home. She was confused, called his name,
and tried to turn around.
Suddenly, the guy exhaled and covered
the girl's eyes with his big cool palm.
She sighed and shuddered in surprise.
"Who would have thought I'd be doing
this with you?" When he touched her, the
girl felt like she'd been electrocuted.
She recognized the voice. At this time,
the guy, satisfied with her confusion,
bit her ear and exhaled
heavily. And then he began to descend,
kissing her neck gently.
She was very much aroused and
embarrassed, took the guy's hand off her
face, and couldn't believe to the end
that all this was actually happening.
Nahu took the guy's hand and saw a
familiar tattoo on his wrist. The girl
slowly turned her face, flaming with
embarrassment towards the one she
already knew she would see. Bye's face
was right in front of her. He was
looking at her with insanely excited
eyes and a sly smirk playing on his
lips. Suddenly, Nahu woke up breathing
heavily and feeling
dissatisfied. She got up and looked
around, but there was no one in the
room. She tried to catch her breath and
wondered what the hell had just
happened. Had she just fantasized about
Baum Taiha? Was she crazy just because
of what he did the other day? The memory
of him holding her fingers in his mouth
came to mind. The girl thought it was
his fault, too, for it was he who had
behaved so promiscuously.
Do young people nowadays behave so
frankly with each other? She pulled her
legs up to her and rested her head on
her knees. She thought about the fact
that he was so open about liking
aunties. Anyway, now is not the time to
blame him for his behavior. Maybe it's
because she hasn't done it in a long
time. After all, she and Mitchell hadn't
been intimate for a long time before
they broke up. Nahu remembered making up
pathetic excuses not to do it. She even
wished Mitchell would leave her alone
and not bother her. Though what could be
worse than waking up in tears and
sweat. She thought of Baum Taiha, a
strange guy, either promiscuous or
innocent, who behaves recklessly and
doesn't give a girl time to grieve. She
was embarrassed by her thoughts again
and thought about the fact that this guy
wouldn't let her rest day or night.
Nahesu's coworker was about to go home
after a hard shift and was thinking of
buying a bottle of beer as a reward for
a job well done. Suddenly, she saw
outside the window the guy who had been
coming for her coworker everyday lately.
The young man stood in the street with
his head down and his hands in his
pockets. She wondered if he was too lazy
to wait for Nah Su in the cold everyday.
The woman turned to Nah Su and told her
that her acquaintance was waiting for
her again, asking if he would come
everyday from now on. The girl was about
to go home, too. She replied that it is
not safe to walk alone in the
neighborhood in the evenings as there
are a lot of entertainment districts and
suspicious people around the area. The
girl calmly walked past her coworker and
added that this guy is afraid to walk
alone in the dark. The woman was left
standing there in a stouper, not
realizing what was happening. She
thought it was the guy who was afraid
for Jesus safety, not the other way
around. She thought they were a very
strange couple. Nahu walked out to
Biamha and said hello. The guy smiled
and said he was looking forward to
seeing her. Suddenly, he held out his
hand to her in
anticipation. The girl looked at it and
asked what happened and why did he
extend his hand. He looked at her
slightly and without lowering his hand
replied, "Actually, I had really, really
scary dream last night." "So, let's hold
hands and go like this," he said and
opened his palm. "Nahu was confused. In
light of recent events, she had made the
decision to keep her distance with him,
and now she didn't know how she should
proceed. Suddenly, she remembered her
dream from last night and the feelings
she had experienced. It was wrong. She
was afraid of her own feelings. Biama
continued to stand there and smirked. He
was sure the girl wouldn't be able to
refuse him. Nahu shuddered. She pulled
herself together and walked resolutely
forward past the guy. He remained
standing stunned and confused with the
offered palm of his hand. And then he
heard, "Don't come too close. Stay a bit
further away." By Taiha was surprised.
He thought that she was clearly acting
strange today. He asked why she wouldn't
let him walk beside her since he had a
really scary dream last night and is
still afraid to walk late
alone. The girl walked calmly, trying to
walk ahead of him and answered that that
was why she was with him now. Bontea
took a closer look at her. He felt like
the girl was trying to hide something,
acting too
suspiciously. He noticed that the girl's
ears were reening. Was she embarrassed?
It felt good, even though he didn't want
to embarrass her. He came up behind her
and said he would go behind her back,
but asked her to hold his hand anyway.
Nahu felt the young man lightly touch
her pinky finger. She looked at their
hands, and all her resolve to keep her
distance crumbled. She couldn't resist
him. "Forget it. Come here. Just walk
next to me." Biamjo was surprised and
overjoyed. Suddenly, he realized that
the girl had feelings for him after all.
Nahu took his hand and asked him if he
was afraid now. The guy smiled broadly
and said that he felt good now. She
scolded him for being afraid of
nightmares for such a grown-up guy. The
young people were walking down the
street holding hands and suddenly Bjumha
asked if she thought it was colder than
usual today. The girl asked if he asked
that question to change the subject
because he was embarrassed. to which the
guy laughed and said she got him. The
young man watched the girl's
embarrassment and was very pleased with
himself. He made sure she wasn't
blushing from the cold, which meant that
the girl had another reason for it, and
that was enough for him for now. The
chairman stood in front of the panoramic
window in his office and looked out over
the city at night. One of his bodyguards
came up bowing and reported that the
chairman's eldest son had landed safely
in Korea. The man's face expressed
nothing. His thoughts were occupied with
the fact that they were now going to
have a family reunion. A young man in a
dapper shirt and with a lanky gate
walked out of the airport. He
immediately started wailing about how it
was the first time he had flown to Korea
in a long time and it was too cold and
he immediately wanted to fly back. He
took off his glasses and saw the
bodyguard and said with the sneer that
it looked like his father, the chairman,
would live longer than he did and that
he had nothing to worry about.
Then he asked how his brother was doing.
The bodyguard asked if the young master
was really interested, to which he only
waved it off. The young man smiled evily
and replied that except for his
obituary, he wasn't interested in any
news related to the damn bastard.
Chapter 25. The young man smirked and
said he wasn't interested in any news
about Biamha unless he was dead. The
bodyguard said his brother was dead. The
guy smirked again and asked if Bam Tai
had asked him to say so, to which the
man replied in the
affirmative. The young man rubbed his
neck tiredly and said there was no
chance of his brother being dead. He
pointed out that the guy had become
quite insolent during his absence and
that no matter how much he wanted him to
die, his brother clung stubbornly to
life all the time. His gaze turned cold
and he said he just wouldn't let him die
in peace. In the guy's mind, a memory
surfaced of the little battered Baom
Taiha, who continued to look at everyone
with defiance no matter what. He vowed
to make sure that bastard suffered.
Pushing the unpleasant thoughts away,
the guy said he wanted to go to a hotel
and get some sleep. The bodyguard asked
him if he was going to go to his
parents' house, to which he replied that
he would not be able to rest there. The
young man, out of habit, reached out to
hug someone and realized that there was
nothing around him. Then he waved to his
bodyguard and told him to take him to a
place where he could relax with the
women. Bomaya slept very restlessly. He
was having nightmares again. Sweat began
to trickle down his face from the
exertion. In the dream, he was again
lying beaten on the floor. Again, the
same tall figure towered over him. And
though he was a child, beaten bloody,
his eyes burned with hatred. Despite the
restraining terror, Beaum Taiha slowly
woke up. This dream haunted him, so he
calmly opened his eyes. Head aching from
lack of sleep, the guy sat up on the
bed. He ran a hand over his head,
ruffling his hair, and exhaled
heavily. Suddenly, he heard a strange
noise in the flat. Li Jay sneaked into
Baum Taiha's apartment and looked
around. On a small table was a packet of
cigarettes that the guy doesn't even
smoke, a cheap lighter, and an empty
pack of band-aids.
And even though they were perfectly
ordinary things, they didn't fit in here
in any way. He bent down to get a better
look, and his instincts told him that
that woman might have made a huge
mistake in getting involved with Bam
Taiha. Suddenly, a chill ran down Li's
back. He froze and turned his head to
the side. The owner of the apartment
stood silently towering over him. Byte
looked at the bodyguard carefully and
said hello.
The man was surprised that the guy was
awake and asked how he knew he was here.
Ljay was sure he was acting quietly like
a ghost. The young man replied
cryptically. Something about scattered
rose petals. The man stared at him and
thought he was really crazy. Bamha
turned round and asked what was wrong.
The man replied that he had come to tell
him that his older brother just arrived
in the country, but he wasn't sure if he
should wake him up for that information.
The guy took a bottle of water and
muttered that he wasn't surprised now
why he was having nightmares again. He
looked at the bodyguard carefully and
asked if it was such an urgent matter
that he had to barge into his house. Li
Jay smiled awkwardly and replied that he
thought the young master seemed
concerned about his brother's arrival.
So, he thought he would be interested to
hear about his arrival right away. Bum
Taiha approached him and told him to
relax. He did the right thing. That's
why he trusted him with the password to
the house.
He patted the man on the shoulder, him
and said he would rely on him that way
in the future. Li Jay breathed a sigh of
relief. Nahu finally started waking up a
little later than usual. Since Mitchell
is no longer around, she doesn't need to
diligently prepare breakfast early in
the morning. Her daily expenses have
also decreased. Although she still had a
mountain of debt, Mitchell's big hands
weren't around to constantly take her
pocket money. The wounds left by his
betrayal no longer achd so often.
Instead, she has a smile on her face
more often and thus reassures herself
that she is doing well. But sometimes
her heart suddenly bursts out of her
chest and tears gather in her eyes. In
13 years, every moment she have lived
and every breath she have taken reminds
her of Mitchell. In the Heisu's world, a
part of her world has been emptied out
that took up more space than she did.
The girl pondered if she would ever be
able to fill that void. Would she ever
be able to forget Kang Mchel? Sometimes
Nahes Su thought that it would be better
if he physically harmed her because that
way the wounds would definitely heal in
time. And while Mchel was enjoying life
with Ahri, the girl wondered if the
wounds he had inflicted would continue
to bleed for the rest of her life.
Suddenly, her attention was caught by a
teddy bear that was displayed in the
window of a toy shop. Recently, Nahisu
has reduced her spendings, and perhaps
because of this, a girl who would never
spend an extra penny made an impulsive
purchase. She bought a teddy bear for a
certain boy who has
nightmares. The girl remembered how
recently her work colleague was
embroidering a heart on a soft toy and
told her about one
omen. She said that if you embroider a
heart on the toy with which the child
sleeps, it will have a soul and it will
protect the child in sleep and ward off
nightmares. Baam Taiha came to meet
Nahauai Su from work as usual. The girl
looked at him and wondered if it would
be too childish to give him a teddy
bear. Still, she thought that she wanted
to please him. She imagined how she
would give him the teddy bear and how
cute he would look cuddling it. She
hoped with all her heart that it would
help him get rid of his nightmares. Baam
Taiha noticed the girl smiling sweetly
and asked her what she was thinking
about. She looked so happy that he
smiled. The girl smiled even more and
said it was nothing special. Suddenly,
the guy asked if she was busy this
evening. Nah, Su thought about it. She
was planning to start embroidering a
teddy bear tonight. She had a lot of
free time lately, and for some reason,
she didn't want to say no to Bea Ta.
Lately, she'd been enjoying spending
time with him more and more. "No, I'm
not busy," she said, and the guy smiled
happily. "Then please spend some time
with me." Suddenly, Bomb Taiha put his
helmet on her head. The girl stared at
him, not knowing what was going on. She
just wanted to ask him what he was up
to. Nah Su then felt the guy's arms
around her, and she ended up on his
shoulder. Hanging her head down, the
girl started to resent him, asking what
he was up to. Bum Taiha took her
comfortably and said with a smirk, "I
want to steal you away."
She was so petite and fit so naturally
on his shoulders that the guy felt joy
and mischief spill into his chest. The
girl hanging from his shoulder grumbled
that he looked like a mountain tiger.
Bum Taiha grinned
contentedly. There was a sepul silence
in the flat. Suddenly, light inaudible
footsteps crossed the
threshold. Lie Jay crept into the flat
like a ghost and started looking around.
Chapter 26. The roar of the motorbike
subsided and Biam Taiha put it on the
foot plate. He carefully removed the
helmet from Nahu's head. The girl
exhaled a sigh of relief. This is the
place, the one I wanted to come to with
you. Bomb Taiha brought her to the place
he comes to when his head gets too full
of thoughts. The girl stared in surprise
at this view. The guy was only looking
at her and his mind was racing with
thoughts of what Nahu's house feels
unusually close to the moon. even for
such a
neighborhood. At night, the entire
cityscape of Soul's lights could be
visible from below. He admired the way
the girl was mesmerized by the lights of
the night city and how the thousands of
small lights reflected in her burning
eyes. He knew that when Nahu was
returning home tired after work, the
thought of turning her head and looking
at the lights around her didn't even
cross her mind. So now he was admiring
the way she was enjoying what she was
seeing.
To think that I've lived this long
without knowing that the city I live in
is this beautiful," said the girl with a
mixture of bitterness and joy. Bomha
suddenly asked if there was something
she wanted to say. The girl didn't quite
know what he meant. Then the guy
explained that if she had any emotions
she wanted to vent, she could shout them
out right now since there was no one
else around but them. The wind ruffled
his hair, making him even more
attractive. The guy just said, "Shout
and let it all out until you feel
refreshed, whatever it may be." His
words echoed in her soul. Nahisu grabbed
the railing and sucked in a lungful of
air. She put her hands together and
started screaming as hard as she could
that Mitchell was a bastard. And every
time the wind carried her words away,
she felt joy and relief in her soul.
Felt the wound in her chest heal more
and more. Baam Taiha watched her with
pleasure. Tears welled up in the girl's
eyes, but she continued to scream that
the bastard could enjoy his life without
her. The girl screamed that she didn't
love him anymore, and even if he later
regretted what he had done, she would
never forgive him or accept him back.
Biamha stood silently watching her. He
waited patiently for the girl to let go
of all that had accumulated in her soul.
When Nahu finally finished, he gently
embraced her and asked if she was
relieved, to which the girl calmly and
evenly replied in the
affirmative. Baom Taiha inquired if she
had said everything she wanted to say.
The girl, feeling his big warm hand on
her back, was silent for a while and
then said she wasn't finished yet.
"Thank you." Her voice rang out and the
guy froze in surprise. She said it so
suddenly. It was the first time in his
life that anyone had ever treated him so
sincerely. Nahu looked at him with eyes
full of warmth and repeated again. Thank
you, Biamha.
Biamha looked carefully into the girl's
eyes and didn't understand how every
time without even realizing it when he
was about to get upset, she managed to
understand it. The fact that she was so
attentive to him made him feel worse
about himself. He started to take off
his jacket and thought that he was not a
nice guy at all. And every time she was
so sincere and innocent with him, he
felt guilty in front of her. The guy
gently wrapped her in his jacket to keep
her warm and then said quietly, "Do you
know what goes on in my head when I hear
something like that from someone I
like?" Nahisu continued to look at him
and asked what he was thinking about.
Bum Taiha took her in his arms and
enclosed her in his embrace so quickly
that the girl had no time to object.
Their faces were very close together.
The girl stared unblinkingly into his
eyes, felt his strong hands and warm
body. Her heart began to beat a crazy
rhythm. Biamha held her tightly, but at
the same time tenderly, feeling how warm
and soft she was. He liked to feel her
in his
arms. He grinned playfully and said,
"Indecent thoughts." He headed with the
girl in his arms towards the motorbike.
Nahu put her arms around his neck and
blushed, asking him what he meant. The
guy smirked and continued to flirt and
asked her if she wanted him to tell her
everything in detail from start to
finish. He put her on the motorcycle and
said with a laugh that she turned red
from embarrassment. The girl was
indignant and said that it was because
of the cold. Continuing to grin, the guy
said that they were leaving and he would
take her home. Jesu felt embarrassed by
his ambiguous phrases. So when he got
behind the wheel, she felt embarrassed
to hold on to him tightly. It's going to
be dangerous, so hang on tighter than
you did before. Baam Tai's voice came
from under his helmet. When he felt the
girl hugging him tightly around the
waist, he contentedly pressed the
ignition button. They were traveling
along the night road at quite a high
speed, and Nahi Su clung to him tighter
and tighter. The noise of the engine and
the monotony of the motorbike's movement
soothed the girl.
She thought that Baum Taiha was really
unusual. With a broad back shaped by
hardships, she wanted to embrace those
shoulders which have been burdened by
the world's pain in a more mature
way. But instead, she ended up leaning
on him. Never had she felt so serene and
safe as she did now in this guy's arms.
Nahesu closed her eyes, pressed herself
against him, and exhaled with relief,
savoring the moment. Once inside the
young master's flat, Li Jay thought that
chairman Biam Téju was not a man to be
disobeyed. When he first heard the
chairman say that he needed to keep an
eye on Biam Tahha and report any
suspicious behavior, the man thought it
was rather ironic that such a powerful
man still felt the need to control his
son. So he thought he would do his job
quickly and easily enough, tell about
the ridiculous antics of the Chiball
air, and get a tidy sum for it. In the
end, he'd rather deal with a spoiled
brat than such a madman. There's
something strange about this guy. His
actions are sometimes so bizarre, it's
hard to ignore your
intuition. Lie Jay was sure that if he
had reported the young master's affairs
to the chairman, he probably wouldn't
have died a peaceful death. He didn't
know whose orders to obey now, caught
between father and son. Lie Jay made
sure that Biamha didn't realize that he
was observing him on the chairman's
orders. So, he had to be careful. The
man left the apartment as quietly as he
came in. When Nahesu returned home, she
started carefully embroidered a heart on
the teddy bear's chest. With each seam,
his heart filled, and the girl felt that
Biamha's presence in her life was
mending her wounds like a torn doll.
With careful seams, step by step, her
wounds were being mended by his caring
hands. And even though she felt like a
broken toy, the fact that it was
important and dear to him to keep her
safe warmed her heart and soul.
Finished, the girl lifted the teddy bear
to examine her work. She was very proud
of herself. Looking at it, she marveled
at how just one needle and some thread
could bring so much joy. Jesu thought it
was very cute and afraid that she might
get it dirty carrying it around with
her. She decided to invite Biamha to her
house tomorrow after work and give it to
him as a present. The girl admired the
teddy bear, sighed, and thought she
hoped the guy would like it.
Mitchell was lying in bed with Ari
sleeping, thinking that it had been
several days since he had left home. And
Nahu still hadn't called him once.
Honestly, he was hoping she'd run after
him right away. She couldn't help but
worry about him because she'd always
cared about him, even if her anger
hadn't cooled off yet. Nah, Sue was all
about that. She was always concerned
about where he was, whether he had
eaten, how he was feeling. It was like
it was second nature to her. Mchel
thought about how he couldn't wear the
same things indefinitely. Ari keeps
nagging him and insisting to replace it,
but not to go back to that house. The
man reasoned that she was very wasteful
compared to Nahau, perhaps due to her
youth. His ex-wife was always mending
clothes and wearing them. He decided
that he would go home tomorrow to get
his things and see how Nahu was doing.
The next day, much dismay, Biamha sent a
text message apologizing for not being
able to meet the girl after work. Nahu
was upset, feeling silly because she had
hoped to meet him all day long. She
texted him back that everything was fine
and said she was looking forward to
seeing him another day. The girl was so
used to seeing him everyday that it had
become a habit for her. After all, he
had his own life, so there would be days
when he couldn't come. So, she reassured
herself. On the way home, Nahu realized
that this was the first time the guy had
texted her that he couldn't meet her.
She was worried that something bad had
happened to him. At this time, Baum
Taiha, accompanied by Li Jay, arrived at
the meeting place. He was sure it was
going to be an interesting evening. And
on the other side of town, Mchel came
confidently to there with Nahu's shabby
apartment.
The man smirked and thought about how
happy the girl would be to see him and
most likely he would be able to play on
her feelings again. Chapter 27. Mchel
cautiously opened the door and saw what
he expected to see. He was even relieved
that nothing had changed since the night
he'd left. Even though it was clean
inside, his and Nahu's flat was still
shady. While the man was not at home,
the girl continued to live in this flat.
It seemed a matter of course.
Suddenly, his gaze fell on a table in
the middle of the room. Menchel picked
up the teddy bear and looked at it. He
never thought that Nah Su liked stuffed
animals. Then the man laughed, thinking
that apparently the girl missed him so
much that she bought herself a toy to
cuddle with. He thought it was kind of
cute. He threw the toy back and smuggly
thought she should have appreciated him
while he was around.
The man then headed to the wardrobe to
retrieve some of his clothes, rather
noting that Nah Su had washed them and
folded them up. Biamha, accompanied by
Lie J, arrived at the family dinner. His
older brother stood on the top floor,
sipping wine and watching his brother. A
nasty grin appeared on his handsome
face. He tossed the crystal glass and
looked down
carelessly. The glass flew a centimeter
from Biam Taiha's face and shattered
right at his feet. The guy looked up at
his brother
nonchalantly. Bum Taihi looked at his
brother mockingly and asked how he was
doing. He wasn't happy that his little
brother didn't greet him properly,
started saying nasty things right away.
Then he noticed that Baum Taiha had
grown even taller since their last
meeting, and he had chosen a bodyguard
to match. The young man started talking
in a mocking manner about how the
younger brother should have his legs cut
so he could look his elders in the eye.
Beum Tha looked down at him and replied
that perhaps it was his brother who
should grow up. Beumhi got angry while
the young man innocently continued to
ask why his older brother never grew
taller again. He reminded his brother
how he suffered with leg pains and cried
every day. Bamha grinned contentedly and
asked with fained sympathy, "Do you
still cry every night?"
No sooner had the older brother swung
his arm than he was immediately caught
and immobilized by Li. Bomi brought his
face close to his brothers and spat out
not to be happy for long. He promised to
get to him and finish him off just like
his mother. The guy looked at his older
brother calmly and replied that he would
look forward to it. Suddenly, one of the
bodyguards announced that the chairman
had arrived. Lij removed his hands and
released the elder master. Bam. He
turned to him and said that he will
remember his face and that he had better
look around on his way home at night.
Bombaya smilingly put his hand on
Lijay's shoulder and said that he had to
be careful now because his older brother
was very vindictive. It sounded like a
mockery. Soon the three men were seated
at a large, beautifully set table. The
elder brother was silently and
thoughtfully picking at his plate when
the chairman's voice rang out. The man
wanted to know who a girl named Melissa
was. The guy got nervous and said it was
just a crazy girl from the other side of
the world. Asked why her father was
interested in her. The chairman didn't
like that answer. And although he was
calm on the outside, one look at him was
enough to realize he was not to be
trifled with. Bomb he got even more
nervous and blurted out that he had
nothing to do with her child, that it
was just a crazy girl who wanted to get
her hands on his money. He suggested
that the father bring her to examine on
her. The man continued to stare at his
son as if he were an underdog and
answered nothing. The guy swallowed hard
and grumbling to himself,
apologized. Biama quietly dined as he
listened to his brother apologized to
his father for his indiscreet behavior.
He was about to sip wine from his glass
when the chairman asked what about him.
The man wanted to know if his son had
any problems. The guy remembered Nahesu,
hesitated for a moment, and finally
replied confidently that he was doing
fine and that his father had nothing to
worry about. Back home, Nahesu saw
Mchel's shoes on the doorstep and her
eyes glazed over with rage. She ran into
the house screaming his name. The man,
as if nothing had happened, walked out
of the room holding a bag of belongings.
The girl started shouting at him, asking
him who he thought he was for breaking
into her house.
Mitchell smiled impressively and replied
that the girl had made a very bold
statement. After all, this was their
shared home. Such calm and insolent
behavior infuriated the girl even more,
she thought. Who the hell he thought he
was and answered rudely, no, this is no
longer our house. It's my house." She
jumped on him with fists and screamed at
him, asking how he had the conscience to
come back after seducing a young girl.
Mel intercepted her wrists and squeezed
tightly. He smirked and asked who she
thought was young. Ari was 25 years old
and quite aware of what she was doing.
Nahesu tried to break free from his
steel grip and continued to accuse the
man of being
irresponsible. She shouted that he
should have avoided that girl. Knowing
the situation should have acted like an
adult. Mchel laughed and then brought
his face closer to the girl's face and
Snidly told her to admit that she was
just jealous. There was panic and
incomprehension in the girl's eyes. He
mockingly whispered, "Is she offended
that he cheated on her with a girl 8
years younger than her?" Nahu couldn't
get over the shock of what that man was
saying. Then the man lowered his hand
and squeezed her ass, continuing to ask
maybe she was angry because she missed
him. The girl's body felt like it was
pricricked with needles of disgust. She
looked at her ex-husband and was
convinced that he was a crazy bastard.
She started throwing everything she
could get her hands on at the man with
unbelievable force and screamed at him
to never touch her again and to get out
of her home. Mitchell, pleased with this
reaction, smilingly left the apartment
and said they would see each other
again. He liked the way she was
hysterical and threw her fists at him
like a real bully. He walked out of the
house dancing and humming a little song
to himself.
The man was sure that since she'd left
his things behind, it meant she was
pretending not to be happy to see him.
He was sure she missed him. He could
even breathe easier because he saw
Nahu's rage. She finally looked like a
living person. Nahu stood in the middle
of the apartment and breathed heavily.
Her anger was slowly
subsiding. The girl's body began to
shiver and she weakened and fell to her
knees.
She surprised herself, but the first
thing that came to mind was to pick up
the phone and call a specific person.
Finally, she heard a familiar voice on
the other end of the phone. Bonteha
replied almost
instantly. Hearing the girl's voice, the
guy immediately realized that something
bad had happened. His eyes lit up with
anger and a promise of revenge. Chapter
28. Byam Taiha listened intently to the
girl on the other end of the phone. And
with every word she said, his expression
grew darker and darker, and he was
already halfway to her. Finished
speaking, the guy exhaled heavily. He'd
expected something like this from her
stupid ex-husband. He'd even considered
killing him. Lie Jay caught the young
master's attention with his cheerful
appearance. He asked him if he wanted
him to stay with him today and help him
bury someone's body. Bomha looked at him
thoughtfully and then smirked and calmly
replied that it wasn't necessary for
now. He thought about the fact that it
wasn't time yet. He's going to let that
bastard enjoy his supposed victory and
then he'll make sure his end is as
miserable as
possible. Thinking about it, the guy
stared out the car window in cold blood.
Biamonte he had too much alcohol at
dinner and tried to clean himself up in
the bathroom. The bodyguard asked if he
was all right, to which the young man
snapped and said that nothing was all
right, that the dinner had been so awful
that he didn't know whether he wanted to
eat or vomit more. The guy stared at
himself in the mirror and at the memory
of his brother and father. He shook with
anger. He was disgusted at how much Baum
Taiha tried to resemble their father,
his manner of speaking, eating, even his
style of dress, all copied from the
chairman. his cheek muscles flexed. The
bodyguard said the younger master left
recently. Bomb Taihi smiled wickedly and
said that his younger brother had been
doing everything all evening, as if he
was the chairman's only worthy son, and
as if he already had the whole family
under his control. The young man stared
at himself in the mirror with a crazed
look and promised he wouldn't let his
brother just get away with it. Nah Su
stood at the bus stop and looked at the
cars passing by. Absorbed in her
thoughts, she did not immediately notice
the tall figure that appeared beside
her. "I'm sorry. I tried to get here as
quickly as possible. Did you wait long?"
The girl heard a familiar voice and
turned around to meet Biamont Taiha's
gaze. He was standing in front of her,
so dressed up and handsome. She was a
little confused looking at him. She
couldn't even think of what to say at
once. The girl remembered that he had
texted her that he had important things
to do that evening. Maybe he had a job
interview or
something. The guy just smiled with his
head tilted to the side and looked at
her. Nahesu started to apologize for
taking him away from his business, but
the guy just reached out his hand to her
face, wrapped a loose lock of hair
around his finger, and without letting
her finish saying anything, replied that
she wasn't bothering him. Bya looked at
her, still playing with her hair, and
said, "Thank you for contacting me
first."
Still sitting in the car, the guy was
thinking about the fact that it was hard
for him to tell if the girl's trembling
voice made him angry or
hurt. But one thing he knew for sure,
knowing that he was the first person she
was searching for in a difficult
situation, gave him a strange sense of
satisfaction. Nahu looked down tiredly
and said that she had no one she could
turn to, as she had no family or close
friends, and recently no husband either.
After the words about her husband, the
girl looked at the guy and saw that he
was smiling quite a bit. She smiled back
at him and said, "Just be my friend for
today." Baom Taiha looked at her
genuinely pleased that she needed him.
His eyes were filled with care. Then he
moved closer to the girl and asked
conspiratorally, "Do I get nothing in
return?" Nahesu felt awkward at how
close he stood beside her and looked at
her
expectantly. While the girl was
seriously considering how to thank him,
not understanding the guy's ambiguous
hints, Biamha stood like a sly kitten
waiting for
encouragement. Suddenly, the girl
started rumaging around in her coat
pockets. And then she reached out and
put something in the guy's palm and said
in an apologetic tone that it was all
she had. The guy froze in place, looking
at the crumpled notes in his palm. Nahu
apologized for taking up his time and
told him to buy himself something sweet
later. The young man couldn't decide
whether to cry or laugh. He wanted to
flirt with her, but she took it all at
face value. At that moment, he felt
disgusted with himself. The girl had
already managed to get not far away when
Biamha called out to her and said that
she couldn't just leave after she had
just bought it. She stared at him and
wondered what he meant. The guy leaned
towards her with a beaming smile and
replied that she had just bought it for
2001, so she couldn't just leave him
like that. The owner of a roadside food
stall was tiredly stirring her food when
she heard customers coming in. Looking
up, she saw a young pretty girl and
behind her an incredibly handsome man.
The young men greeted her in a friendly
manner. When they went inside, the
shopkeeper said enthusiastically that
they were so beautiful that they looked
like celebrities. Nahesu was a little
embarrassed.
The girl was about to go on in silence,
but the older woman continued to admire
them and saying that they didn't look
like siblings, asked if they were a
couple. The girl was embarrassed and
rushed to object. She said they were
just good
acquaintances. Biamha looked at the girl
thoughtfully. He moved closer to the
girl and put his hand on her shoulder.
The gesture made her cheeks flame and
sent shivers down her spine. She thought
that perhaps her abrupt response had
sounded a little hurtful and ugly to
him. But the guy ducked down to her and
gave her a little hug, smiled at her in
his boyish way, and said to the elderly
lady in a cheeky manner, "I'm in
unrequited love with her, so I'm the one
chasing after her." He said it so
lightly and sincerely that Nahu
immediately blushed with embarrassment.
She could only silently open her mouth
in surprise.
The woman sighed resignedly and said
dreamily that this is the best time of
the
relationship. While Nah Su was
embarrassed and thinking of what to say,
the guy continued to tease her and
smiled sweetly. It was getting dusk
outside and starting to snow lightly.
Young people were spending time in a
small roadside tent. Nahu opened the
bottle of soju and looked at the glass,
thinking about how Kang Minchul always
drank without any snacks when their
lives became especially unbearable. For
13 years, their life had been full of
hardships. And even in moments like
this, the girl kept remembering her
neglectful
husband. She reached for the bottle to
pour herself a glass, but Baum Taiha
reached out and stopped her. He said he
would pour the alcohol for her himself.
"Last time it was cigarettes. Today it's
alcohol," he said as he poured the soju
and sighed heavily. He kept his eyes on
the girl and noticed that last time she
looked as if she was about to cry. But
today she looked only angry. Nahu
confidently took the glass and said that
he himself had told her that there were
many good things in the world. So she
decided to try them. The guy rubbed his
neck with his hand and replied that the
good things he suggested had nothing to
do with what she was doing. When she
grumbled and asked what kind of things
he was talking about, the guy ducked his
head even more, gave her a flirtatious
look, and stopped talking. He wondered
if she was really so naive that she was
completely unaware of his innuendos. "If
you keep asking, I might just want to
tell you." He smirked at her and looked
at her
expectantly. For a moment, their gazes
lingered on each other. The girl even
opened her mouth a little as if she were
about to ask something. The guy kept
looking at her
flirtatiously. Biamha gently moved his
foot so that it touched the girl's
thigh.
Suddenly, the girl looked at him and
said that looking at him, she couldn't
help but think of Kang Mitchell from the
old days. The guy thought for a moment
and then smirked, asking if she meant to
insult him in that way. The girl
laughed. She exhaled tiredly and replied
nostalgically that it sounded like an
insult now, but there had been a time
when things had been different. There
was a time when their days together were
full of a twinkle in their eyes, and
those were wonderful times. Chapter 29.
Nahesu was walking home when a guy came
up to her and said hello. She looked at
him in surprise as he introduced himself
and said he lived not far from her. The
guy said he knew her and even knew where
she lived. The girl did not understand
why he started talking to her. He handed
her a bun and smiled and said he'd
bought it especially for her. The girl
staredly at the bun. Seeing her doubts,
the guy told her not to worry about the
quality of the bun and to eat it in
peace.
Then he walked on, waved goodbye to her
and said they would see each other
later. Nahu was left standing with a bun
in her hands. She actually knew this
boy. He lived on top of a mountain. He
had no parents and his grandmother had
died early. At night, he often spent
time in the company of older boys. They
smoked and drank in dark corners. It
seemed like all the boys and girls knew
him.
And while you'd think he looked like a
real delinquent, he was actually a very
good-natured guy. He often helped
neighbors and had a charming
personality, so many adults had a good
opinion of him. And since he was quite
good-looking, everyone around him
unanimously thought he was a good bloke.
After that time, Mchel began to meet the
girl everyday, and every time he brought
her some kind of treat. Sometimes it was
banana milk, and sometimes it was cup
noodles.
Each time the girl didn't understand why
he was doing all this, why he was paying
attention to her. One day, a guy
couldn't stand it and asked why she
never once asked anything about him.
They've been seeing each other every day
for a month, but she never once asked
him a single question. He held out his
mobile phone to her and asked her to
give him her number. Mhel teased her by
saying that he would cry very loudly if
she turned him down. When he saw that
she was embarrassed, he said that if she
didn't want to, she could refuse him.
Jesu got nervous but replied that she
wanted to give him her number but she
didn't have a phone. The guy was very
surprised. It was strange that someone
was still walking around without a
phone. Mitchell promised himself he'd
make money in a month and give the girl
a phone. He worked long and hard on the
construction site and even borrowed
money from an
acquaintance. And finally after a month
he was able to buy a phone though not
expensive but still a phone. He was very
proud of himself and told the girl that
he wanted to give her something more
expensive, but it was better than
nothing. Nahu was very grateful, but
asked why he did it, and Mitchell said
he wanted to be able to always be in
touch with her. The guy started showing
her how to use the phone and asked her
to write down his number. The girl just
wrote down his name, to which the guy
jokingly took offense. Said it looked
too official. He took the phone and
added a heart emoticon at the end of his
name and asked her not to edit the
contact when she got home. That same
night, Nahu lay curled up in a ball and
tried to drown out the drunken shouting
and swearing by covering her ears. The
phone screen lit up, alerting her to a
text message that had arrived. Mitchell
sent her a smiley face kitty. It looked
so cute, but in this situation, it was
so stupid that the girl cried. There was
no room for anything good in her life up
to that point. So, it was simple things
like this that gave her mixed feelings.
Mitchell's school friends began to
notice that he had become absent- minded
and was often late for lessons. The guy
smuggly stated that the girl he likes
has a class that starts 30 minutes late.
So, even though he gets scolded, he'll
still be late because he has to see her
off. Friends were surprised and asked
what would happen to
Sangmi. The boys stared at them
incomprehensibly and asked who they were
talking about. The guys replied that
there is a girl named Sangmi and
everyone knows that she likes Mchel a
lot. They warned him to be careful
because this girl is very dangerous. She
constantly bullies other girls. But Kang
Mchel said he doesn't care and it's not
his problem. Soon it was time for the
exams. Nahu was very anxious and unsure
of her
abilities. Menchel, on the other hand,
was relaxed. He was mostly hoping for
good luck. Later, sitting on the porch
of the house, the guy asked the girl how
her exams went. But embarrassed, the
girl said it was better he didn't ask.
Laughing and snatching the results sheet
out of her hands, the guy said he wanted
to see. Jesu pounced on him like a
kitten trying to get her papers back.
Looking at her sheet completely crossed
out in red pen, the guy joked that she
didn't have a single correct answer at
all. The girl said that he had probably
failed it himself. The boy handed her
his paper with only a couple of mistakes
on it and asked that she didn't expect
him to be so good at his studies. Nahesu
stared at him in surprise. He really was
very clever and gifted and it made her
feel sorry for him. It was such a shame
that such a gifted boy was growing up
without parents. In addition, his
grandparents also died early and he was
left all alone. It is a pity that none
of his relatives can see how wonderful
he is growing up. She continued to think
that this was a great loss. She was
sorry that such talent was
wasted. Everyone around him thought he
was well-mannered and nice. Said he had
no faults and wished him all the best.
That's what everyone thought of him. But
it was only years later that the girl
realized it was all just pity. Everyone
felt sorry for Kang Mchel. Mchel was
just passing by with his friends when he
noticed Nahu watching him and waved
cheerfully, calling her his wife. His
friends started hooting and patting him
on the shoulder and the guy told them
all to call her their sister-in-law. The
guy started cheerfully greeting her.
Nahu was shocked and burned with shame.
She wasn't even in a relationship with
that guy. She embarrassedly tucked a
loose curl behind her ear and moved on.
The girl was calmly walking down the
street when suddenly someone called out
to her. It was a group of girls. One of
them came forward and asked if she was
Nahai Su. one of Mchel's friends who was
passing by at that moment saw the girls
surround Nahu and take her somewhere
else. The guy found Mchel and asked if
his girlfriend was friends with the
girls from Syangan High School. He was
surprised and said it couldn't be. And
then his friend told him that he saw
them take Nahau somewhere. Mitchell
visibly tensed up and asked where
exactly he had seen them. Chapter 30.
The girls dragged Nahisu into the
washroom, surrounded her and insulted
her, asking her what kind of
relationship she might have with Kang
Mincchel, to which the girl frightenedly
replied that there was nothing between
them. Sangi leaned over to the girl and
said that she would ruin her face so
that she could no longer flirt with
guys. Nahu stared at her in horror,
unable to believe what was happening.
One of the girls was assigned to watch
the entrance so they wouldn't be caught
and punished. She was sure no one would
come in, but suddenly Kang Mchel
appeared at the door. He pushed the door
open with such force that the girl fell
to her knees with her hands covering her
head. The guy pulled Sangmi's arm with
force and shoved her aside. He saw Nah
Su sitting on the floor in the corner.
The girl was covered in abrasions and
her clothes were torn, so she had to
cover her body with her hands. Her eyes
were full of tears. Mchel took off his
shirt and threw it over her shoulders.
He helped her up and said he would walk
her home. Sang me in a rage pulled out a
stationary knife and threatened the guy
that she would finish him off. The guy
grabbed her arm and put the knife to his
throat. He looked at her angrily and
told her to try it. The girl didn't
budge. Late at night, Mitchell was
helping Nahisu get home. Wrapped tightly
in the guy's shirt, the girl wondered
what would happen now. She was worried
that these girls might be plotting
something against him. Menchel hugged
the girl and brightened with a smile,
asking if she really cared that much
about him. Later, the guy had to face a
group of older guys who were sent to him
by those girls. And although he got a
decent beating, he managed to beat them
up, too. Seeing Mchel after the fight,
Nahu was angry and sorry at the same
time. After all, he had promised her he
wouldn't get hurt. The guy stood in
front of her awkwardly rubbing his neck
covered in abrasions. He told the girl
not to worry about him. bragged that he
managed to beat those guys even though
they attacked him at the same time. Then
he froze when he saw Nahau crying with
her fists clenched tightly. He asked her
to calm down, promising that next time
he would fight like crazy and not miss a
beat. He even offered her to hit him if
she wanted to. The guy took her hand,
bringing it to his head, and froze when
he heard the girl ask why he was
treating her so well. Nah, Su stood with
her head down and sniffed her nose as
she continued to ask why he was being so
nice to her. She looked at him and saw
his ears and cheeks reen. He asked
embarrassedly if she didn't realize why.
Nah Jesus saw in front of her the guy
who she knew had stolen girls hearts
more than once, and now he stood
blushing in front of her, his hands
trembling. She reached up and wrapped
her arms around his neck. They were both
immature, but their youth had been full
of rawness and beatings. The girl kissed
him and was ready to burn to ashes in
that vivid raw youth that night. And
after they both burned in that flame,
Mchel disappeared like smoke and Nahu
was left as ashes. Memories consumed the
girl and she drank another shot of
soju. Biamha silently watched her
intently. Jesu asked why he was watching
so intently as if he'd never seen people
drink before. The guy admitted that he
was jealous of her. She sat next to him
and drank, but her thoughts were
occupied with another man. It hurts.
While she held the glass sadly and
silently, the guy thought about whether
he could ever win, what he had to do to
defeat her memories that he could
neither destroy nor
erase. Nahu muttered that he was just a
promiscuous. She said that when he says
things like that with his pretty face,
girls probably fall in love with him
right away. Biamha looked at the girl
carefully and smirked. "You didn't fall
for it." She replied that it was because
she knew everything, but the guy said
that it looked like she didn't know
anything. Nahu told him not to interrupt
the adults, to which the guy laughed and
said he was an adult, too. Then the girl
looked at him and asked, "Honestly, tell
me, how old are you?"
By the Taiha leaned towards the girl,
put his hand on her forearm, and pulled
her closer to him. His breath tickled
her ear, and he whispered softly, "I'm
23." He bit his lower lip, holding back
a laugh, while the girl turned away in
embarrassment and began coughing. Jesu
thought she was going crazy. She, of
course, realized that he was younger
than her. And even though he looked so
damn attractive and was more mature for
his age, he was still 10 years younger
than her. The girl couldn't stop
coughing, so she grabbed a bottle of
soju and drank it straight from her
throat. The guy stared at her in
bewilderment. He propped his head up
with his hand and grinned, saying that
apparently auntie was already drunk. The
girl hiccuped and lowered her head and
mumbled that she wasn't drunk at all.
Seeing that she might fall, Baum Tha
reached out and put her head on his
shoulder. Nahu felt how warm and strong
he was. And when she opened her eyes,
she admitted that no matter how much she
thought of him, he was still too young.
Hearing those words, the guy smiled. On
a drunken head, the girl was saying
funny things. He ducked down to her and
asked, "Aren't you happy to win?" Nahesu
raised an incomprehensible gaze and
their eyes met. The girl blushed at the
sight of his face so close to hers. The
guy kept smiling seductively and said
that her ex was sleeping with a girl 8
years younger than him and he was even
younger than her so she should be happy
about it. The girl continued to drown in
his eyes while Baum Taiha said that she
must be terribly angry at and wanted to
take revenge on her ex-husband.
Then it's okay to use me. The guy
offered her. For a moment, obscene
thoughts flashed through the girl's
mind, but then she froze with shock. The
girl jumped up from her seat and said
she wanted to leave.
She couldn't do that. He was too good a
guy for her. Bam. Taiha walked quietly
behind the girl while she walked along
the road, swaying from side to side.
Noticing that she was off course, the
guy gently took her by the shoulders and
told her that her house was in the other
direction. A slight smile played across
his face. But suddenly, Nah Su clung to
him and rested her head on his chest,
saying she didn't want to go home. The
guy froze. He wrapped his arm around her
waist, holding her up and keeping her
from
falling. She was so warm and
soft. Swallowing, the guy said, "That's
a bit dangerous to say." Nahesu pressed
her back against him, feeling his firm,
warm chest. His hand gently held her
under her breasts, but at the same time
sent goosebumps all over her body. The
girl sighed, and the guy asked if she
wanted him to stay with her. You look
completely seductive, the girl replied.
Baam Taiha continued to hug her. When he
heard this, he smirked and said that
because of the alcohol, the girl didn't
filter what she said. But she protested
and said that she had always had that
opinion of him. He just didn't know it.
The guy smiled and with a shake of
laughter replied that earlier she had
said he was too young for her. Nahu
turned around in his arms and told him
to stop acting like an adult in front of
her. The girl grabbed him by the arms
and started telling him off for acting
like that, saying that if he teased her,
telling her to take advantage of him,
she would punish him. To be taller and
see him better, she stood on the toes of
his shoes. Biama was amused by the
situation. He enjoyed teasing her and
how frank she became after drinking. He
smiled playfully at her and looked her
in the eye and challenged her. Go ahead,
try it. Nahesu pulled his sleeves down
while stretching out on her toes. She
pressed her breasts against his, feeling
her heart quicken and pleasure flow
through her veins. Exhaling, she
whispered softly, "Come here. Lower your
head more." She pulled him by the lapels
of his coat and reached for him with her
lips. The guy kept smiling, not taking
the situation seriously because she was
barely on her feet. He thought about how
funny she was. But suddenly, the blood
pulsing in his ears rumbled. Beam Taiha
could feel his heart beating against his
chest and his lips were
captured. This small, fragile woman
pressed her body against him and kissed
him. She took over his whole world.
Chapter 31. Biamha froze in surprise
when he felt soft, warm lips on his
lips. He hadn't expected the girl to do
something like this. Breathing heavily,
the girl shivered briefly and then
kissed him again. Her heart beat like a
moth that was happy to fly into the
light. She continued to hold him by the
lapels of his coat and lowered her head,
trying to regain her breath. The guy
kept looking at her, trying to figure
out what to do. Nahu pronounced that she
said she would do it and did it. It
seemed like she was trying to prove
something to herself rather than to him.
The girl jabbed her finger at his chest
and looked at him with a flaming face of
shame, telling him not to argue with her
anymore. The moment their eyes met,
something clicked in Biamonta's mind. He
reached out his hands and wrapped them
around the back of the girl's head,
bringing his face closer. She tried to
say that she had more life experience,
but the guy didn't let her finish. He
bowed her head slightly and dug his lips
into hers in a greedy kiss. At that
moment, his body was as if struck by
lightning. He ran his hands through her
hair and began to move in time with her.
Nahesu felt his tongue slip into her
mouth, and then he took her face in his
palms and started kissing her as if he
was looking for salvation in her.
She closed her eyes and gave in to the
desire. The girl's legs trembled. The
guy was kissing her very skillfully, and
she was reaching for him closer and
closer. She stood up on her toes to kiss
him even harder, but suddenly felt her
body spinning. Biamha turned her around,
pressing her close to him. He wrapped
one arm around her waist and hugged her
tightly. And with the other hand, he
gently held her neck, hovering over her
and making the kiss even deeper. He
could hear her moaning and feel her
pressed against him, but he continued to
taste her gently. The girl's mind was
almost completely clouded. She tried to
remember to breathe. They pulled away
from each other for a moment to breathe
in the air. Nahu immediately felt the
coldness prickling her lips and reached
for the guy to resume the kiss. And then
suddenly she started breathing heavily
and said they had to stop. Biam Taiha's
gaze became serious and expressionless.
The girl lowered her flaming face to his
chest and tearing breaths tried to say
she couldn't breathe. She rubbed her
cheek against his hard chest and
admitted that he was the reason she
couldn't think straight. Then suddenly
panic came over her so hard that the
girl felt that she was losing
consciousness. Biamha picked her up and
held her gently in his arms. He looked
at the unconscious girl and tried to
make a decision. He walked with her in
his arms through the hotel lobby like
she was light as a feather. Walking up
to the front desk, the guy nonchalantly
asked for a room. Nahisu was sniffling
and moaning heavily at the same time.
Porter and Portier began to watch the
young man with interest. At first, they
thought it was the chairman himself, but
on closer inspection, they realized that
it was his son, who looked like two
drops of water. One of the men assumed
it was the eldest son of the Bome
family, who takes new girls to his room
every day. But the Portier said it was
the wrong son. The one about whom the
unpleasant rumors had been circulating
he saw quite often in the company of
various girls. One could recognize him
as a typical representative of the
Chibles at a glance. At the time he
thought that the guy looked like the
chairman like two drops of water. But
now looking at this son, he was even
creeped out by how much more he
resembled his father. It's like he's a
carbon copy of him. Bomi was having fun
with another girl at the time. He paused
for a moment and scratched his ears,
saying that someone was talking about
him. The girl began to grumble unhappily
because he had stopped. She licked her
lips and pulled down the straps of her
dress, wondering if he was capable of
taking his eyes off her. The young man
immediately returned his attention to
her and replied that he was unable to
tear himself away from her. He kissed
the girl and said he didn't have the
patience for a hotel and that they would
do it right here. The spacious room was
dark and silent. Biamha gently laid Nahu
on the bed. He sat down by the bed and
carefully pulled the shoes off the
girl's feet. He couldn't put her to bed
with her shoes on. He wanted her to rest
in comfort. The guy thought about their
kiss and what she had said to him. It
would have been easy to take advantage
of the situation, but he didn't want to.
He talked himself into being patient and
waiting for her quietly. After handling
the shoes, he lifted the girl up to take
off her coat. Nahu was almost completely
unconscious, only mumbling quietly.
Biama tried to act carefully so as not
to alarm her. All the while he was
thinking that he wanted the girl can be
completely at ease. Nahesu turned her
head in his direction and pressed her
cheek against his shoulder. The guy
froze, gazing intently at her face. He
smirked, watching her snuggle up to him
in her sleep as if seeking protection.
It was like she trusted him quite a bit
already. He gently tucked her back into
bed and whispered sweet dreams to her.
She would definitely be hung over
tomorrow, so he didn't want to bother
her any further. Biama covered her with
a blanket and stroked her. He was about
to take his hand away when the girl
instinctively reached for him and
wouldn't let him go. The guy propped
himself up on the bed, hovering over her
and again talked himself into restraint.
His heart was racing and he desperately
wanted to get naked for this girl, but
he had to wait. He stood up and took a
few steps toward the exit when he heard
the girl's quiet sobs. The guy came back
and stroked her head, whispering that
she was going to be fine. He crouched on
the edge of the bed and continued to
stroke her and soothe her until the
girl's breathing evened out. Chapter 32.
Nahesu moaned contentedly. She felt her
body drowning in something soft and
warm. Normally, she woke up with a draft
blowing through her body and her body
aching, but today she felt very
comfortable. She turned around abruptly
and opened her eyes, trying to focus her
attention. The girl sat down on the bed
and looked around trying to figure out
where she was. She obviously didn't know
this place and didn't remember how she'd
gotten here. Then the events of last
night began to resurface in her mind.
The last thing she remembered was a
passionate kiss with Bomb Taiha. From
the realization of what had happened,
the girl jumped up on the spot like a
frightened cat. Her face instantly
burned with shame.
She put her palm to her flaming cheek
and talked herself into believing that
it must have been a dream, just like
last time. She'd been having a lot of
dreams like this lately because of this
guy. Nah Su looked around the room, and
it wasn't hard for her to imagine that
it was a dream. Her shoes were neatly
folded, her coat was neatly hung up, and
her purse was carefully left on the
nightstand, but she distinctly
remembered the slow and gentle touch of
someone who had taken care of her after
she got drunk. She groped herself in a
panic to make sure her underwear was in
place. She felt like nothing had
happened to her that night. Nah, Su hit
her head in shame and thought that
although she was glad that nothing had
happened, wasn't it too late to worry
about such things now? She shouldn't
have crossed that line. But his
gestures, which were like asking for a
chance to cross it, tickled her nerves
so much, and his perpetually smug and
calm expression, looking at which the
girl couldn't help herself.
She wanted to bite his lip hard enough
to hurt him, but at the end of the day,
she doesn't have to be dramatic. They
didn't sleep together, so it's hardly
worth making a big deal out of it. Jesu
began to put on her shoes and caught
herself jealously, thinking that this
was probably not the first time for him.
With his handsome face, it would be
silly to think that he didn't have a
past. She blushed and admitted to
herself that he turned out to be quite
skillful. Putting on her coat, the girl
scolded herself for being such an
irresponsible adult and thinking silly
things. She should definitely apologize
to him. When she dipped her hand into
her pocket, she found a note. Making
sure the girl was sleeping peacefully
and soundly, Biamha decided to write a
note for her. He was sure that when the
girl woke up, she might be frightened to
find herself in a strange place. He
wrote that she was too drunk to carry
her to her house, so he apologized for
bringing her to the hotel and hoped she
would understand. He also asked her not
to worry about paying for the room. To
the girl, he wrote that he had a winning
free voucher and he was planning to use
it when he got a girlfriend. In fact,
the hotel was actually owned by his
family and the entire staff walked him
to his car. Li Jay gave a strange smile
and asked the young master if he really
needed the extra protection of the
house. He was surprised by the extra
shift, asked if the guy thought someone
would fly through a window into a
skyscraper in downtown Soul to stab him
with a knife. The Taiha laughed and
asked the young man to entertain him
with something. Li Jay asked if the guy
was going to meet that girl today. Byam
Taiha smiled and replied that he wasn't
going to be the first to contact her
today. He smirked oddly and stated that
her debt to him had grown, so she should
be the first to contact him. In that
case, maybe he'd be in the mood to let
it slide. Li Jay looked at the guy like
he was crazy and couldn't understand
what he was muttering about. He couldn't
understand what the guy was thinking
lately. He followed him last night and
saw him go into the hotel with the girl
in his arms and then come out
accompanied by hotel
staff. Now he couldn't tell if this guy
wanted to avoid being exposed or if he
was burning to be found out. Taking a
drag on his cigarette, Lee Jay thought
whose exposure would be scarier, that
girls or the chairman's. Mhel and Hiji
were lying in bed talking about nothing.
Suddenly, the girl fake pouted her lips
and declared that it wasn't fair that
the man was so skillful in various
fields. She said it looks like he's
dated a lot of women and his ex-wife is
even obsessed with him. Asked if it's
because he's good at it or because he's
big. The man smiled smugly. Noticing his
reaction, the girl jealously said that
he probably didn't screw up his first
time either. Mitchell smirked and looked
at the girl, thinking how naive she was.
Did she really think he was like that
when he was younger? He put his arm
around her and condescendingly replied
that it was because he was older than
her. Hiji asked. Is that what happens
when you get older? The man replied
evasively. Mchel recalled the beginning
of his and Nahu's story and said that as
people get older, they stop being as
stupid and naive as they were when they
were young. He remembered the first time
she had kissed him. How childish they
really were and how scared he'd been of
it. The guy turned her back to him so
she couldn't see his embarrassed, reened
face. He told the girl to go home. She
asked him if he liked the kiss and why
he was sending her away so
suddenly. The guy was struggling to hold
back and trying to catch his breath. He
said his body was sore from the fight
and Nahu offered to give him medicine,
but the guy panicked and asked her not
to turn around and look at him.
Eventually, he abruptly turned around
and said he was going home
first. The girl stared after him and
didn't know what to do or say. Miel, on
the other hand, was trying to catch his
breath and calm his frantically beating
heart. He couldn't believe that this
girl had stirred up such a storm of
emotions in him. Hiji, looking at how
stupidly the man was smiling, asked what
he was thinking. She wondered if he was
thinking about his first love. Mchiel
exhald and said he wasn't thinking about
anything important. Nahu decided to
clean the house and get rid of all
unnecessary things. Since she was no
longer going to live with Mchall, she
decided to pack up all his belongings.
She got rid of most of her things with
ease, but looking at some of them made
her think of memories.
But even then, she didn't shed a tear,
for she had promised herself she would
never cry again. The girl decided that
she would never cry for this man again
and let go of all their memories
together. Finish, the girl exhaled in
relief and stretched her stiff
shoulders. She felt as if she had moved
into a new home. She remembered that
it's customary to eat Ja Jang when
moving. She and Mchel had eaten this
dish on moving day. Nahu smiled at this
memory and realized that she felt an
unprecedented lightness, as if she had
gotten rid of something very heavy in
her life. Now the house was clean and
empty with no one to even eat with. But
it made the girl realize how little
space she had before in their already
small apartment. The girl decided to
throw out all her old underwear at the
same time. Even though she no longer
lived with Mchall, the poverty that had
haunted her for the past 13 years would
remain with her. but she will buy new
underwear to fill the void in her heart.
Throwing a glance at the teddy bear she
had so diligently embroidered the heart
on. The girl thought she might find room
in her heart for something else. She
immediately thought of calling Bomb Ta
and asking him to eat Jang together. The
guy was sitting with Li Jay playing
Jenga trying to pass the time. Suddenly
the screen of his phone lit up and a
ringtone echoed through the room. Bomba
took the phone in his hands and smiled
contentedly. Chapter 33. Nahu went
shopping. For the first time in her
life, she decided to buy something new
for herself. Before that, she was always
given old and used things. So, if she
had something of her own, she'd attach
herself to it and consider it her jewel.
The most dazzling thing that ever
happened in her life was Kang Mitchell,
but he disappeared from her life so
easily, as if he had never belonged to
her from the beginning. The girl stopped
at a clothing stall and started looking
around. Upon noticing her, the friendly
saleswoman immediately began offering
her her goods. She asked her what she
was looking for and Nah Su said she was
looking for basic lingerie. The woman
complimented her beautiful form and the
girl blushed with embarrassment. The
saleswoman started picking out different
bras and offering it to the girl.
Finally smiling, she pulled out a red
lace bra and smiling said that in this a
girl would drive her husband crazy. Nahu
was shaking with embarrassment, looking
for something absolutely basic. Then the
woman handed her a classic white bra
that satisfied the girl. She asked if
Nahu had a boyfriend or husband.
Smiling, the girl easily replied that
she was single. Hearing this, the kind
saleswoman packed her a red lace thong
in a separate bag, saying that it was a
gift and that such a young girl should
wear beautiful lingerie. Nahu, who had
never worn anything like this in her
life, clutched the shopping bags to her
chest.
Even though she was embarrassed, she was
proud that she had bought something for
herself for the first time. After that,
the girl was pleased to find that
spending money on little things was very
satisfying. She bought a beautiful
package for the bear she was going to
give to
Biamonta. She also bought warm socks for
herself. She walked and hummed a little
song to herself, pleased with herself.
Thinking about the guy, the girl
suddenly remembered one very important
detail. He often wore gloves, but they
didn't look warm at all. And then her
gaze fell on a pair of warm knitted
mittens. She didn't hesitate to give
them to the guy. Packing them in a
separate bag, the pleased with herself
girl went on her way. Nahu received a
message from Bomb Taiha saying that he
had already arrived on the spot. She
looked around, but it was hard to see
anything in the crowded marketplace.
Then suddenly, she saw him. Tall and
handsome, he stood surrounded by local
women vendors. Women cooed around him
and asked if he was a model. They
praised their familiar girls and
daughters to him in the hope that he
would want to meet them. But when Bomb
Taiha saw a girl out of the corner of
his eye, he smiled and said that he
already had a lover. Finally meeting the
guy's
gaze. Nah Su froze a little embarrassed
after what happened yesterday. Then she
went to meet him and smiling thanked him
for coming to her so quickly. Bomba
reached for her bags and replied that he
was getting very curious. The girl
thought he was about to start a
conversation about what had happened and
she began to think feverishly about what
to say to him and how he would react.
Bum Taiha took the packets from her
hands and smilingly asked why she had
called him today. The girl was
embarrassed and said she wanted to eat
Jajjangan with sweet and sour pork, but
she didn't want to do it alone, so she
wanted to invite him over. The girl was
embarrassed and said she wanted to eat
Jajjang Mean with sweet and sour pork,
but she didn't want to do it alone, so
she wanted to invite him over. Soon they
were in a restaurant and sat in awkward
silence. Nahes Su drank water while
waiting for their order and thought
about how she looked like a shameless
auntie who made all of the first moves
towards a guy and then treated him to
food as an apology. When the food was
ready, the girl said he should
definitely try it because this place
serves the most delicious
jajangyan. The guy asked if she comes
here often, quicker than she realized,
she answered that she'd been here with
Mitchell and then said she'd been here a
couple of times herself. She felt very
embarrassed that she had mentioned her
ex in front of him. As she ate, the girl
thought about how awkward it was to
mention her ex-husband in front of the
guy she'd kissed, even if drunk. It was
wrong. Then she glanced at the guy and
wondered how he could stay so calm and
relaxed, as if nothing had happened
between them yesterday. Biamaya was
quietly eating and kept a friendly
expression on her face without forcing
her to make conversation. The girl
thought about the fact that it probably
didn't matter much to him because he
probably had a lot of girls with his
looks. So, he preferred to pretend that
a drunken mistake like that didn't
happen. Nahu decided to relax and just
have a meal. As they approached the
house, the girl thanked the guy for
spending time with her and walked her
home. She also thanked him for coming
yesterday when she called him, even
though he had his own business to attend
to. The girl lowered her head and said
she had something else to say. She
plucked up the courage to look him in
the eye and told him she was sorry for
what she had done yesterday. She was
drunk and she shouldn't have behaved
like that. Suddenly, the guy abruptly
brought his face close to hers and
interrupted her, saying that he didn't
need her apology. When she felt his
breath on her face, the girl froze.
Bombaya looked into her eyes. Their
faces were so close that he could run
his nose over hers. He was serious and
said she didn't have to apologize
because he liked it so much. The guy
asked if she didn't like it.
The girl blushed and turned her face
away and replied that it wasn't that.
Her heart sped up and her mind flashed
again with obscene thoughts. That answer
flattered Baum Tha. He thought that at
least she was being honest with
herself. He turned his head to catch her
gaze again and said it was all right,
that she could use him if she wanted to,
then smiled flirtatiously. The guy
reached for her hand, continuing to say
that if her heart wasn't ready to accept
him yet, she could use his body for now.
Hearing such a blatant offer, Nah Su,
hiding her red face, shoved the gift bag
into his hand and turned around
abruptly. Running home before the guy
embarrassed her further, she shouted
that it was a Christmas present and
asked him to open it at home. Biam Taiha
smiled merrily, enjoying how cute she
was embarrassed and running away from
him. He shouted after her, asking if he
could go to her house and open the
present, to which the girl told him to
go home. Once home, the girl leaned her
back against the wall, burning with
shame. She thought of the guy pretending
to be innocent but acting like a total
pro. What was he thinking trying to get
into her house? Nahu pressed her hand to
her mouth, imagining all sorts of
naughty things he could think of. The
tense girl then stood up and decided she
should take a shower and relax. After
getting out of the shower, the girl
decided to put on new underwear as it
was cold in the flat. She looked for the
laundry bag and sat down in front of the
brown paper bag. Suddenly, she froze in
bewilderment. She remembered exactly
that the nice shop assistant had put the
underwear in a red bag and the mittens
was in a brown one. Now she was looking
at the very same brown bag. Once in his
flat, Bomb Tea pulled a teddy bear with
an embroidered heart out of a box.
Intrigued by the next gift, the guy
picked up a red paper bag and dipped his
hand into it. At this time, realizing
her fatal mistake, Nah Su screamed in
horror in her flat. Chapter 34. The
original plan was to give Bum Taiha a
teddy bear with an embroidered heart and
a pair of warm mittens, but in reality,
the guy got a bag of her underwear. The
girl had never felt such shame before.
She grabbed her phone and called him,
nervously chewing on the pad of her
finger as she waited for an answer, her
head spinning with the thought that if
he'd been home and opened the package,
he'd probably have called her. She hoped
he hadn't seen the contents yet. Biama
collapsed on the sofa and answered the
phone. His voice was low and hoarse.
Hearing his voice, the girl asked
hopefully if he had already got home and
had time to open his present. The guy
replied that he was already home, but
hadn't looked in the bag yet. She
exhaled happily and admitted that she
had mistakenly given him the wrong bag
and asked him not to look inside. Beumha
covered his eyes with his hand as if she
could see him and catch him in a lie. He
swallowed hard and asked why he
shouldn't do it. The girl stammered and
replied that there was something so
scary at there that he might have
nightmares again. She calmly repeated to
him not to open the bag. She thought it
was strange that his voice was hoarse
and his breathing sounded as if he had a
cold. Then the guy said he'd give it
back to her tomorrow morning and they
said goodbye. Nahesu breathed a sigh of
relief. Bamha slowly took the phone away
from his ear and lowered his hand to the
couch. His face was flaming. Who would
have thought it? Now, thanks to Chance,
he had something to think about. It was
quiet in the semi darkness of the
quarters. Only the languid breathing of
the two could be heard. On the girl's
neck and shoulders, there were already
allelujah of fresh marks left by Beaum
Teha. Soon she was looking down at him
in anticipation. At the sight of her, a
cold flame raged in his eyes, which
flared up with rapid speed. The guy
slowly clamped a small piece of cloth
between his teeth. Nahu jumped up
abruptly, waking up and trying to come
to her senses. She turned round and
hugging the pillow moaned. She was
definitely starting to lose her mind.
Both never slept a wink until morning.
Only neither of them suspected it or the
cause of their insomnia. The girl
decided that even though it was still
early, she would get ready for work.
After showering and getting dressed, she
heard the bell ring. Biama stood at the
door of the girl's house and hid his
nose in the high collar of his jumper
against the cold. The girl looked out
and saw him. As promised, he had come
early in the morning to exchange
packages. The guy held out the red ill-
fated bag to her. In exchange for it,
the girl embarrassedly held out another
one and said it was his real present.
The girl apologized for disturbing him,
but he smiled enigmatically and replied
that it was fine. She looked at him and
thought that even though he was smiling,
he looked strange. Nahu asked if he was
sick, to which the guy said he wasn't.
She persisted and asked if he was tired
and he smirked and said he was hooked.
He ducked down to her and told her that
last night he couldn't sleep a wink at
all. The girl looked away embarrassed
and said she hadn't slept well either.
She said it was probably because of the
cold. There was an awkward silence
between them for a moment. Then the girl
mumbled that she had to pack up and go
to work. She had already turned towards
the house when she felt a gentle tug on
her coat. I also brought you a gift. Go
inside and open it. Bam. Taiha handed
the black bag to the surprised girl.
Once at home, Nahu opened the bag and
took out a beautiful soft jumper. Her
eyes lit up with happiness. She
immediately put it on and was surprised
that it fit her perfectly. The girl was
happy about the gift sincerely, like a
child. It was very warm and apparently
not cheap. She decided that she would
thank the guy again when she met him.
Soon she strutdded into the flower shop
and greeted her colleague
radiantly. In spite of the frosty
weather, spring rained in her soul.
Hujang yawned and was about to greet the
girl when she suddenly noticed her in
her new clothes. She immediately
complimented Jesu and said that she
looked great. The girl thanked her
happily and said that it was a gift.
Hujang said that she used to be shy to
say, but because the girl wore the same
clothes everyday, she looked shabby. Now
she looks very beautiful. Nahu was
embarrassed. The joy of the gift was
gone.
She wondered if Baum Taiha had given her
a jumper because she looked shabby and
pathetic in her old clothes. Huaong
meanwhile went on to say that her
husband must have good taste. Nahesu
stared at her and the girl said that
since it was a gift, it must have been
from her husband. Or was she confused?
Nahu lowered her head and hesitantly
admitted that she had actually recently
gotten divorced. Hajang was surprised
and asked why it happened so suddenly.
And why didn't the girl say anything
earlier? Well, Nah Su left to change her
clothes, and on the way, she threw back
that it was just the circumstances. The
girl stood there and looked suspiciously
at her. She thought it all looked rather
strange. Shortly after the shop opened,
their regular, handsome customer showed
up as usual. He and Nah Su chatted
nicely while the girl picked the bouquet
of roses for him. As usual, Jang watched
with envy and bewilderment as the guy
flirted with Nah Su. And just as
strangely, the girl cheered him on. Bam.
Tha was genuinely smiling and bantering
with the girl while she was fulfilling
his order. It was obvious from the
outside that the two were quite close.
The moment he gently stroked Nah Su's
hand with his hand, Hua Jong thought she
had lost her mind. She couldn't believe
that a handsome man like him would be
courting an auntie much older than him.
It's not known if she's really divorced
or not. It didn't make any sense and
looked weird. So, the girl got out from
behind the counter and walked over to
the guy and tugged at his coat. She
asked the guy for a few minutes. Biam
Taiha looked at the girl dismissively.
Chapter 35. Nesu saw this and turned
away saying she would get back to work
and the young people could talk for a
while. The guy looked at her in surprise
and a little resentment. He felt bad
that the girl's colleague had
interrupted them and that the girl
herself had turned her back on him so
easily. Hujang called him outside and to
her surprise, the guy obediently
followed her out. She put her hands in
her pockets and looked up at him
proudly, asking him what his
relationship with Nahu was like.
Biamontea smirked and asked her why she
cares. The girl said that if he didn't
want to answer, that was his right.
Wajang said he sees that he likes her,
but he should stop acting like that
because there's something he doesn't
know. Bomha's gaze turned cold. He
seemed to realize what the girl was
getting at. Nahi Su tried to do her job
but couldn't help but think about why
Hua Jang had so suddenly called Biam
Thaiha in for a conversation. A small
flame of jealousy burned in her soul.
Meanwhile, Hua Jong folded her arms on
her chest and smooked that she didn't
realize that Ooni was this kind of
woman. She got nervous and bitter her
finger and said that Nahu was married
and that at her age and her status as a
married woman, it was not appropriate
for her to behave like that. The girl
suggested that she might be lying about
her divorce because of the guy. Biamha
asked why she was telling him this and
the girl said that of course it was
because she was worried about him. The
guy frowned and asked why all of a
sudden she cared about a complete
stranger. Did it have anything to do
with her personally? Huai Jang was
annoyed and angrily replied that she
couldn't watch an old divorce hiding her
past and trying to seduce a young guy.
Suddenly, Bea Taiha leaned towards the
girl and smuggly said that he knew about
everything. I knew that she had a
husband and that things ended with him a
long time ago. I knew everything and yet
I lingered. Every single day, I crossed
the line little by little, waiting
eagerly for that relationship to
collapse, wishing for something so
selfish and wrong. Realizing how badly
she screwed up, Hua Jang asked why he
was doing it. Satisfied that he had
managed to put the girl's self-serving
colleague in her place, he smirked and
replied that he had impure intentions,
he leaned in close to her ear, his gaze
cold. He quietly and threateningly said
that now she could go to Nahau and tell
her to be wary of him, as she should be
worried about her friend now. Biam Taiha
stood on the roof of a skyscraper and
thoughtfully examined his Christmas
present. Lij watched him and thought
that the young master was like a puppy
who follows his mistress to work and
then faithfully waits until she is
finished and walks her home. It seemed
him kind of touching. Suddenly, the guy
waved a glove that only held four of his
fingers and asked with a smile how he
liked his gift. Bam Taiha was happy
about it, even if they turned out to be
small for him. Lie Jay asked why he kept
begging for gifts from the girl. even
though he could afford everything and
knew the tight circumstances in which
she lived. He asked directly if the
master was really sincere with her. To
which the guy replied with a question
about what he thought. Li Jay honestly
replied that he doesn't see her being
taken seriously by him. He said that the
master behaves carelessly even though he
has the ability to hide himself better.
This makes him think that Biam Taiha is
deliberately behaving like this in order
to get caught and find out if she will
continue to be with him or if it's all
over. For a man of his age to court an
adult divorce was unusual, but not
something impossible to understand. From
what he had seen, he could tell that
this girl was not the kind of woman who
could be bribed with gifts and money.
That must be why she had put up with her
worthless husband for so long. But it's
also possible that if she finds out that
the young master is from a family of chi
bowls, she'll start pulling every penny
she can out of him. All people have a
taste for money. In any case, for a
young master to whom the whole world
seems boring and simple, perhaps only
someone who will not fall in love so
easily is able to give a thrill. And
perhaps that is the essence of their
relationship. Baom Taiha listened to the
man and smirked and replied that he
would give him an answer next time. Li
didn't say anything, just thought that
he expected nothing less from him. When
Bom Taiha got home, he took the teddy
bear Nah Su gave him and put it to bed
with him. He saw with what confusion and
jealousy she watched them while he
talked to her colleague outside. He
stroked the teddy bear contentedly as if
trying to reassure the girl. It warmed
his ego. She definitely had feelings for
him. Nahu was lying awake again. She
couldn't get out of my head that Bomiha
and Wa Jong looked much better together.
Although at his age, it was not uncommon
to have such frivolous feelings, the
girl tried to pretend she didn't realize
he was interested in her because she was
lonely. She decided that the longer she
pretended nothing was going on, the
longer he'd be there for her. And now,
while the guy quite enjoyed the
feelings, the girl decided that it was
time to end their relationship. After
all, sooner or later, they will have to
admit that they are completely
unsuitable for each other. The next day,
Baum Taiha as usual led the girl to the
house and told her to hurry up and go
inside as it was very cold outside. But
suddenly, the girl grabbed him by the
arm and dragged him into the house,
saying she had something urgent to tell
him. The guy grinned, not expecting her
to be so pushy. He decided to make a
joke and said that she intrigued him, to
which the girl did not turn round and
said that he would not like what she had
to say. Suddenly, they stopped at her
door and looking into his eyes, the girl
said she was going to hurt him. It was
really unexpected for him. He asked her
how and the girl immediately said that
he already know a girl from her work.
Jang Bha grinned and reached his hand to
the girl's chin and asked if she was
jealous because he was talking to that
girl, but Nahu just said she could
introduce him to her if he wanted to.
The guy's hand froze. Ah, that hurts a
little. The boy looked at her pained.
The girl started to say that he could
meet any other girl of his age because
she was sure there were always lots of
beautiful girls around him. Suddenly,
she was silent as she saw the guy's gaze
harden. He slowly ran his finger down
her cheek and hovered over her. He
pressed his thumb over her bottom lip so
that the girl's mouth fell open. Her
cheeks instantly flushed and Biamha
caught her breath and growled, "I'm the
bastard who wants to be with a divorced
auntie." The girl pushed him away from
her and screamed that it wasn't okay for
him to like an old
divorce. Jesu was angry and kept saying
that anyone who cared about him would
tell him that he was out of his mind.
She lowered her head and said more
quietly that if he was sane, he should
meet someone suitable for him. Bamha,
whose blood was boiling from such an
outburst of emotion, lifted her head
again by her chin, and looking into her
eyes, asked if she thought he was sane.
Nahu looked at him defiantly. She had so
many mixed feelings that she was not
responsible for her sanity. She quietly
said no and reached out to him with her
lips. A lone tear trickled down the
girl's cheek and she closed her eyes.
The guy gave in to his feelings and
wrapped both palms around her face and
kissed her as if she were the air
without which he would suffocate. Nahesu
clutched the collar of his shirt and
instinctively reached for the guy,
taking short breaths between kisses.
Beam Taiha looked at her from beneath
lowered lashes and pressed the girl even
tighter against the wall. They weren't
drunk this time, but she clung to him so
desperately as if she was afraid he'd
disappear. Only their breathing could be
heard in the cold silence of the
corridor. Becoming bolder, Nah Su
wrapped her hands around the back of the
guy's head, and he felt a wave of
goosebumps sweep across his body. Then
suddenly, the girl slowly shivered and
looked at him.
Biam Taiha breathed heavily and looked
at her with a hazy gaze. He saw the
regret in her eyes and lightly slammed
his fist on the wall beside her head.
She said that she was a human being too
and that the guy was right to suggest
that she have an affair to spite her
ex-husband because she was really hurt
by the way he treated her. She did have
those thoughts. Of course, it pleased
her to think that a young and successful
guy like Bumha was following her and
that she could live happily and do
things like that with him. She wanted to
show her ex-husband that and to mock
him. The girl trembled with tears and
lowered her head tiredly. She tried to
catch her breath and then quietly went
on to say that even though she was
shabby and jaded, she didn't want to
destroy herself by dating someone just
to prove something to that bastard. And
she certainly didn't want to use someone
as good as him to drown out her
loneliness. When she was younger, she
had no one to support her. So, she
wanted to be that person for Bayamha.
Nah Su closed her eyes, letting her
tears flow and turned away with pain in
her heart, saying that he shouldn't fall
in love with her. The guy quietly
replied that feelings of love are not
something a person can control. But the
girl interrupted him and said tiredly
that he should try harder. Bom Teha took
her hand and frantically said that in
that case, let the girl pretend to know
nothing about his feelings. The girl
looked up at him with tearful eyes and
he looked at her and said that so far
she've done that well so far. Let it be
like before. The guy looked at her with
sadness and thought that she should do
what was best for her because he, for
his part, was ready to use all the
necessary means. He dropped his head on
her shoulder and said with a heavy
weight on his heart that he would not
force her to love him and that if she
did not want him near her, she should
not pretend to care for him. His breath
touched her neck and cheek. He could
feel her breasts heaving rapidly. He
said all she had to do was say she hated
him and then he wouldn't come back
again. The girl tiredly leaned her head
against the wall. Tears were pouring
from her eyes. With his words, it was as
if he had opened her chest and pulled
out her heart clenched tightly in his
fist. Later, sitting in her bed at home,
Nah Su sent a message to the guy not to
come to pick her up from work tomorrow.
The girl wrapped her arms around herself
and rested her head tiredly on her
knees. After much thought, this message
was the only thing that came to her
mind. She just couldn't see him. After
she decided to let him get so close to
her, she sharply pushed him away. But
she couldn't bring herself to say the
words to not see him again. She pondered
why she never got round to saying them.
He had given her the perfect opportunity
to end things with him. But she
couldn't. From the moment she was about
to open her mouth, she had a feeling he
knew even before she answered. He would
have known she didn't mean it if she
said she hated him. That all of her
words would have been lies. There was
silence in Biamha's flat. He held the
teddy bear and pressed its toy nose. Li
Jay looked uncertainly at the young
master and wondered what the hell was
his problem. Why did he call him in and
create such a tense atmosphere? He
looked at the guy sitting silently with
a look like he was planning someone's
murder. It was much better when they
were joking around and playing Jenga.
The man was creeped out by how similar
the guy and the chairman's faces were.
Suddenly, Biamha asked if he would ask
why he had called him. Lij gave a
strange smile and thought he was afraid
to ask a question, but he said aloud
that of course he was curious. The guy
pressed the embroidered heart of the
teddy bear with force and calmly replied
that he wanted to give him an answer.
Seeing the bodyguard's uncomprehending
look, he said it was about the question
Lee Jay had asked him on the roof about
that girl. The guy started telling that
when he was a kid, he saw a film where
there was a scene where a man brought an
intoxicated girl to a motel. The room
was filled with nothing but the sound of
breathing. The man did nothing until
morning came. He stayed awake beside the
woman he liked, as if he might wake her
from her deep sleep with the sound of
his blinking. He wondered then why such
a simple scene was filmed so
sentimentally. Why were that man's
emotions that one night's patience
considered to be so special? Ba put down
the teddy bear and met the man's eyes,
saying that he now realized that it
wasn't easy. Li Jay listened intently to
the guy and realized he was just crazy.
Was that really his answer?
The man thought that the chairman had
completely failed at parenting. He
thanked the young master for his answer
and said with a smile that he was a
little funny to hear him say such
things. After all, Bea Taiha is not a
virgin coming with his girlfriend to a
motel for the first time to make it such
a big deal. Glancing at the guy, Li Jay
saw the emotionless expression on his
face. The man laughed at the naive
things the guy said as if he really was
an inexperienced youngster. But when he
noticed that the young master did not
share his amusement, his smile faded.
Beumaya continued to stare impassively
at the bodyguard, as if silently asking
what funny thing he had just said. The
man swallowed hard and couldn't believe
what he had just learned. It would never
have occurred to him. Nesu was at work
when her colleague excitedly asked if
the girl was okay. The girl said she'd
been watching her all day and that it
was like she was mentally somewhere far
away, making mistakes she hadn't made
before.
Jesu replied confusedly that everything
was fine, that she was just thinking
about something else for a bit. At the
end of the day, she asked her colleague
and boss for advice. She asked, "What
are some ways to make someone who likes
you lose interest in you?" Her colleague
stared at her with suspicion, but didn't
want to pressurize and embarrass her
with unnecessary questions. Even though
she said she wasn't asking for herself,
but for her friend, everyone in the room
knew it was definitely about Nahu. The
girl suggested that Nahu asked the guy
who keeps coming for her to scare the
annoying guy. She said that he looked
pretty strong and could easily do it.
Seeing that she had rejected this
option, the colleagues looked at each
other and said that in such a case,
there was only one sure way to get rid
of someone. Nahu was walking home and
thinking about what she had been offered
to make a man disappear from her life
once and for all. In order to break
relations with relatives, friends, or
close people once and for all, it is
necessary to ask for money. and the more
the better. Nahu looked at the screen of
her phone and thought that love and
youth is full of passion but fleeting.
Even if people call it love, it may pass
after a season or two. For a moment, she
remembered again her and Mchel's youth
and how it had ended. She started typing
a message to Baum Taiha asking to borrow
10,0001. But suddenly, she was afraid
that he, driven by his youthful
impulsiveness, might ruin his life
trying to get the money. So she decided
to ask him for an unrealistically huge
amount of money that he could never get
under any circumstances. The phone
screen lit up and a sound alerted about
new text message. The guy reached out to
look at it. He read a message from Nahai
Su asking her to borrow money. Another
message came next. The girl asked for
100 million1. Baum Taiha grinned after
reading her messages. He thought about
the fact that the girl had chosen such a
tactic to get rid of him and that it was
funny. It's been a few weeks since Nah
Su hasn't heard a word about Biamha.
Their communication, which was usually
initiated by the guy, stopped after her
last message. The phone was silent, and
the girl returned home alone every day.
But for some reason, she was sad and
uneasy. Although Nahu realized that she
had hurt him with her cruel words, in
her heart, she hoped that he would still
hold on to her. Everyday she looked
hopefully at the door of the shop and
waited for him to come. It took her two
weeks to come to terms with the fact
that he might never walk through those
doors again. Because of the fact that
the girl often hovered in her thoughts,
she became absent-minded and began to
make many mistakes at work. The number
of dissatisfied customers grew, so she
had to dutifully apologize to everyone.
But it didn't bother her. On the
contrary, she often wondered how Biamha
was doing and whether he was all right.
She was walking down the street alone
and all she could think about was how
his life was going at 24. Does he have
nightmares? Is he safe? Do the gloves
she gave him keep him warm? Did he go
again to the place where he had taken
her to see the city at night and be
alone? That time she had been too caught
up in her emotions to realize that Bam
Taiha also had countless emotions that
he needed to let go of too. She wondered
how many times he had gone there and how
much pain he had to let go of looking at
all those countless lights. The girl
slowly walked down the street feeling a
lump in her throat and only now realized
that she didn't really know anything
about him at all. Suddenly passing by,
she recognized the shop window where she
had bought that very teddy bear. At Jesu
stopped until now, the girl thought
there was nothing left to remind her of
him. Their relationship was so fleeting
that it would feel too grand to say
forgetting. She stepped closer and
looked at the empty stool where the
teddy bear used to sit and put her hand
to the display case. The girl remembered
how she had bought him and how she had
carefully embroidered a heart on his
chest. Nahu thought sadly that there was
something she never got to tell him.
There is a belief that if you put a
teddy bear like this at the head of your
bed, it will protect you and you will
never have nightmares again. Her eyes
filled with tears and her chest achd.
She thought she should have had time to
tell him about it. With him, who always
seemed deeply scarred, she acted like a
selfish and horrible adult until the
very end. The words she had never been
able to bring herself to say to him
personally for a long time hurt her
heart. A man was lying face down on the
ground. Biam Taiha stood over him. Li
Jay stood against the wall with his back
leaning against it and grudgingly asked
why the young master was bothering
innocent
people. If he's drunk, he should just go
home and sleep peacefully. The man
excitedly thought about Baum Taiha being
very tense lately and throwing himself
into fights with anyone who meets his
path.
The guy stood there covered in abrasions
and looked indifferently at the
unconscious man. Suddenly, he asked Lee
Jay how well he fights. The bodyguard
tensed up and replied that he was pretty
confident. Then asked for what purpose
the guy was interested. The young man
smiled like a madman and asked him to
hit him, preferably in the most visible
place. The man had a chill down his
spine. He shivered and told the master
not to say such things. And anyway, it's
pretty weird to hear such things from a
guy who's built like a door. Beam Taiha
smiled tiredly and ran his palm through
his hair, pushing it back. He said that
Li was free for the day. The man asked
if he was going home, but he said he had
some other things to do. The man was
very surprised. Where could he possibly
go looking like that? Nah Su stared at
the phone screen and read the message
anxiously. The guy texted he was
standing in front of her house. She went
out to him in conflicted feelings, not
knowing what to say and not realizing
why he had come after all this time. He
stood there as if nothing had happened,
his hands in his pockets, staring at her
with that look in his eyes. The girl
confidently stated that if he didn't
bring what she asked for, she had no
desire to talk to him, so he should
leave. Then she cut the speech short and
noticed the abrasions and scratches on
his face and neck. She wearily removed
the mask from his face and saw that his
lips and nose were smashed. The girl
asked in horror what had happened to
him. Nahisu felt her eyes watering and
she started berating the guy for getting
into fights like a real thug. She
shouted that he was old enough to avoid
it and asked him if he was in pain now.
Biamha looked at her silently.
He thought about the fact that she was
always digging into his vulnerable parts
and didn't realize whether it was
strange or not. But he realized that he
was the one who was getting softer and
weaker for her sake. The girl exhaled
heavily. It pained her to see the form
he had come to her in. Then she said
that this would be the last time and
turned round and told him to follow her.
The guy stood motionless for a few
moments. She said she would just put
some ointment on his wounds. Soon they
were sitting on the floor of her
cramped, shabby flat, and the girl was
tenderly treating his wounds. When she
finished, she said that if he didn't
want to be scarred, he should stop
fighting, and that if he came to her
like that next time, she wouldn't come
out to him. Biamha didn't say a word the
whole time, silently listening and
watching her intently, as if he were
having a silent dialogue with himself.
Nahesu stood up and said that he could
go now, but suddenly she felt him gently
grab her arm and pull her towards him.
Bamonteha reached into the back pocket
of his jeans and without taking his eyes
off the girl said that he brought what
she asked him for and asked if he could
stay a little longer. The girl thought
she had misunderstood him and knelt down
in front of him and asked what he meant.
He handed her a brown paper bag. She
took the package with trembling hands
and thought about how this was simply
impossible. He couldn't get such a
cosmic sum in just a couple of weeks.
She turned it over and wads of money
began to fall out of it.
The girl's heart skipped a beat. Her
throat was dry and she barely audibly
asked where he got it. Then she shouted
for him to answer her
immediately. The guy dispassionately
replied that she asked him to lend her
money and he had done it. Nahesu pounced
on him in horror and grabbed his
t-shirt. She looked at him with a
mixture of fear and disbelief, unable to
imagine what he'd gotten himself into to
get that much money. Suddenly, the guy,
without taking his eyes off her, took
her wrist and pulled that down, lifting
her t-shirt up. He guided her hand up
his chest until she felt the scar
beneath her fingers. Then calmly told
her he'd sold something and was being
paid well. Nahesu froze in horror, her
heart beating so loudly that her blood
rumbled in her ears. She looked at the
scar on his chest and guilt flooded her.
All she could think about was what she
had done. She lowered her head and the
guy felt her start to shiver. And then
she looked up at him with eyes full of
tears. The girl cried as bitterly as she
had probably never cried in her life.
Then Biamha excitedly started jibbering
that it was a joke. He didn't expect her
to believe him since it was a very old
scar. Seeing that the girl was panicking
and would not calm down, he gently
stroked her cheek and
apologized. He admitted that he was
wrong and said that he would leave as
soon as she told him to, but that she
had to calm down first.
He asked her to say him something, but
the girl heard his last words burst into
tears. And now she was choking and
screaming at him, asking him how he
could do this to her. What did he want
to achieve? The guy hugged her, trying
to comfort her and deeply regretting
what he had done, but realizing that
saying anything else would be
unnecessary
now. Meanwhile, she continued to sob and
ask why he was making her hesitate even
though she was trying to push him away
from her.
Why did he make her feel like an
irresponsible adult? Beam Taiha sat the
girl on his lap and cradled her like a
small child. After a while, she stopped
crying, just shook quietly in his arms.
Gently stroking her head, he quietly
asked if she had finished crying. Nahu's
eyes were red and puffy, and she was
embarrassed to look at him after such a
tantrum. She said it was already fine,
and then the guy asked how long they
would have to sit in that position.
The girl looked up at him in confusion
and surprise and then she finally felt
something pressing against her
thigh. Bam Taiha said he was fine but
worried that maybe the girl would feel
uncomfortable. She was embarrassed and
asked, "How could he say such
embarrassing things in such a situation?
Is he even the least bit embarrassed?"
The guy looked at her carefully and then
quietly said, "Can't she see for
herself?" He turned away. Nahu looked at
him and saw that his cheeks were flushed
red and a drop of sweat rolled down his
cheekbone. She reached out a hand to
wipe it and suddenly remembered how a
young man had once said that if she
wasn't ready to give him her heart, she
could at least use his body. Something
clicked in her. She looked up at him and
realized she was tired of resisting him.
The girl wrapped her arms around the
guy's neck and gently pulled herself
closer to him. The guy froze, not
expecting her to do such a thing. And
then she said something that knocked all
the thoughts out of his head and made
him doubt that he was thinking straight.
The girl pressed against him and quietly
asked him to stay over tonight. Nahu
kissed him on the corner of his lip just
where he had a wound and then lightly
bit his lower lip. The guy stared at her
in
amazement. He was still in a state of
shock from what he had heard. Not
noticing his confusion, the girl sat
down comfortably on his lap. Soon Baam
Taiha realized what she wanted from him
and put his hand on her waist, pulling
her to him. They succumbed again to the
feelings overwhelming them. Nahu began
to run her hands over his body, but
suddenly the guy pulled her away from
him and looked into her eyes. The girl
was breathing hard. Her eyes were misty
and her cheeks were burning. He
understood her emotions, but seriously
said that if she was going to regret
later what she wanted to do, they'd
better stop right now. Nahesu saw the
struggle in his gaze and realized what
was happening. But she had decided to
step onto this path and she wasn't going
to turn back from it. Then she took his
palm and put it back to her waist.
Looked at him confidently and told him
that if anything he'll be the only one
to regret this. The room was in semi
darkness and only the sound of their
breathing could be heard. By Taiha
gently leaned towards her neck and then
discovered that her ears were very
sensual and the girl really liked what
he was doing. With a hand reaching
behind her back, he defeated the clasp
with a flick of the clasp. He stared at
her for a few moments, his throat dry.
His heart pounded against his ribs with
a furious force. The girl stared at him
in anticipation. From time to time, he
caught himself thinking that he was not
dreaming, that the girl in front of him
was real and that he had been waiting
for this for a very long time. And even
though he didn't have a lot of
experience, he wanted to make the girl
remember the evening. It was a surprise
to Nah Su that she was able to feel such
emotions. Mchel had never paid so much
attention to her and everything was
happening quickly. Bomha was in no
hurry, attentive and seemed to savor
every moment, making sure that the girl
lost her head completely. Nahu was
sleeping peacefully in a guy's arms. The
dawn was as calm as a deep river. Her
body was enveloped in a pleasant and
warm exhaustion. She could feel Bam
Taiha's warmth and his measured
breathing. When sleep gradually left
her, the girl wrinkled her nose and
opened her eyes.
She didn't even remember when she fell
asleep. She thought her bed was more
comfortable this night and the house was
warmer because she slept so well. She
wanted to get up and go get ready for
work, but she felt a strong male arm
wrap around her waist. Bam Teha was
lying on a nearby pillow, his face
serene, his hair disheveled. He looked
stunningly handsome, like a fallen
angel. Nahesu's cheeks flushed as she
caught herself looking at him. She lay
back down, resting her head on his
forearm, and tried to calm her racing
heart. The events of the previous
evening came flooding back to her. She
took a deep breath, covering her eyes,
and tried to calm herself down, telling
herself that she knew what she was
getting into. And even though it may
have seemed impulsive, what a damn good
thing it was. She was thinking about how
to act when he woke up. Maybe it would
be better not to make such a big deal
out of it since they were both adults.
The girl thought modern young people
often do that when they drink too much
and then remembered that they were both
completely sober. She suddenly
remembered how his timid and clumsy
touches had become confident and
skillful movements. The girl turned
round looking at the sleeping guy and
thought sadly what else she had expected
for he had apparently had a lot of
experience. She felt sad and jealous.
She decided that he was unlikely to make
a big deal out of what had happened, so
she shouldn't worry too much about it.
After a while, she became uncomfortable,
just lying there, and wanted to get up
and get dressed. Nahu tried to get out
of his grip, but the guy had her in a
vicelike grip, and she wondered if he
was asleep or just joking with her.
Suddenly, she heard a low velvet voice
touching her ear. Biamha put both arms
around her and asked her where she was
going. The girl saw his sly smile and
was embarrassed. Her mind immediately
flashed back to yesterday when he had
whispered in her ear, and she felt her
skin goosebumps. She turned away,
tucking her hair behind her ear, and
embarrassedly asked him not to whisper
in her ear like that. The boy smiled and
hugged her tighter, asking why, even
though he could see her reaction, but he
liked to tease her. Nahu said that his
whisper made her body tingle. She tried
again to get out of his arms and said
she had to go to work. Thea calmly asked
her not to leave, saying that his wounds
still hurt. The girl jumped up and asked
indignantly how a man who had done such
things recently could complain that he
was in pain. The guy laughed gleefully.
Eventually, she agreed to skip her
shift. Biamha promised to ask a friend
he could trust to replace her. Even
though the girl agreed, she was still
worried. Ever since she met him, she'd
been doing reckless things. First, she'd
made impulsive purchases, and now she
was skipping work. Bomiha kept his
loving gaze on her, continuing to hold
her gently in his arms and savor the
closeness. The girl thought that his
tastes were very strange, and he often
behaved rather strangely
himself. Then she looked at his scar on
his chest again, and then noticed many
more small ones all over his body. Nahu
gently ran her fingertip over each one
as if she was afraid of hurting him and
excitedly asked why there were so many
scars on his body. The boy looked at her
carefully, going back to memories from
his childhood, and replied that when he
was little, he was often ill. He
remembered how weak and helpless he was.
He said that while he was in the
hospital, he was always begging to be
allowed to walk outside, but it had been
so long ago that he had almost forgotten
about it. The guy grinned and said she
might find that hard to believe,
considering how healthy he was now. The
girl continued to gently stroke the
largest scar in the center of his chest
and quietly replied that it wasn't at
all. She leaned her head against his
chest and said that he had probably been
through a lot of pain. Baom Taiha gently
stroked her. The girl thought about how
many tears he had shed while suffering
such a deep wound as a young boy. She
couldn't even imagine him shedding tears
and then sternly told him that if he
knew how much it hurt, he shouldn't
fight anymore. Threatened him that
otherwise she wouldn't see him. The guy
smiled. He thought about the fact that
first she told him he should see other
girls and now she's threatening not to
meet with him. They lay there arguing
like little children. Baom Teha said he
wouldn't do it again so as not to upset
her. Suddenly, the girl's stomach
rumbled with hunger and she blushed. The
guy asked if she was hungry, but the
girl tried to lie and said she wasn't.
To her surprise, he immediately got up
and told her to wait a little while he
made breakfast for her. Nahu watched him
walk confidently towards the kitchen,
confused. She tried to talk him out of
it since he was her guest, but the guy
assured her he was good at cooking.
Forgetting her appearance, she got up
and wanted to run after him, but then in
time picked up the blanket, covering
herself up. Bam! Taiha stood at the door
and smiled contentedly. Said he didn't
see anything, but the girl panicked and
shouted that he was lying. Then the guy
smiled even wider and said that she had
caught him. While the guy went to the
kitchen, Nahu started to get dressed.
She took out the jumper he had given
her, but then she froze. She remembered
how her ex-husband had once wanted to
cook dinner, saying he was a great cook.
He ended up nearly burning down the
whole kitchen in them. The girl rushed
into the kitchen to make sure the guy
was okay. She ran over to Baum Taiha,
standing by the cooker and frantically
asked him if he knew how to use the
cooker and began to show him where she
kept the salt. The guy silently threw
her onto his shoulder as if she weighed
nothing and headed into the room. And
then he put her on the bed and told her
to just rest while he cooked and not
worry about anything because she looked
tired. Nahu was embarrassed. She thought
it was funny because it was his fault
she was so
tired. Then she felt uncomfortable with
how much care and attention he was
giving her. She couldn't resist and
decided to see what he was doing in the
kitchen. She opened the door slightly
and looked at him and her heart started
beating again at an accelerated rhythm.
The guy just looked huge in her cramped
little kitchen. His broad back was
rippling with muscle with every movement
of his arms, and his jeans sat low on
his hips. The sight of him made her
throat dry. Baam Taiha, with a confident
look, was making breakfast from what he
could find in the girl's kitchen, and
suddenly felt her gaze on his back. The
girl watched him like a mesmerized girl.
She was also curious about what he was
going to cook. She didn't notice herself
letting out a quiet sigh. The guy heard
a muffled sigh and turned around
slightly to see that the girl was
peeking at him, clearly enjoying the
view. He looked back, but the girl had
already hidden behind the wall. He
smiled, pleased with her reaction to him
and eager to tease her some more. Nahu
sat behind the wall with her hands
tightly clasped over her mouth, burning
with shame. She thought that she was
crazy for peeping at the guy and
drooling on him. Bum Taiha sat in a
chair in his apartment, carefully
studying the photo. Yes, he had acted
wrongly, taking advantage of the
situation and deceitfully stealing it
while the girl wasn't looking. But such
a discovery gave him hope that the girl
had truly left her past relationships
behind. After breakfast, Nah Su asked
him to wait while she took a shower and
told him to stay put, not leave, and
especially not enter the bathroom. The
guy obediently stayed sitting on the
floor. He sat tapping his fingers on the
floor until he heard the sound of
running water. Smirking and letting out
a heavy sigh, he tilted his head back
and thought about how much the girl
trusted him. In reality, he had no
intention of calmly sitting and waiting
for her. Making sure she was busy in the
shower, he headed toward her room.
Entering the girl's room, Baumha began
to look around. He was curious about
what she was hiding and whether there
were any traces of her ex-husband left
in her apartment. He methodically opened
each cupboard and every shelf, carefully
examining the girl's belongings. When he
came across a shelf with lingerie, he
pulled out a red lace set and smirked.
It was the very same lingerie she had
accidentally given him instead of a
Christmas gift. He hoped that next time
he would see it on her. Then the guy
stepped into the hallway and made sure
there was nothing there either. He
paused and thought that there really
were no traces left in the apartment of
anyone who had once filled her life. It
seemed like she had gotten rid of
everything, and that couldn't help but
please him. Then he left the apartment,
and near the door by the trash bag, he
found a bundle that seemed to be filled
with old belongings. The guy crouched
down and began to examine the contents.
Although the girl didn't know at that
moment, as he looked at the past she had
so methodically thrown out of her life
with her own hands, Bomb Taiha felt a
tingling sensation, and a sense of
dizziness filled him. He smirked as he
looked at the old photo of the girl with
her bastard
ex-husband. He took pleasure in the fact
that now it was nothing more than a
distant memory, a piece of her past that
no longer held any power over her or
over him. The guy tossed the photo aside
and picked up an old flip phone. It was
dead, but he was certain that the girl
had deleted everything from it before
getting rid of it. Then he froze. At
first, not believing what he saw,
thinking that maybe he was mistaken. He
pulled an ultrasound photo from the
bundle. His heart skipped a beat. He
couldn't even imagine that Nahu could
have a child. Now, the guy sat there
staring at the photo without blinking,
deep in thought. If the girl had thrown
something like this away, decided to
erase it from her life, it meant she was
completely and irreversibly ready to
move on. He swallowed hard, continuing
to think about what she must have gone
through in the past. Suddenly, he heard
LJ's voice, who had arrived at his
request, and the guy immediately flipped
the picture over. He remarked that the
bodyguard had arrived rather quickly and
took a sip from his glass. Li Jay
carefully examined the young master and
was surprised. The man thought to
himself that this guy looked too
satisfied today, smiling and acting so
relaxed. He even felt a bit sorry for
that woman, as he couldn't even imagine
how much he must have deceived her to
now be in such a good mood. Biamont Teha
asked him to play with him. Li Jay asked
if they were going to play Jenga again,
but the guy replied no. He smiled kind
of wildly and said he wanted to play
Monopoly today. The man began to feel
uneasy. The bodyguard tensed up and said
that he wouldn't want to play Monopoly
with someone who in real life could
bankrupt his in-laws and distant
relatives for generations to come if he
so wished. He added that the young
master already lived as if he were
playing games in real life. In the end,
Lij had no choice but to play with him.
Suddenly, the man looked closely at the
young man and realized that something
was off with him. He watched him closely
and noticed that he was acting
strangely. Before, he carried himself as
though he owned the world. But now,
everything felt off, as if something had
shifted. After another loss, Beum Taiha
lifted his gaze to Li Jay, who was
wondering why his young master was so
unlucky today. A wild thought suddenly
crossed the bodyguard's mind. Could it
be that his master had accomplished
something with that auntie? Then he
immediately shook off the thought,
covering his eyes with his hand,
reminding himself that he definitely
should not be noticing such things, let
alone meddling in his employer's private
life. Nahu, feeling a surge of energy,
happily carried out her duties at the
little restaurant. She recalled that
morning she had spent with Bam Teha back
then. After breakfast, the girl said she
would wash the dishes, but the guy
stopped her, saying he would do it
himself since he was good at household
chores. He wanted to do something nice
for her. He smiled sincerely and enjoyed
being able to take care of her. The girl
gave a strange smile and thought to
herself that in reality, he had
oversaled and burned the rice a bit, but
she couldn't bring herself to say
anything against his disarming smile.
She was genuinely touched by his care.
Nahu suddenly noticed the package with
money that had been lying on the floor
since last night. She swallowed,
remembering that he had come to her
bringing the money. A bitter taste rose
in her throat as she couldn't shake off
the question of where he had gotten such
a huge amount from. The girl called out
to him and anxiously asked where all
this money had come from. She looked at
him waiting for an answer. The guy
leaned toward her and asked if she
wanted to take the money for herself.
Nahu blushed and replied that of course
not. those money belong to him. She then
asked why he thought she would want to
take them in the first place. For some
reason, the guy had hoped she would say
that. This girl wasn't materialistic.
What mattered to him was that she wanted
to be with him for who he was, not for
anything else. He smiled and looking a
bit guilty, said that in fact, the money
wasn't real. It was more like a prop for
movies. The girl gave him a reproachful
look and replied that she had suspected
it all along. She asked why he did it.
Did he really think to impressing her
like that? The guy smiled slightly
apologetic and said he was sorry. He
leaned closer to her and in a low voice
replied that he thought without it she
wouldn't want to see him again. There
was a trace of mockery in his tone as it
was exactly what she had said to him
before. Nahesu froze holding the dishes
in her hands. Those were definitely her
words. She thought about how it must
have felt for him to hear that from her.
She turned away, hoping he wouldn't
notice her face turning red with shame.
The girl realized that he had caught her
in a lie. It was strange at one point.
Even when he wasn't around, the girl
could still hear the echo of his voice.
His quiet laugh lazily tickled her.
Despite the embarrassment from the night
they spent together, she felt
comfortable with him, as if she had
returned home after a long journey.
Nahu's body still achd lightly, a
reminder of what had happened between
them. Suddenly, a colleague approached
her and smiling, asked if something good
had happened to her. Nahu stared at her
in confusion, and the colleague
continued, saying that Nahu looked very
happy today, as if she were glowing from
within. The colleague leaned in
conspiratorally and asked if perhaps
Nahu had eaten something sweet. The girl
immediately blushed, unsure of how to
respond. She started to deny it, saying
she hadn't done anything like that. She
really did feel much lighter and
happier, but she didn't think it was so
noticeable. The girl patted her on the
shoulder and said that no matter what,
she looked really good and it suited her
well. Recently, she had noticed that
Nahu seemed a bit down, but she was glad
that everything was good for her now.
She had thought that the girl was upset
because of the previous incident with
the drunk guests, but usually she never
dwelt on such things. Nah, Su suddenly
remembered that lately there had been
much fewer troublemakers and work had
become easier. She had no idea that all
of this was thanks to
Biamha. He along with Li J had dealt
with everyone who caused trouble for
her, making sure they would forever
forget about behaving abusively toward
those weaker than them. The girls felt
like everyone around them had suddenly
taken some sort of medicine for anger,
becoming polite and calm as the number
of problematic clients had dropped to
zero. Baom Taiha was satisfied. No one
dared to inconvenience his woman. He
liked that he had done all of this
behind her back so that she would feel
that even though there are trashy days
in life, good ones always follow them.
The girl truly radiated from within,
feeling how her life was getting better.
If even those around her noticed, it
meant she was really on the right path.
Warmth spread through her soul. At that
time, Mitchell was enjoying the company
of Ahri. Since he now lived with her,
they were constantly absorbed in each
other. Unfortunately, over time,
physical contact became insufficient to
sustain the relationship. Exhausted by
him, the girl lay on the couch and asked
him to make her some ramen. Meanwhile,
the man indifferently buried himself in
his phone. He replied without taking his
eyes off the phone, telling her to make
it herself since he didn't know how. Ary
puckered her lips and said that because
of him, she couldn't even walk properly.
She was hurt that the man used her but
didn't show any attention or care. He
wanted to be pampered but never offering
the same in return. She started kicking
him with her foot and said that there
are guys who cook for their girlfriends
and even help them take a bath while he
always tells her either to sleep or do
it again. Mchel openly ignored her half
listening and muttering something in
response. This angered the girl and she
wrapped her legs around him grabbing his
nose and pulling it cursing at him and
telling him to put his phone down and
listen to her. The man sighed wearily,
thinking about how much of a nuisance
Ari had become and how tired he was of
her. He suddenly remembered how much
easier it was with Nahu. Ari was leaning
against Mchel while he was boiling
water, standing by the stove. The girl,
pleased that she convinced him to cook
dinner for her, asked him to add an egg
to the
ramen. Grumbling, the man said he would
do it and asked her to go wait while he
finished. He opened the pack of noodles
and suddenly memories from his youth
flooded his mind. the first time he had
ever cooked for someone. He and Nahu
were returning home late in the evening,
and by that time, they had been dating
for a while. Suddenly, the girl lifted
her gaze to him and shily asked if she
could have dinner at his place tonight.
Mitchell instantly blushed, never having
brought a girl to his place
before. He became nervous and asked why
all of a sudden she was asking such a
thing. The girl slightly lowered her
head and quietly replied that her father
had returned home. The guy knew what
that meant for her. Her father drank and
caused trouble and he understood why she
didn't want to go back home too soon. So
he replied that of course they could
have dinner at his place. Approaching
his house, he said that they would have
dinner and then he would escort her
home. When they entered, the girl froze,
staring at his living space. Since the
guy hadn't expected guests, the place
was a mess with his underwear and socks
scattered in plain sight. Mitchell
immediately started hastily picking
things up and apologizing.
Meanwhile, the girl stood there in
confusion, watching him. After a moment,
he said that the only thing he had left
to eat was ramen. Nahu said that it
would be fine and began taking off her
outerwear. The guy watched her
nervously, feeling a sense of excitement
building inside him. She seemed calm and
without hesitation settled into his
room. Meanwhile, he felt awkward and
strange as just the day before he had
been fantasizing about this girl. And
now here she was in his house. The guy
swallowed hard, trying to regain his
composure, reminding himself that he had
invited her over only for dinner, and
only because he didn't want her insane
father to harm her. He turned completely
red from the uninvited thoughts filling
his mind and tried to focus on recalling
the proper sequence for making ramen.
When Nahesu leaned towards him and asked
if he wanted her to cook dinner herself,
he tensed up even more and stammered
that there was no need for that. He
quickly stood up and headed to the
kitchen, telling her to sit and wait for
him. Relieved that he could distract
himself for a moment from the thought of
being alone with his girlfriend in an
empty house. Soon, Mitchell triumphantly
placed the pot of ramen in front of her.
The girl stared at the dish in surprise.
It looked really good. She began eating
and thanked him, saying that it was
really delicious. Then she asked if he
wasn't going to eat as well. The guy,
still feeling embarrassed, replied that
he would eat, too. But suddenly, the
girl placed her hand on his thigh and
anxiously said that his nose was
bleeding.
Mchel looked at her, still red from the
tension. He started wiping his nose with
his hand, reassuring her that he was
fine. Nahu continued to worry, asking
where the tissues were and wanting to
help him wipe the blood away. The guy
tried to convince her not to dwell on it
and just eat the ramen. The girl,
overwhelmed with worry, didn't notice
how her hands ended up in a dangerous
zone. They both froze as Mitchell's
tension reached its peak. And Nahu,
finally realizing the situation they
were in and the reason for his
condition, suddenly blushed as well. In
the next moment, her hands were high
above her head and she was pinned to the
floor. The guy leaned over, already
struggling to comprehend what was
happening. They both looked at each
other in embarrassment, led by their
emotions. They barely remembered how it
all started, both clumsy and uncertain.
Mitchell was scared, constantly thinking
about how he thought everything would be
easy and simple. But in reality, he had
no idea what to do. Nahu looked at him
with frightened eyes, just as confused
and lost as he was. The guy saw the girl
start to cry, and he began to blame
himself for causing her pain. His mind
was torn with thoughts, realizing he was
just a self-absorbed idiot who didn't
know what to do to help her, and he
started to panic. In that moment, Nahu
took his face in her hands. She said
that if it was him, everything would be
all right. She kissed him. And for them,
the whole world ceased to exist. In that
moment, it was everything he had dreamed
of every day because it was her and only
her that he had dreamt of. But over
time, phrases like, "I'm tired today."
or "I'm sorry," began to be said too
often and became routine. Mitchell stood
by the stove, smiling faintly, lost in a
melancholic mood. Memories from those
times stirred something in his chest.
He suddenly remembered that there was
another time between him and Nahisu. He
imagined the girl sitting at home going
through his things and wondered if she
felt the sadness of encountering the
emptiness he had left behind when he
walked away from her. Did she regret
pushing him away? Was she crying even
just a little over the wounds he had
inflicted on her? Nahu had always cried
because of the pain he caused her. Yet
she continued to miss him. In his
memories, she was always crying so much
because of him, which is why he hoped
she would keep crying, even more than
before. And even though it hurt her, he
wanted her to come back to him. Nahu was
cleaning the table when she accidentally
overheard a conversation between two
visitors. One of the men was complaining
that he had to turn off his phone
because he was being bombarded with
calls and texts from a woman with whom
he had spent only one night. His friend
laughed at him. He said that after two
times, she would ask him to marry her.
The men laughed and discussed how it was
obvious that since they started with
just a one night stand, there was no
talk of a serious relationship. The girl
listened carefully to their
conversation. Nahu didn't have any false
hopes. She wasn't 18, but 34, so she
didn't lose her head just because
someone told her that he liked her.
Despite the fact that her feelings were
more than just impulsive actions, a
selfish desire to take everything she
could and then leave awoke within her.
She had already seen what relationships
could be like, so she wasn't going to
act as desperately as she might have
before or try too hard. She decided not
to complicate things with unnecessary
thoughts. Relationships could ignite
quickly and burn brightly, but in the
end, they all fade and become cold. A
cold, indifferent
familiarity. The end of love is always
like that. Nahu considered herself just
an insignificant woman he once held
because he had desperately and
tirelessly pursued her. Eventually, he
would realize this himself. People often
deceive themselves into thinking that
the one who gains affection is the
winner. But in her relationship with
Mchol, the winner was him. That's why
she didn't know how to fill the
emptiness left by their vanished
attachment. So, she suppressed
everything inside of her. his
indifference, his contempt, his cold
snears, and his everchanging attitude.
Because if she hadn't, it would have
meant that their relationship had truly
come to an end. So, she meekly accepted
everything. Her thoughts were
interrupted when she suddenly saw Baum
Taiha outside the restaurant window. The
guy was sitting on his motorcycle,
smiling and waving his phone at her,
clearly hinting that she should check
her phone. He looked obscenely handsome.
The girl grabbed her phone and read the
message.
He was asking how she was feeling and if
her body was still hurting. She replied
that everything was fine. The guy looked
at her with a reproachful gaze from
outside the window and gave a slight
smile as if he had caught a little child
in a lie. He slowly said, "It doesn't
seem like it." So she could read his
lips and smiled again, somewhat
condescendingly. Nahu blushed, realizing
that he understood everything and that
he was so cunning. There was nothing
that could be hidden from his gaze.
Suddenly, her phone notified her of a
new SMS. He asked if she would mind
going on a date with him after work. The
girl was so surprised that she slightly
opened her mouth. As if seeking
confirmation that she wasn't imagining
it, she lifted her gaze to the guy who
was smiling at her sweetly, waiting for
her response. Bomb Tayha reminded her of
a cute little puppy, tilting his head in
anticipation.
The girl thought about how youthful love
fades quickly, but in its own way, it's
beautiful. She sent him a short okay and
looked at him gently. In that moment,
the girl decided that although feelings
are fleeting, she couldn't allow herself
to completely break. The silence of the
night was briefly interrupted by the
roar of an engine. The guy stopped and
with a swift motion placed the
motorcycle on its kickstand. Leaning
over, he got off the motorcycle and
carefully reached out to help Nahau Su
take off her helmet. Baam Taiha told her
to wrap her arms around his neck and he
would help her get down since it was too
high for her. The girl grumbled and
asked why he was so tall. She glanced to
the side and saw the familiar staircase
leading to her house. The girl was
surprised because he had invited her on
a date, but in the end, they had ended
up at her home. The guy noticed the
change in her expression and while she
was distracted, he pulled her into his
arms and asked if she was upset. The
girl hit her face and pretended not to
understand what he was talking about.
Then Bom Taiha said that he really
wanted to spend more time with her. He
hugged her tighter and the girl admitted
that she felt the same way. His scent
filled her lungs and she felt a sense of
comfort and warmth in his arms. Nahi Su
wrapped her arms around his neck,
inhaling his scent deeply as the guy
continued to hold her in his embrace. He
knew that each day for her felt too
short because of the overwhelming amount
of work, and that she would have to
sacrifice her sleep for every desire she
dares to pursue. Baam Taiha stood
looking her in the eyes and said that he
knew she was busy and that he would
patiently wait for her without
complaints. They were climbing the
familiar stairs when the girl suddenly
asked if the gloves she had given him
fit. The guy smiled, her, and lied,
saying they fit perfectly. She told him
not to ride with cold hands and not to
hesitate to wear them. Then, a little
embarrassed, she said that if they wore
out, she would buy him new ones. She
remembered herself when she was younger.
The girl had always been afraid to wear
new things because she treasured them so
much and feared damaging them. As a
result, most of them remained unused and
eventually lost their relevance. She
looked at his hands and thought that he
really should use it and that probably
his hands had gotten very cold while
riding. Unexpectedly for herself, she
reached out and placed her palm in his
hand. Biamha, not expecting such a
gesture from her, silently looked at her
in surprise. Seeing him look at their
intertwined fingers, the girl blushed
and stammered, explaining that she had
taken his hand because she thought he
was cold and because there was a strong
wind today. Her heart was pounding
wildly with nervousness. Seeing him look
at their intertwined fingers, the girl
blushed and stammered, explaining that
she had taken his hand because she
thought he was cold and because there
was a strong wind today. Her heart was
pounding wildly with nervousness. Biamha
smiled joyfully and gently. He was so
happy that it felt as though a glow had
appeared around him, and he said that he
felt incredibly warm thanks to her. The
guy walked, casting occasional glances
at the girl, feeling a growing joy in
his chest. Nahu thought about how
usually after physical closeness,
touches become routine. But now, holding
his hand, a variety of emotions surged
within her, including embarrassment. His
large and warm body heat makes her feel
like her nerves are tangled at the tips
of her fingers. Nahu felt embarrassed
and wasn't sure if she had the right to
experience such feelings for this young
man, but she really enjoyed it.
Approaching the house, her cheeks and
ears were burning with
embarrassment. She awkwardly lowered her
head and whispered that they had
arrived. She didn't want to let go of
his hand, not wanting to break the
warmth that was flowing between them.
Finally, she pulled her hand away, and
the cold air burned her skin where his
hand had just been. She reminded herself
again that she shouldn't be harboring
false hopes. She thought it was the
right thing to do. So she turned to him
facing him and said that she didn't want
him to misunderstand her. She asked if
he understood that there couldn't be any
serious relationship between them. Bomha
lazily smiled and said that he hadn't
thought that way. But the girl responded
that he himself had suggested she use
him even if she wasn't ready to give him
her heart. But he wasn't planning to
rush her. The girl stared at him in
shock, unable to believe that he would
actually agree to the fact that all she
wanted from him was just his body.
Although he claimed to be more innocent
than she thought, she knew that wasn't
true. From his mere appearance, it was
clear that he was far more experienced
than he let on. She felt deceived as she
looked at this handsome and statuesque
man. Meanwhile, he stood there calmly
looking at her as if waiting for her to
say or offer something more. Nahes Su
turned away, embarrassed by her own
frank thoughts, and told him to go home
and not get involved in any trouble on
the way. She slowly descended the
stairs, hearing his leisurely, lazy
steps behind her, as if he were a little
puppy, following closely on her heels.
She looked back at him several times,
each time meeting his sweet smile.
Finally, she asked why he was following
her. Beamha approached her, leaning in
and said that his wounds were still
aching. He asked if she could apply some
more ointment on them.
He smiled with the corner of his lips.
The girl could feel his broad chest
against her back. Her pulse quickened
and her mouth went dry. She said that he
was capable of applying the ointment
himself because the way he was speaking
made it seem like he had hidden motives.
Suddenly, she heard his deep chuckle and
the guy reached out, leaning against the
wall, effectively trapping her. He
quietly said that she was right. Nahu
turned to him, her face burning with
confusion, and found herself staring
into his laughing eyes. The guy smiled
and his breath brushed against her
cheek. He softly said that he just
wanted to flirt with her. The girl felt
something ignite inside her. Her
breathing quickened, but she said that
he shouldn't behave like this with
someone older and that she would punish
him. Bumha smirked, his voice low and
horsearo. He agreed with her. Then he
pulled her into his embrace, resting his
head on her shoulder, and asked her to
hug him goodbye. At that moment, she was
enveloped by his warmth. The girl could
feel his heart beating strongly through
the fabric of their clothes. He held her
gently, as if she might shatter into a
thousand pieces at any moment, yet
tightly at the same time, as if afraid
this might be the last time. Biamha felt
the girl shudder when his breath brushed
against her neck, and her arms
instinctively pulled him closer. He
inhaled her scent and then leaned
towards her neck. He kissed her and the
girl couldn't hold back a soft sigh. She
reached out to him, gently trailing her
hand from his jaw to his neck. Nahesu
tilted her head back, giving him more
access, and the guy reached the
throbbing vein, her quiet size caressed
his
hearing. Finally, he turned his face
towards hers, their breath mingling so
she could feel it on the tip of her
tongue.
The girl opened her lips in anticipation
of the kiss. She lifted her face,
looking at him from beneath her
half-loed lashes, and their gazes
met. But Baum Tha was watching her
closely. In the next moment, he pulled
away from her and said that since she
wanted it so badly, he would go home and
they would see each other
tomorrow. Nahu looked at him in
confusion, still not fully catching her
breath.
She slowly opened the door and while he
stood there watching, the girl stepped
inside and managed to say she would see
him tomorrow. As soon as the door closed
behind her, the girl slid down, holding
her burning cheeks in
embarrassment. She had just realized
that she almost invited him to stay
again, and she really wanted that, but
she was scared because she had never
acted like this before. On the table
lays personal file, and there was a
bottle of expensive wine. Chairman Biam
Ju frowned as he looked out the window,
hands shoved into his pockets and said
that he hadn't received any reports from
his son's bodyguard in quite a while.
One of his men immediately expressed his
willingness to get in touch with him.
The man simply raised his hand in a
silent gesture, signaling to the
bodyguard to be quiet. Then, in a steely
voice, he said that he would handle the
matter himself. Li stood in the young
master's apartment, forcing a smile as
he thought about how he could never
understand his mood. Whether he was in a
good mood, angry, or just irritated, his
facial expression was unreadable. Bomb
Taiha simply lay on the couch putting
gloves on the teddy bear. Both gifts
from the girl, staring at the toy while
lost in his own thoughts. The windows in
the apartment were wide open despite the
cold weather, and the wind was sweeping
through the place, making the man stand
there,
shivering. He wondered why the guy had
turned the house into a fridge. Unable
to hold back, he asked if the young
master had accidentally planned to catch
a cold. Bum Taiha, still thoughtfully
spinning the teddy bear in his hands,
replied that he was actually hoping for
that. The man smirked and asked if it
wasn't enough that the guy had allowed
himself to be beaten. His expensive,
handsome face was covered in bruises and
scratches, but instead of calming down,
he continued to sulk. The guy smirked in
response and said that it was indeed
true.
He was thinking about what else he
needed to do for her to be satisfied. He
thought about how he had already given
her his love and his first time. Then he
said aloud that he had given this girl
everything he had, but it still wasn't
enough. The man sighed, averting his
gaze and said that perhaps the young
master simply wasn't to her taste. After
all, looking at her ex-husband, it was
clear they were completely different
types. LJ replied that life wasn't a
board game and that it would be boring
if everything always went according to
plan. He said that in life it often
happens that you can be used and then
thrown away. The guy froze and looked at
the bodyguard strangely, saying nothing
in response to his last remark. Then he
sat down, scratched the back of his
head, and said that he was giving him
the day off tomorrow, so he didn't need
to come to him. At that moment, Nahu,
lying alone in her apartment, was
consumed by conflicting emotions.
She felt lonely in her bed now after
having experienced how warm it could be
next to Baum Taiha. At the same time,
she scolded herself for so desperately
wanting to invite him. The guy
mysteriously told Li that he didn't plan
to spend tomorrow night at home. After
that, a sly smile spread across his
face. The room was filled with size and
loud breathing. Biami was spending time
with another girl, but even she couldn't
distract him from his thoughts. He
leaned over the girl and looked at her
with irritation. He was frustrated that
his younger brother wouldn't leave his
mind. Even in moments like this, then
without pausing, the young man suddenly
asked if the girl knew what his younger
brother was up to. The girl didn't
understand who or what he was asking
about. But Bey continued to grow angry
and said that she must have many
acquaintances, so she might have met
him. The guy felt his anger mixing with
pleasure, but the girl kept babbling
that she didn't understand anything of
what he was saying. When he finally
pushed his sweat-drenched hair back and
tried to catch his breath, the girl
asked who the hell this brother was that
Biam kept grumbling about. The young man
replied that he was just some bastard
and walked into the next room. There on
the couch, his friend was waiting for
him and asked if he had finished his
business. The young man sat down next to
him and asked for a light. He exhaled a
puff of smoke and said that what
bothered him was how quiet it was. Then
tilting his head back, he said that he
was sure the bastard hadn't died, but
not a single soul around knew what he
was up to. Either he finally understood
where he belonged or something else
entirely. He asked if it even made sense
that a guy with such looks and abilities
wasn't dating any girl. His friend asked
who he was talking about and Biamont he
replied that it was about his younger
brother. The guy finally remembered how
his friend used to beat the small, pale
boy with the sweet face every day. He
asked if it was about him. The young man
said he almost felt like vomiting. He
told his friend that the bastard was now
a head taller than him. His friend
laughed and said he must be joking. He
put out his cigarette and said that in
any case, he was the young master and
with his status, he couldn't have a
girlfriend. It must be that his younger
brother's tastes were different from
his. The guy suggested that perhaps his
brother preferred older women. Biami
took a drag and said that he couldn't
stand women older than him. They always
look at him with disapproval as if they
were constantly trying to teach him
something. It pisses him off. His friend
smirked and said that's exactly what
turns most men on. He said men have a
damn wide range of preferences. The guy
sighed wearily and said that Korea was
damn boring. His friend asked why he
didn't leave then, but Bayam Teahhei
replied that he absolutely wouldn't do
that right now. He said the chairman had
to make a decision soon, so he had to be
here. He wasn't going to let that
bastard get a penny under any
circumstances. He grinned wildly and
said that all the money and power should
belong to him alone. Biamha sat on the
floor of the room he despised and
wearily watched the setting sun through
the large windows. Suddenly, delicate
feminine hands appeared before his eyes.
They gently touched his face, covering
his eyes as if trying to shield him from
the world. In his mind, he pleaded to be
allowed to just escape, to simply
disappear. Suddenly, the hands parted,
and he heard a voice reminding him that
he should not let his feelings be
discovered. A woman's hand gently
touched his cheek, carefully brushing
over the wound, and the guy felt the
fingertips slowly pull away, taking the
warmth and care with them. In the next
moment, Biamha opened his eyes and the
terrible dream faded away. The teddy
bear gently embraced him with its plush
paw. The guy lay on the couch hugging
the stuffed animal. The bear's paw was
wearing gloves that Nahu had given him
as a gift. He remembered how she had
told him that the teddy bear would keep
nightmares away from him. He ran his
fingers over the spot where the wound
used to be and where now he felt the
gentle touch of the girl through his
sleep. A faint smile spread across his
face as he pressed his hand to his cheek
as if he could touch the girl's hand. He
hugged the stuffed animal close,
inhaling the familiar scent and feeling
glad that it still carried Nahu's
fragrance before drifting off into a
peaceful sleep. Nahu pondered the
emptiness left after Kang Mchel's
departure. And she didn't mean just the
empty house or the bed that had grown
colder without the warmth of his body.
While doing the calculations, she
realized that despite spending more than
usual in the past few months, she felt
freer and even had more money left than
she had
anticipated. It was a relief as she
could pay off a significant portion of
the main debt and interest. She knew
that the traces of her youth remained as
a debt she still had to repay even
without Kang Mitchell. All the time
spent with him and now without him still
left her living hard and working
tirelessly, constantly under pressure.
She remembered their last meeting with
Bomb Taiha and how he had said that he
knew she worked a lot and that he would
wait patiently without complaining. The
girl pondered even if just for a little
while. Didn't she have the right to take
a full breath and feel free? Can't she
allow herself to be a little greedy? Her
voice echoed in the room. She called her
boss and said that she wouldn't be able
to come to work today. Beam Taiha stood
outside the girl's house exhaling hot
vapor into the cold air. His plan had
worked and today he felt as though he
was sick. He lowered his medical mask
from his face. He waited patiently for
the girl. Raising his eyes to the sky.
His eyes were red and it was clear that
his temperature would soon spike. Soon
the door opened and the girl peeked out.
She anxiously asked if he had waited for
too long and the guy replied that he had
just arrived. She stood next to him,
awkwardly looking at him. She knew he
thought he would walk her to work, not
realizing that her plans had changed.
Gathering her courage, she asked if he
was busy today. The guy looked at her
with interest and then replied, "No."
Nahisu was nervous about how he would
react, but she asked if he minded taking
a walk with her today. The guy asked in
surprise. "What about
work?" The girl quickly replied that she
had taken the day off because she wanted
to buy some things. Bomb Taiha was
genuinely surprised by this turn of
events. She had managed to catch him off
guard, but then Nahu noticed something
was off with him. She said that his face
looked swollen and that he appeared to
be sick. She suggested that if that was
the case, he should go
rest. The guy tightly clenched the
handkerchief behind his back and replied
that he was fine. Although it was clear
he was lying, Bomb Taiha said that he
felt perfectly fine and wanted to spend
time with her. The girl looked at him
skeptically and became worried. She
reached out and touched his face, then
said that he was burning up. The guy
smiled sweetly and said that he was just
young and healthy, so he had a lot of
warmth. Nahu still suspected that he was
hiding something from her. She knew she
wouldn't be able to convince him given
how persistent he was. So, she started
thinking about where young people go to
spend time together. After all, back in
the day, she and Mitchell only went to
school, to his house, and occasionally
to karaoke. They started walking slowly
and the girl asked if there was anything
he wanted to do together. The guy walked
leisurely, matching her pace, and asked
if there was something like that. Would
she really agree to do it with him? He
paused for a moment and looked at her
with interest, thinking about what he
definitely wanted to do. In his mind, a
plan quickly started to form. Their
hands found each other and intertwined
so naturally, as if by instinct. Both of
them simultaneously felt the warmth that
connected them. After her quiet and
confident yes, Bomba smiled sincerely
with a mischievous boyish grin and said
that she had just made him a promise and
now she wouldn't be able to back out.
Joy filled him. The young girls stood at
the mirror adjusting their hairstyles
and makeup. They chatted happily about
how beautiful they looked and decided
they needed to take a few more photos.
Suddenly, one of the girls became upset
when a shadow loomed over her. She
turned around and asked what the hell
happened.
Did a wall just suddenly appear next to
her? As he passed by, Beum Ta shot the
girls a cold, disdainful glance. The
girls immediately blushed upon seeing
such a handsome guy and began whispering
about how tall and attractive he was.
They started debating which one of them
should approach him and ask for his
number. Meanwhile, the guy embracing
Nahu led her into a booth. One of the
girls replied that she was ready to
approach him, but asked if her friends
had noticed that there was a woman next
to him. Baom Taiha embraced the girl
trying to show with his every gesture
that everything was fine. The girl
hearing the whispers of the other girls
felt embarrassed and uncomfortable. Nahu
asked where they had come to. The guy
replied that it was something like a
sticker photo booth. The girl blushed
and said that she wasn't familiar with
such things, adding that if he wanted to
do something like that, he should do it
with his friends. Bam. Taiha leaned
closer to her and asked if she was
refusing.
He really wanted to take at least one
photo with her. He looked like a little
puppy. The girl couldn't bring herself
to refuse him as he looked so cute.
Seeing the girl blush, the guy playfully
poked her cheeks and smiling said that
she looked so cute when she pouted. The
girl became even more embarrassed and
told him to look at the camera. Bam.
Taiha replied that he was already
looking, but in reality, he couldn't
take his eyes off her. At first, she was
embarrassed, but soon they began to fool
around, letting their feelings be
genuine and carefree. As they left, they
received two copies of the photos where
the young couple looked incredibly
happy, as if they were scenes from a
movie. The guy asked if the photos
turned out great, and Nahu agreed. He
suggested that each of them take a photo
as a keepsake. The girl couldn't help
but stare at him. He was holding the
small photos and looked so content. She
found it incredibly cute that a guy
who's built like a door could be so
excited over it. Then suddenly she
remembered his face from that night. How
he looked and how he gazed at her and
her cheeks turned bright red. The girl
closed her eyes in embarrassment. She
shouldn't be thinking about such things.
And how could such an adult guy look so
cute? Bum Taiha looked at her in
surprise. In the next moment, she felt
something soft gently wrap around her
neck. Biama draped his scarf around her
and cupping her face with his hands
looked at her with a wide smile. His
eyes sparkled with joy as he suggested
they to move on to the next thing. Soon
they found themselves in a clothing
store where a polite consultant
immediately greeted them. They entered
the store hand in hand and the girl
asked if he wanted to buy new
clothes. The guy smiled mischievously
and nodded in agreement.
She thought to herself that she wasn't
very good with clothes, but she would do
her best to help him choose. Nahu looked
at the exquisite items around her,
thinking to herself that they were
probably so expensive that she would
never be able to afford anything like
that. Suddenly, the guy appeared in
front of her, holding a beautiful blouse
and asking if she liked it. He was
nervous as he didn't know much about
women's clothing. The girl liked it at
first glance and asked if he was really
planning to buy it for her. The guy
looked pleased and nodded in agreement.
The girl felt uneasy. She blushed and
replied that he had already given her
clothes before, and it would be better
if he spent the money on something
delicious for himself, as clothes were
really expensive right now. But then she
heard him respond that he had saved up a
little, and that everything was fine.
She remembered the young Mitchell, and
how in the beginning he had also tried
so hard for her. She sighed as she had
long stopped receiving such gestures of
affection and hadn't felt cared for in a
long time. Suddenly, the consultant
appeared next to them and chirped that
they made such a beautiful and cute
couple. The guy immediately smiled
proudly while the girl blushed. The
woman apologized for the interruption
and offered her help. She friendly
scanned the girl from head to toe and
then asked Biamha if he was picking out
clothes for his girlfriend. The guy
proudly answered, "Yes." And the woman
smiled widely, saying that she was even
a little envious. She praised him for
being so attentive to his girlfriend.
Then she started showing him clothes
that would perfectly compliment Hi Su's
fair skin. The consultant picked out
very beautiful and highquality blouses
and pants while the guy carefully
examined each piece. Nahu stood in
shock, surrounded by a pile of clothes
that had been set aside for her, and
tried to say that she didn't need any of
it. While the girl was in confusion, the
woman gave her a strange look. Then the
woman approached her with a pair of very
beautiful pants made from highquality
fabric. The girl could tell they must be
very expensive. But the consultant
assured her that there were huge
discounts in their store only for today.
And all these items could be bought at a
very low price. The girl took the pants
in her hands and couldn't believe that
such a highquality item could be so
cheap, only 9,900 Korean one. It felt
like she had stepped into a fairy tale.
The woman gave a mischievous smile and
told the girl to let the guy spoil her a
little
today. Baam Taiha stood off to the side,
watching with a content expression as
the girl enjoyed picking out clothes. He
kept picking out and setting aside one
piece of clothing after another until
the girl finally stopped him and said
that she simply couldn't handle so many
clothes. Soon, the young couple left the
store with their arms full of shopping
bags. The guy looked pleased with
himself while the girl nervously pressed
the bag to her chest, wondering if
perhaps she shouldn't have let him spend
so much money on her. Of course, all
these items were not expensive
individually, but together they added up
to quite a hefty sum. The girl was
worried that he might later regret
spending so much on her. Suddenly, her
thoughts were interrupted by the guy's
voice. He asked her to give him all the
bags so that it wouldn't be too heavy
for her.
Nahu pondered deeply, realizing that
sometimes his unquestionable kindness
scared her. And even though their
connection was fleeting, she feared that
one day he might regret meeting her,
just as she was sure Mitchell had
regretted it. She told the guy that next
month after receiving her salary, she
would buy him something as well. The guy
was surprised and said that it wasn't
necessary. But the girl replied that it
didn't feel right to be the one who only
receives. Gifts should be exchanged.
When she said that she would definitely
repay him, Biamha's mood immediately
soured. He wasn't doing all of this to
get something in return, but he simply
replied, "All right." He understood that
she hadn't meant to offend him, but
still, it stung a little. He wished
things were simpler, and that Nahu could
just enjoy receiving gifts from him
without overthinking it. But no matter
how much he searched for an answer to
this question, even if he eventually
found one, he was sure there wouldn't be
an easy solution. So he walked up to the
girl and gently touching her took her
hand. The girl said that they still had
plenty of time and asked where else he
would like to go with her. Baum Taiha
smiled and replied that if he told her
everything, one day wouldn't be enough.
To his surprise, the girl answered that
if they didn't manage to do everything
today, they could just continue the next
day. Then the guy suddenly hugged her
from behind and thought to himself,
"What will happen if he constantly feels
like there's not enough time with her to
the point where it becomes unbearable?"
He asked her, "What if next time they
don't have enough time either and kept
holding her tightly?" Trapped in his
arms, the girl felt embarrassed and
asked, "Why should that be a problem?"
She promised that she would find time
for him again and again. Hearing this,
the guy let out a relieved sigh, but
didn't release her from the hug. Nahu
felt embarrassed as they were standing
in the middle of the street and told him
that he wasn't a little kid and that his
hair was tickling her. She enjoyed
feeling his strong, big arms and the
warmth of his body. But she told him
that they needed to hurry and go to
wherever he wanted next. He really did
feel like an anxious child. The guy
carefully adjusted her collar to cover
the hickey on her neck. The blouse was
cheap and he wondered if she'd throw it
away without regret after using it. He
was afraid the same thing might happen
to him. After that, the young couple
went to a cafe where Bjom Taiha couldn't
take his eyes off the girl. Then they
walked through the park holding hands
and eating bongjopang. Afterward, they
visited the oceanarium. They were
mesmerized as they watched the fish and
the large shark, receiving a wave of
emotions from the experience. By Taiha
was glowing with happiness like a little
child. Meanwhile, Nahu thought that she
needed a break. It had been too long
since she had walked around so much. She
thought that the guy was full of energy
compared to her and probably it was due
to the age difference. She said she was
going to the bathroom for a bit and
asked him to wait. The guy agreed. The
girl glanced at the guy who was
patiently standing among the passers by
holding the bags. He stood out in the
crowd with his bright appearance.
Suddenly, the guy heard the voices of
girls chattering excitedly and
addressing him. He indifferently shifted
his gaze to the two girls. One of them
smiled at him and asked if he remembered
her. At that moment, Nahisu returned and
glancing around began looking for the
guy. Finally, she froze seeing the scene
before her. Her foolish heart skipped a
beat. Beum Tayah was standing there,
smiling charmingly as he chatted with a
very attractive and young girl. The two
of them looked very beautiful and
harmonious together. The girl stood
uncertain, watching what was happening.
And suddenly, the girls began to leave,
and one of them shouted to the guy as a
parting remark, telling him not to
regret his decision later. and winked.
Finally, Nahu approached him and the guy
immediately smiled at her. She asked who
the girl was that he had been talking
to. Biamha replied without hesitation
that it was just some unfamiliar girl.
The girl felt a little sad. She had
anticipated this that the procession of
women around him would be endless. After
all, many people have similar tastes. It
would be very strange if someone didn't
fall in love with Baum Teha at first
sight given his appearance. The girl
thought that it wasn't so much the
glamorous lives of the people passing
by, but rather his constant kindness and
care that made her feel insignificant.
Beam Taiha noticed how the girl
nervously gripped the strap of her bag.
He realized she was upset and silently
took her hand in his, gently
intertwining their fingers. Nahu looked
up at their intertwined hands in
surprise, feeling the warmth radiating
from him. Then suddenly, she asked if
that girl liked him, to which the guy
immediately responded negatively.
She wanted to ask something else, but
then thought that maybe she was being
too curious. It would probably be
strange to feel jealous and asked such
questions since she had decided there
was nothing serious between them.
Suddenly, the guy leaned towards her and
quietly said that the girl was just good
at reading faces. He flashed a
mischievous smile and looked at the
surprised girl with attention. She
raised her gaze to him and with interest
asked what kind of face reading happens
on the street. Then the guy became
serious, not taking his eyes off Nahu,
and replied that the girl had told him
his future was full of misfortune. She
said he was born unhappy, would wander
and live a life full of sorrow and that
his life would be short. The girl
listened in horror, her eyes growing
wider and filling with concern. Noticing
her concern, the guy smiled inwardly and
continued, saying that fortunately, if
he met the right person, he would have a
chance at a happy life. He leaned in
conspiratorally closer to the girl's
face and said that the woman would be 10
years older than him with the surname na
and name ending
ensue. In that moment, his tone was
serious and dramatic. For a moment, an
awkward silence hung between them. The
guy burst out laughing while the girl
blushed and became angry with herself
for listening so attentively and
trustingly to him. She turned away and
said that it was too cruel of a joke on
her. He kept laughing loudly and
contagiously. She then asked if he
really thought she was that gullible.
The young couple walked along the
waterfront, playfully arguing while
holding hands. Nahu pouted, saying she
was upset and was going to leave, adding
that he could eat his ramen alone. Biam
Taiha pretended to be horrified and
asked if she had used him and was now
abandoning him. Hearing this, the girl
blushed and asked him not to say such
things in public.
They laughed, chatted, and flirted
happily. The guy looked at her warmly,
thinking to himself that the world of
this girl moved slower than usual, even
to forget her withered love. It took her
more time than it did for others. He
admired her smile and the way she
blushed, thinking to himself that she,
slowly warming up, shone in the most
tenderly. He was waiting for the moment
when her heart would thaw for him. He
was curious about when she, the one who
had been drowning in the cold for so
long, would finally warm up. He was more
than willing to be the one to heat her.
Biama suddenly tugged on the girl's
hand, pulling her closer to him. He
hugged her tightly, pouring all his
feelings into the embrace, making it
clear that she could continue asking
questions, no matter how
annoying. He was ready to prove it to
her, no matter how much she demand.
Meanwhile, in another part of the city,
a woman exhaled a cloud of smoke and
smiled. Li Jay sat on the edge of the
bed, listening to her playful reproach
about how he had been ignoring her
messages. The man wearily rubbed his
neck and said that he works as a
personal assistant to a young master on
a 24-hour schedule, and that he was
finally given a day off after a long
time. The woman smiled and asked if his
employer was really that strict. He
smirked and replied that if it were only
about that, he would be happy. The man
said that he was completely insane and
that he didn't know what to do about it.
He recalled how recently Bam Ta had
given him the task of bringing items to
the boutique and negotiating with the
consultant. The woman had refused to
believe it wasn't a joke until the very
end, constantly asking where the hidden
camera was. She looked at the items he
had brought and said that it was the
first time she had seen such expensive
things being asked to be sold at a
discount. She added that one would have
to be a real psycho to pull something
like that off. Lijay could only smile
humbly and agree. The problem was that
the young master knew he was crazy, yet
still continued to make such actions.
The woman snapped him out of his
thoughts and after taking him a drag,
asked him what his master's name was.
The man smiled and replied that he
couldn't tell her because if he let his
tongue slip, he might find himself
buried somewhere high in the mountains.
He merely said that she would be
surprised to hear his master's name.
The woman ran her hand across his chest
and replied that he should have agreed
to accept his allowance as dealing with
such people was very dangerous for one's
life. But the man caught her hand and
said that he was too short on things
like allowance, so he couldn't do that.
Meanwhile, Baum Taiha and Nah Su entered
the supermarket to buy instant ramen.
They decided to get just one to share as
they had already eaten quite a bit
earlier. They headed towards the river
to eat, watching the sunset. Suddenly,
the girl asked what else he would like
to do that they hadn't done yet today.
The guy smiled and looked at her. He
said there were so many things he wanted
to do. He didn't even know where to
start. The girl mentally listed
everything they had done today. They
took photos in a photo booth, chatted at
a cafe, visited the oceanarium, ate
bongo pang, and now they were sitting by
the riverbank eating. It seemed like
they had done a lot already, but she
asked him to name at least one or two
more things. Bomb Taiha replied that he
would like to go shopping with her and
cook a warm dinner together. He also
wanted to try tarot cards or to see his
love fortune. He smiled and said he had
never done anything like that before.
The girl listened carefully and after
looking at him, she thought that it was
unlikely because he hadn't had a
girlfriend before, as she was sure he
had had many. It seemed like he just had
never looked into his love fortune. She
paused for a moment and replied that
these predictions rarely come true. The
guy asked curiously if she had ever had
her fortune told, and the girl responded
that she had once. Nahu remembered how a
long time ago she and Mchel had gone to
learn about their futures. The elderly
woman pointed her finger at the young
man and said that he should treat his
girlfriend very well and take good care
of her. Mchel was excited and said that
he was already doing so, asking Nahu to
confirm it. The woman sighed and told
him that he should continue acting this
way so that later he wouldn't feel
ashamed of his behavior. Then the old
woman looked at the girl carefully and
pointing at her asked if she was older
than her
boyfriend. But he replied that he was
older. He grumbled that he had been told
she was an excellent fortune teller, but
it turned out she was just a charlatan.
He pulled the girl by the hand and told
her not to listen to this nonsense and
that they were leaving. The woman kept
muttering that it was strange, but she
could see that the guy destined for her
was younger than her. Finally, she
warned the girl that she should be
careful with men and not trust them
blindly. The young couple was already at
the door, and Mitchell was covering the
girl's ears so she wouldn't hear what he
considered nonsense coming from the old
woman. Through the door, the last
warning could be heard. The woman told
Nah Su to be careful until a leech with
a black heart attached itself to her and
drained the life out of her. And
although it wasn't tarot cards or love
fortune, the feeling from the visit
still felt strange to her. She didn't go
into detail with Bumha, only saying that
it wasn't a very pleasant
experience. The guy said that in that
case, if she didn't like such things,
she shouldn't do them. Then he suddenly
looked above her head and said that they
had picked the perfect time as the
sunset was just beginning. He told the
girl to look at how beautiful it was.
Nahes Su turned around to look in the
same direction and froze in awe at the
breathtaking beauty. They stood on the
riverbank, their eyes fixed on the sky
where the stunning sunset wrapped the
city in golden and pink hues. Sunlight
danced on the water, reflecting its glow
and creating an enchanting atmosphere in
which they both forgot everything. Lost
in the moment, the girl was so
captivated by the view that she couldn't
take her eyes off it for a long time.
silently enjoying the beauty of the
moment while Bea Taiha in turn couldn't
take his eyes off her. Suddenly, she
softly said that when he suggested
having ramen by the river earlier, he
didn't actually want to eat ramen. The
guy continued to watch her intently, not
giving an answer, as the girl had
already figured everything out on her
own. She gazed at the stunning soft
sunset and quietly thanked him for the
beautiful moment. Now she realized with
painful clarity that even the purest
love could turn into something ugly,
leaving only the bitter aftertaste of
broken promises. Biamha watched the girl
intently and noticed how her excitement
shifted to a subtle sadness. He wondered
what she was thinking in that moment. He
understood that Nah Su was not naive
enough to believe in childish innocent
love. He caught her attention and
holding out the bowl of ramen asked if
he could ask her to hold it for a
moment.
The girl took it in her hands and looked
at him with curiosity. In the next
moment, to her surprise, the guy cuped
her face with his hands and pulled her
toward him. She froze in surprise as the
guy's lips gently touched hers in a soft
kiss. Nahu knew that he would be the one
to remain sincere in his love until the
very end, but she always believed that
the time for their farewell would
eventually come, and she responded to
his kiss, not wanting to waste any time,
as she believed they had so little of it
left.
and she felt a deep sense of regret. The
young couple stood in the golden rays of
the setting sun, kissing as if the world
around them had frozen, savoring the
moment and the desire to remain in it,
to melt away into each other. After some
time, the young couple decided to
fulfill another one of the guy's wishes
and went to the supermarket to buy
groceries for dinner. Nah, Su was
determined. Since there was only an hour
left before closing and many people were
trying to grab the discounted groceries,
the girl told him to stay close to her
and not get
lost. By Taiha watched her with a smile.
The girl carefully examined the shelves,
thinking about what to buy right away to
prepare breakfast. Leaning on the
shopping cart, the guy watched her
closely and thought that even though she
had said there was only a physical
relationships between them, right now it
felt as if they were living together.
Meanwhile, Mitchell and Ari got into the
car after finishing work. He took the
driver's seat in her car and asked her
to fasten her seat belt. The girl let
out a heavy sigh and said she was too
tired, asking him to do it for her. The
man reluctantly leaned over and fastened
her seat belt. She looked at him
attentively and suddenly asked if he
thought she should change her car.
Mitchell was surprised and asked why
since there was nothing wrong with the
current car. The girl replied that since
he was the one primarily using it,
something cooler might suit him better.
The man chuckled, thinking to himself
that she was treating it like some kind
of whim. He sarcastically asked where
she was magically going to find the
money for a new car, considering their
salaries weren't exactly high. Ary gave
him an innocent smile and replied that
she could just crash the car somewhere
and ask her father to buy her a new one.
She was confident he wouldn't refuse
her. After all, he had always fulfilled
her every wish. The man smirked,
surprised by how someone could be so
careless and useless. It was rather
amusing, as this type of person
attracted him precisely because they
were different, not like he and Nahu.
The privilege of speaking such things in
such a casual tone, that carefree
attitude that allowed the girl to grow
up under the care of parents who were
always ready to help her no matter what
happened. At first, her carefree and
light-hearted nature was refreshing to
him, but over time, it began to
suffocate him. Ary interrupted his
thoughts, saying that she didn't want to
go home. She wanted to go on a date. The
man replied that he was tired after work
and just wanted to rest. But the girl
pouted and said that she was tired of
always working and being at home. She
added that he was acting like an old
man. He replied that he was indeed an
old man. Then the girl looked at him
carefully and decided to ask something
that had been on her mind for a while.
She hesitantly asked if he ever thought
about having a child with her. Mchel was
surprised and bristled. He replied that
she should seriously think about such
things before speaking. But the girl got
offended and said that she wanted to
marry him and that she had been
seriously thinking about it for a long
time. Weighing everything carefully, he
reached out to her and said that she was
still too young. The girl got upset and
said that she was already 26 and that he
was fine with doing everything else with
her. But whenever the conversation
turned to marriage, he always said it
was too soon. He got tired of listening
to her talk and decided to stop her
chatter by silencing her with a kiss.
While he was kissing her, his hand went
lower and began to undo the buttons of
her blouse, which made all thoughts
immediately disappear from the girl's
head. Pulling away from her, the man
looked into her clouded eyes and watched
as she blushed and began to breathe
frequently. Then he coldly said that he
didn't treat her like a child and asked
if she was satisfied. Now Ari's
embarrassment turned into anger and
indignation. She lowered her head,
hiding the tears that were already
welling in her eyes, and said that it
irritated her how he always avoided
answering like this. She knew she loved
him more than he loved her, so she
tolerated a lot, but she really wanted
to marry him. She asked him to seriously
think about it. Mchel sat behind the
wheel with an indifferent expression,
thinking about how tired he had become
of her. Arriving at the girl's house,
Bea Taiha smiled and thanked her for
spending the day with him, saying that
he had a wonderful time.
Nahu was also glad and responded that
she should be the one thanking him for
such a wonderful day. The guy looked at
her carefully and said that it was time
for him to go. However, when he heard
her surprised question asking if he was
really leaving, a satisfied smile spread
across his face and he answered yes. The
girl, feeling shy, asked him not to
leave. She softly said that there was
still one more thing on his list of
desires that he wanted to do. With a
voice trembling from nervousness, she
said that he should stay to finish it.
Behum Taiha stood still, towering over
her, feeling satisfied as he thought
about all the desires he still had
regarding her. He felt pleasure spread
through his body, and with a sly squint,
he asked what she meant. He saw how cute
she looked, blushing despite what had
already happened between them, and it
amused him. Smiling, he asked what she
meant, as he wasn't entirely sure what
she was referring to. Nahu blushed and
replied that he had mentioned going to
the store together and cooking. Since he
had made breakfast for her last time,
she wanted to cook breakfast for him
this time. The girl stood there, hiding
her eyes and biting her lip in
nervousness, realizing how it sounded
and
looked. The guy studied her intently,
making her even more anxious as he
silently admitted to himself that she
had surprised him. Therefore, he slowly
leaned towards her, his voice quiet and
low, sending a shiver down her spine.
He whispered that he knew an auntie who
told him that if he didn't learn to be
cautious around adults and followed
someone somewhere, he would get into
serious trouble. Feeling flustered, the
girl decided that he was making fun of
her. Grabbing the door handle, she said
that if he didn't want to, he didn't
have to go, but he was quicker and with
a swift movement, he blocked the door
with his foot, not giving her the chance
to close it. Then he leaned against the
door frame, trying to open the door
wider, and said that he had never said
he didn't want to follow her. His gaze
pierced through her. The door closed
behind them and Biamha teased her,
asking if she wasn't planning to do
anything strange with him, to which the
girl's indignation was clearly heard. At
that moment, an unknown figure stood in
the shadow of the house. While the guy
was taking a shower, Nahu decided to
fold the items she had bought today and
also sort out the freshly washed
clothes. The girl was in an elevated
mood, unable to believe that luck had
finally turned in her favor. She was so
happy that she had managed to buy so
many new beautiful clothes. It would be
enough for her for several years. Baam
Taiha stepped out of the shower and
froze, intrigued by the sight before
him. She was happily hugging her new
clothes, squealing with excitement as
she rolled around on the floor. He
couldn't help but ask what she was
doing. She froze, feeling embarrassed
that he had caught her in such a
position. She quickly sat up and said
that she was just folding the clothes.
The guy bit his lip to keep from
laughing and said that she was doing it
in quite an amusing way, adding that
he'd help her, although she tried to
protest, saying that he was a guest and
shouldn't be doing such things. The guy
began helping her, responding that he
actually enjoyed doing things like that.
Nahu looked at him and thought that the
more she observed him, the more
fascinating he seemed. No matter what
she said, his expression rarely changed,
but sometimes his ears would turn red.
It was as if his emotions were reflected
through his ears, and he reminded her of
a cute little puppy. He was sitting with
a content expression on his face,
folding clothes, and she could see that
he was in a good mood. Suddenly, she had
a strong urge to do something, and she
moved toward the guy, pressing her
breasts against him. She hadn't noticed
before, but now it seemed easier to
understand his feelings. Maybe because
they were closer now. His expression is
always so restrained. But the way he
subtly shows emotions for some reason
looks quite cute. She was drawn to him,
so she gave in to the urge and kissed
his earlobe gently. When he felt the
girl's lips on his ear, Bomiha felt an
electric shock, and he opened his eyes
suddenly and froze. He slowly turned his
head, their lips almost touching, and
Nah Su's face flushed as she realized
what she had just done. She recoiled
from him, covering her mouth with her
hand in disbelief, burning with
embarrassment. He didn't take his eyes
off her. His gaze now filled with
emotions as if preparing for something.
The girl began to slowly crawl away from
him, stammering, trying to explain that
it wasn't what he thought. But in the
next moment, he moved with the speed of
a predator, grabbing her by the ankle
and pulling her toward him. The girl's
heart seemed ready to jump out of her
chest, driven by adrenaline.
Meanwhile, Biam Taiha, with a predatory
grin, easily caught her wrists in his,
not giving her a single chance to
resist, immobilizing her. Then he
smoothly lifted her arms, fixing them
above her head, and leaned in close to
her
face. Nahu felt a mix of excitement and
fear. Seeing her confused yet interested
look, the guy smirked and with one hand
took a trip down her body. His fingers
traveled lightly down her waist and over
her ribs. He leaned in closer, his
breath against hers, whispering softly.
Without taking his gaze off and smiling
slightly, he asked what his auntie was
doing right now. Nahu gulped loudly,
falling into the captivity of his eyes
and the sensations he was causing in
her. She looked away and quietly replied
that she bit his earlobe. Then Biama
asked why she did that, his voice
already. The girl hesitated before
replying that she didn't know what came
over her and he gave her a crooked
smile. In the next moment, he leaned in
and gently bit her neck, saying that she
shouldn't lie to him. Nahu couldn't
suppress a sigh, remembering that it was
the exact same spot as last time. In a
soft voice, she said it tickled. She
remained lying there, pinned down, and
asked why he kept biting her like a dog.
The girl looked at him with her wide
eyes and thought that it wasn't about
him. It was about how every time she
found herself pinned against his big,
warm body, her entire being tensed up
like a small creature that instinctively
knew it was about to be devoured by a
predator. In the next moment, their lips
met, and as usual, it became hard for
her to breathe. She recognized this
feeling. It was exactly the same as the
last time. Nahu barely managed to escape
his embrace and reached for the switch
to turn off the light, but the guy was
just as quick. He immediately caught her
hand, turned her to face him, pinning
her against the wall as he loomed over
her. Their breaths mingled. His
movements were slow and honed. Finally,
she caught his hands, and a bit
flustered, said that she wanted to go to
the room. Bam Taiha lifted her chin and
smirking asked if she wanted to run away
from him. To his surprise, the girl
confidently placed her hands on his
chest and boldly replied, asking what
made him think that. She pushed him
gently and said that last time it was a
little difficult for her. Therefore,
this time she wants to do everything
herself and he needs to be obedient. The
guy stared at her with wide stunned
eyes. Nahu tried to act boldly, but
inside fear was trembling in her, so at
some point it became hard for her. The
guy reached for her face and began
teasing her, whispering silly things.
She lowered her head, hugging him
tightly. At some point, she stopped
feeling embarrassed and started saying
things that made his pulse quicken even
more. Biamha gazed at her flushed face
and gently stroked her hair, drawing her
closer for a kiss, both of them
dissolving into each other in that
moment. Then he continued to gaze into
her eyes. Anahoo felt like she was
losing her mind. Covering his eyes with
her palm, she said she couldn't handle
his gaze, but he shook his head and met
her with an intense gaze that made the
girl shiver all over. In the next
moment, he felt her body tense up and
she hit her face against his chest. Her
face was burning with embarrassment as
he gently stroked her head, giving her
the space to catch her breath. Then he
smirked with satisfaction and said that
their evening was just beginning.
Holding the girl close, he thought to
himself that he hadn't even started yet.
Nahu was horrified to realize how
gravely she had miscalculated, thinking
she could stay in control of the
situation when in reality she had handed
him the upper hand. The guy felt her
trembling as she tried to scold him for
not listening to her. After all, she had
said she would do everything on her own.
He gave a sly smile and moved in a way
that made the girl's breath hitch once
again. Smirking, he replied that she was
the one who let control slip away, then
asked if she really wanted him to stop.
In the end, she gave in. Lowering her
head onto his shoulder, she softly asked
him to continue. She was breathing
heavily, and as she looked into his
eyes, she kept asking him again and
again. His piercing gaze, which she used
to catch only in fleeting glances, now
sent shivers down her spine and made her
entire body tense with anticipation.
Every time their eyes met, Nahu found it
impossible to hold herself back. And
now, seeing the expression on his face,
she felt even more flustered. She shut
her eyes tightly, afraid she might
completely lose what little reason she
had left. Bam! Taiha gently nipped at
her chin and asked why she always hid
her face from him. It troubled him
because he couldn't tell if she was shy
or if it was because she felt
uncomfortable looking at him, thinking
that their relationship was only
physical. In the next moment, he stopped
and looked at her. The girl asked what
had happened and he replied that
actually he prefer facing each other.
Then he turned the girl around making
her face away from him and whispered
that if she didn't like it, they
wouldn't facing each other. The girl was
slightly shocked by the change in his
mood. He smirked and said that it seemed
like now she liked everything a lot
more. Nahu admitted to herself that she
often thought about him and often
remembered that night. That's why right
now she wanted him to stay with her
until the day ended. Biam Taiha leaned
in and kissed her deeply. As he felt
that he had achieved his goal and the
girl's body trembled once again, a
self-satisfied smile spread across his
face. After a few moments, the girl
spoke, saying that she felt really good
and that she wanted to continue. At this
time, Ary was sleeping peacefully,
cuddled in Mchel's arms. The man,
however, couldn't fall asleep. He lay
there staring at his phone, filled with
doubts. Bomiha lay back, enjoying the
sight of Nah Su, peacefully asleep and
content. The girl was exhausted and fast
asleep. Suddenly, her phone vibrated,
notifying her of a new message. Mchel
typed a message, his thoughts filled
with irritation towards
Nahu. Despite all his requests for her
not to call or text, she had been so
persistent. Now she was completely off
the grid, and there had been no news
from her. Was she even alive? He had
expected that despite telling her to
leave, she would eventually come back to
him. So, what was going on now? Was she
protesting in this way because she was
still angry with him? Typing a few
words, he pressed send and thought to
himself that there was something almost
satisfying about witnessing her pride.
He remembered her tearked face when she
caught him with Ari. The way she reacted
in that moment had even somehow got to
him. He lay there thinking that this had
dragged on too long and that it was time
for her to stop sulking and come back to
him. He believed there was no point in
her staying angry as her grudges never
lasted more than a couple of days.
sighing. Mitchell thought about how much
he missed the ribs that Nah Sue used to
make and how tired he had become of
ordering takeout all the time. Pleased
with himself, he thought that she would
surely respond to him in the morning
when she read the message. After all,
she should be grateful that he took the
first step and messaged her
first. Satisfied with his reasoning, he
decided it was time to go to sleep.
Meanwhile, Baam Taiha picked up the
girl's phone and the screen's light
illuminated his face. He glanced at it
for a moment, his fingers hovering over
the screen as he debated what to do
next. The message received at dawn from
an unsaved number. It wasn't hard to
guess who it was from. A deleted contact
replaced with 11 flashing
digits. Compared to her, the one who
blocked him out of her life completely
as if to shut him out in denial. By
Taiha preferred it this way. He ran his
fingers across the screen, unlocking
pattern. It was so easy. He remembered
that evening at the 24-hour convenience
store when he came to visit her. He
finally convinced the girl to exchange
phone numbers, and she reluctantly
agreed, grumbling as she took out her
phone. She was so carefree and trusting
that she didn't even notice how closely
he watched every one of her movements,
making it easy for him to memorize the
pattern to unlock her phone. He couldn't
help but laugh at how easy it had been.
Her sincerity amused him. So now, with
ease, he unlocked her phone and read the
message. Her ex-husband, of course,
wasn't particularly bright. He wrote the
message as if nothing had ever ended
between them. Reading the simple, "What
are you
doing?" message, the man smirked and
thought about how best to respond. What
exactly Nah Sue had been up to. His
chest quietly trembled with suppressed
laughter as he held the exhausted girl,
who was pressing against him and
sleeping soundly. His hand rested on her
thigh as she nestled her face against
his chest, quietly breathing in her
sleep. Baom Taiha was torn by the
dissonance. On one hand, he wanted to
tell the man an unimaginable story with
all its excruciating details. But on the
other hand, part of him wanted to keep
everything a secret, savoring it for
himself because it was just his and no
one else's. He sighed, thinking to
himself that more and more he wanted to
be caught. He pressed the block contact
button and deleted the entire message
history, wondering if he hurts. Will she
still hurts, too? Would she abandon him
and decide to return to her ex? Looking
at the phone screen, he decided that it
wouldn't hurt to test that. He wished,
and he prayed that she will make him act
worse, act filthier. He placed her phone
back in its place, pulled her head
closer to his chest, and thought to
himself that since she wasn't giving him
certainty, he had no choice but to
become even more petty. Meanwhile, Bea
was spending his usual time at one of
the clubs where a familiar girl noticed
him. She sat down next to him and asked
if he remembered her. The guy tried to
guess her name, but got it wrong twice,
laughing and saying that he did remember
her, just teasing. He handed her a
lighter, and the girl asked if he wanted
her to tell him something interesting.
Biamont he indifferently asked what she
meant and when she replied that she had
recently met a guy who looked exactly
like him, he froze. He replied that
there was no one as handsome as him. The
girl laughed and said that it was true
and from a distance she had thought it
was him. But when she got closer, she
noticed a small difference. She teased
and replied that that guy was much cuter
than he. Then she added that the main
difference between them was their
height. The other guy was very tall,
probably over 190 cm. Biami felt anger
surging inside him and barely holding
back. He asked what happened next. The
girl simply told him that she was
attracted to him and decided to ask for
his number, but he confidently and
politely declined. He smiled and was
courteous, maintaining his distance,
which only made her want to pursue him
even more. Then she said that he turned
her down, saying he already had a
girlfriend, so she decided to leave.
thinking that he had just brushed her
off because she simply wasn't his type.
But as she was leaving, she really did
see a girl approach him. And he smiled
at her so sweetly that it seemed like
they were a couple. Hearing this, Biami
couldn't believe his luck. He smiled
like a madman, muttering, "Of course, my
dear little brother has a girlfriend."
Meanwhile, on the other side of the city
in one of the apartments, the girl
clutched the back of the bed with all
her strength. Li Jay was making the most
of his one and long awaited day off.
After a while, the young couple sat at
the edge of the bed, and the woman asked
why he hadn't told her that he once
dated one of her acquaintances. The man
replied that it was in the past and
asked if it mattered, questioning why
they should stir up the past. With a sly
smile, she said that because of him, she
was now the same girl who had an affair
with the ex-boyfriend of her old
classmate. Lij asked, "Wouldn't she have
stopped seeing him if she knew?" And
with a smirk, the woman replied, "It
wouldn't have stopped me." She reached
out to his face and said that her
feminine intuition should have told her
this earlier, as he was exactly the type
her friend liked. His character, his
face, and even the tattoo on his back.
She really liked all of it. Li Jay
leaned towards her, smiling, and said
that she was talking too much and that
they could do something else instead.
But suddenly his phone rang and the man
got up, grumbling about being on
vacation and wondering who could be
calling him at such a late hour. Seeing
who was calling, the man froze for a
moment, then immediately answered. The
tip of the expensive polished shoes
gleamed in the moonlight. On the other
end of the line, a relaxed and confident
voice of the chairman asked without any
greeting if his son was with him at that
moment. Li Jay stood frozen, unable to
utter a word, feeling fear spread
through his body.
The chairman continued, saying that
since he hadn't seen his son in a long
time and hadn't received any news from
him, he had decided to see him in
person. The man's eyes gleamed coldly as
he informed that he was already heading
over there. Li Jay was hastily putting
on his jacket as he rushed to the car.
The fear that gripped him after the
chairman's words still hadn't let go. He
had tried to dissuade him from visiting
the young master's house, saying that
Bum Taiha was meeting friends today and
wouldn't be home. But Chairman Bom was
adamant and replied that it was even
better. He wanted to see how his son
lived. Their relationship wasn't exactly
warm, so if his son wasn't home, he
would simply look around. Li Jay
anxiously thought about what the man
might find. The young master's apartment
looked like the lair of a madman with
flower bouquets and various trinkets
scattered everywhere, all methodically
collected. He cursed mentally, realizing
he'd seriously messed up. As he raced to
Biam Taiha's apartment, he couldn't help
but remember the day he first got the
job. He had been told it was a
prestigious position, and when he
arrived, he had no idea he would ever
work at such a large company. While
riding the elevator with one of the
bodyguards, he asked if he had any
advice. The man smirked and said that if
Lij kept his mouth shut, everything
would be fine. He didn't understand why
superiors liked their subordinates to
stay silent while they themselves love
to ramble. But turning down such a
well-paying job would have been foolish.
He continued following the bodyguard and
asked if all newcomers went through such
a complicated process. He'd lost count
of how many corridors and elevators
they'd passed. The man replied that
normally no, but Li Jay would be doing a
rather unique job. He told him to listen
carefully and began by saying the
chairman had two sons. Li Jay had heard
that Chairman Biam Ju had a son, the
young heir to the BM family, born with a
vibranium spoon in his mouth and barely
known to the public. But even in this
gossip ridden place, he'd never heard a
single word about the second son.
Judging by how his existence was hidden,
it meant he was an illegitimate child
they'd rather not acknowledge. At first,
the idea that chairman Bom Taiu had a
child out of wedlock surprised Li as he
didn't seem like a man particularly
interested in women. Although with his
power, it wasn't that unusual. But after
getting to know Baum Taiha better, he
decided that although strange, he had
somehow grown close to him. While
everyone else around tried desperately
to flaunt their wealth, this young
master was terrified of standing out.
Lie Jay watched him closely and with
each passing day discovered new oddities
about him. He had a strange taste in
music. The young man listened to songs
about love for Ajumas. His biography was
spotless. No money issues, no problems
with women. He spent only what was
necessary and had no interest in night
life. Though when it came to women,
things were still odd. Li had seen many
girls confess their feelings to the
young master. With his looks and money,
he was never short on female attention.
But each time he rejected them without a
hint of interest, as if he was already
tired of the attention. The last girl
threw a real tantrum. She had been
sincerely in love with him for a long
time. He walked through life leaving
behind trampled hearts, but his gaze
never lingered on the eyes of the woman
so desperately trying to claim him. Now
Li faced a fundamental question. What
kind of report was the chairman
expecting about a young master whose
behavior was pathologically clean? The
only questionable thing was his odd
taste in women. As long as it wasn't
serious, there was no issue. It wasn't
unusual for rich young men to have
strange preferences. Wanting to have fun
with an older woman wasn't shocking. But
the more Ljay observed him, the more
oddities he noticed. He started to
realize that the young master's peculiar
tastes were the eccentric behavior the
chairman had mentioned. And what
initially seemed like a harmless fling
began to go beyond acceptable
boundaries. Lee Jay was already
approaching the required floor, still
thinking that the chairman had somehow
known his son would eventually do
something shocking, something more than
just a passing whim. Why had it happened
right when the young master's
relationship with that woman started to
deepen? As if the chairman had
calculated everything. Lie Jay wondered
whether he should just tell the truth.
Was this a dirty way to find an excuse
to remove Baom Taiha from the line of
inheritance and legally pass everything
to the elder son? That's what an
ordinary man might do. But Baum Taiju
wasn't ordinary. That man was so
ruthless he could bury his own blood in
a dark forest if he wanted. Would he
really go to such trouble over something
so
trivial? The scent of roses overwhelmed
Lie Jay as soon as he stepped into the
apartment, making him dizzy. And only
then did he realize he had overlooked
something important. He remembered the
woman's words that he was too
soft-hearted for this kind of work and
that in the end he would be the one to
suffer for getting involved. Entering
the young master's apartment, he looked
around and cursed, thinking she had been
right. He should never have gotten
involved in this. Grabbing a trash bag,
he quickly began gathering all the
bouquets and rose petals. He couldn't
leave a single clue, not a single hint
that could help the chairman uncover his
son's eccentricities.
Next, he grabbed the pack of cigarettes,
the lighter, and a box of band-aids from
the table. Even if these feelings would
one day ruin the young master's golden
future, right now he just wanted to
support him. Finally, he grabbed the
teddy bear and stuffed it deep into the
wardrobe, making sure it was completely
hidden and promising himself to put
everything back later. Lee Jay couldn't
understand what exactly the chairman was
looking for. If his son were a dumb
playboy, it would be enough to cut his
finances. Relationships with women
weren't even considered damaging to
one's reputation. If he wanted his son
to lead a flawless personal life,
wouldn't it be easier to find him a
bride from a decent family? Or in the
worst case, lock him up? Chairman Biamu
was already walking down the corridor
toward the apartment. Li Jay had barely
finished tidying up the apartment and
himself. Now he stood waiting, thinking
about how he was just an ordinary
person. He could never understand how
someone could be obsessed with things
like this. What kind of report did the
chairman expect to hear from his son's
right hand? Boméju entered the apartment
calmly, his composed but sharp eyes
scanning the space. He walked slowly,
not missing a single detail,
meticulously examining every inch of
Bomiha's residence. The man moved
further inside, and Li Jay watched him
with baited breath, wondering why he was
inspecting the house so closely. Its
appearance barely revealed whether
anyone lived there at all. Lij was
certain he hadn't left a single pedal
behind. He had destroyed every little
thing that could give the young master
away. Finally, the chairman headed
toward the exit, and the man exhaled
with relief. A drop of sweat rolled down
his temple, and although he silently
praised himself for a job well done, he
understood it was only a matter of time
before someone uncovered the truth. He
was grateful it hadn't happened today,
because that obsessive first love still
needed time to sort things out, and the
man had managed to buy them just a
little more. Emboldened, he bowed and
asked the chairman if he had seen
everything he wanted. But suddenly, Baum
Tju stopped. Something had caught his
attention, and he called the bodyguard
by name. Li Jay looked up and saw the
man unfastening the strap of his
expensive watch. He barely had time to
grasp what that meant before he felt a
sharp blow and the metallic taste of
blood in his mouth. The next strike
brought him down to one knee. The
chairman's figure loomed above him and
Ljay didn't dare utter a word. He only
stared straight ahead, breathing
heavily. Then the chairman grabbed him
by the hair and lifting him up said in a
flat tone that he seemed to have grown
quite close to his son. Boméju<unk>s
gaze felt like it was peering straight
into the man's soul. Li apologized, but
the chairman suddenly continued, saying
it looked like his son was seeing
someone. At that, Li froze in horror. He
couldn't understand how the man had
figured it out. The apartment had been
perfectly cleaned. He was sure he hadn't
slipped up. Meanwhile, Baom Tju put his
watch back on and asked why the
bodyguard looked so surprised. He stood
by the shoe rack where a pair of worn
out sneakers lay in plain sight. The
chairman shoved his hands in his pockets
and confidently stated that when a man
starts acting out of character, what
else could it be but a woman? Morning
came and Mitchell was sleeping
restlessly. Lying beside him, holding
him tightly, was Ari. He had been
tossing and turning all night, unable to
get any proper
sleep. And now he wearily opened his
eyes. The man felt awful and reached for
his phone to check the time. Seeing that
it was only 7:20, he cursed under his
breath and thought that his alarm hadn't
even gone off yet, and he was already
awake. It had been a long time since he
woke up this early. He smirked and
thought to himself that Nihei Su should
be grateful to him for waking up this
early just to read a message from her.
He felt a tingling sensation just
thinking about the girl's reaction when
she saw his message. She must have been
waiting for it and was thrilled to
finally receive a long-awaited message
from Mitchell. He decided to check his
messages, smirking as he wondered what
she might have replied. Perhaps
something like, "I'll forgive you for
everything. Just come
back." Then he thought, "No, she does
have her pride." It was more likely she
wrote, "I'll forgive you just this
once. Come home." He was eager to
satisfy his ego. In the end, it didn't
really matter what she had written.
Mchel was certain she was at home,
desperately waiting for him. Maybe she'd
play hard to get for a while, but in the
end, she would give in. Mitchell was
convinced she would crumble easily
before him. But then the smug smile
faded from his face, and a look of
confusion took its place. He saw that
she had read his messages, but hadn't
replied. "What the hell is going on?" he
thought. It was unexpected. The man
tossed aside his phone and thought that
it was actually a bit amusing.
He figured that Nah Su was still the
same boring auntie who only thought
about work and money, which is probably
why she rushed off to work early in the
morning, not having time to reply to
him. He descended the stairs with a
laid-back gate, confident that she would
reply to him during lunch. She was just
playing hard to get, but in the end, she
would reply, and then he would also
crack a little, but he would come back
to her. He smirked and thought that they
both knew that aside from him, she was
needed by no one else. Meanwhile, Baum
Taiha returned home and noticed the
subtle changes that only he could spot,
being the one who meticulously organized
everything and lived there. The petals
of red roses lay in a chaotic order,
most of them much fresher than they
should have been. The arrangement of his
precious belongings. What he had left
with such meticulousness on the small
table was not how he had placed it. The
guy smirked and thought to himself that
this was quite interesting. What had
been happening in his apartment while he
was away? Soon he was sitting in an
armchair reading a book. Li Jay, as
usual, stood nearby, silently doing his
job. Bim Taiha kept his gaze fixed on
the bodyguard, studying him
closely. There was a large bruise
spreading across his cheek, and the guy
remarked that it seemed like the man had
a good time on his vacation, adding that
he must have been hit pretty hard. He
smiled and asked, "How could something
like this happen to you?" LJ calmly
replied that he got beat for some love
affair and that it seemed karma had
caught up with him for his sins. The guy
looked at him strangely and smirking
said that it suited him. The bodyguard
simply turned away thinking to himself
who exactly this guy was trying to mock.
He asked why the young master was
already home so early in the morning.
Judging by the fact that he had spent
the night not alone, Li Jay thought he
might be asked to substitute for someone
again for half the day. Baam Taiha
replied that he was busy today. Lie Jay
smirked and unusually for him asked in a
dissatisfied tone what the young master
would be busy with today. Would he be
selling his pretty face on the street
again to sell flowers, working at a
barbecue shop or heading straight to a
motel or checking out the slums? With a
sneer, he added that the young master
wouldn't rest until he had checked every
move of that woman. He looked at the
mysterious Biamayha and thought that he
was acting as if he would die if that
woman who had neither the means nor the
sense to run away disappeared from his
sight even for a moment. Meanwhile, the
guy smirked and said that he was sorry
to disappoint him, but they wouldn't be
doing any of the things the bodyguard
had listed. He smiled mysteriously and
told him that today he wasn't planning
to go to Nahu. Meanwhile, Nah Su was at
work in the flower shop, constantly
checking her phone, hoping that the guy
would text or call her. The day dragged
on endlessly, her mind full of thoughts,
and there was no news from
Biamha. She didn't know what to think
about it. She recalled this morning.
Exhausted, she had slept peacefully in
his arms while he seemed to be studying
her as she slept. Finally, as sleep
began to leave her, the girl rubbed her
eyes and felt a pleasant scent emanating
from Beamha.
Half awake, she gently ran her hands
over his body. The guy smiled and
tucking a stray lock of hair behind her
ear, said in a low voice that she had
mischievous hands. The girl sleepily
mumbled that she just wanted to sleep a
little longer. Finally, when she woke
up, she realized that she had really
slept longer than usual. She quickly got
up and started getting ready for work,
apologizing to him.
The guy asked if she could stay with
him, but the girl replied that she had
already taken the day off yesterday, so
she told him he could relax and rest as
much as he needed while she had to hurry
and leave. That's why she felt guilty
now. She had invited him to breakfast,
but she had rushed off so quickly, not
even having the chance to feed him.
Moreover, he must have been in shock as
she had immediately dragged him to bed.
The girl thought that she definitely
needed to apologize to him. Nahesu sent
him a message saying sorry, but then
decided to add that next time she would
definitely treat him to breakfast.
However, her fingers hovered over the
send button, unsure whether to send it.
She thought about how sending that
message might cause a misunderstanding,
so she hesitated for a long time, unsure
whether to send it or not. She blushed
and thought that it might look like she
was inviting him to spend the night
together again. But to be honest, at
some point she began to hope that he
would come to her. Even after her harsh
words about how their relationship would
only be physical, he continued to
penetrate her life, filling it and her
nights until they overflowed. The girl
blushed and wondered, "Is this what they
call physical
attachment?" Because even though they
weren't in a relationship, every time
their eyes met, she felt like she wanted
him in her life more and more. She had
sworn to herself that their relationship
would remain purely physical. But what
if in the end it grew into something
more? She recalled recently overhearing
a conversation between two friends when
one of them was asking the other for
advice, wondering if a relationship
starts with physical contact, doesn't
that mean it's already the end of the
story? The girl froze and wondered, does
Bum Taiha think the same way now? Maybe
he believed that their relationship
built only on desire and not on tender
attachment had been doomed from the
start. And now perhaps someone like her,
a plain work-focused auntie, seemed just
too easy to him. Just a worn out adult,
like warm and stale compared to his
youth, still blazing with passion. But
maybe this them staying together is just
the fastest way for him to get tired of
her. Nes Jesus stared at her phone,
wondering, "Wasn't this exactly what she
had wanted?" For the guy to grow bored
and walk away. Maybe that was the best
possible outcome for both of them.
Later, throughout the entire day, the
girl kept checking her phone, hoping for
a reply from him. She kept thinking
about him and couldn't understand why he
was acting so strangely today and not
even replying to her. Maybe he was just
really busy. Meanwhile, Mchel was
sitting at work, staring at his phone as
if trying to hypnotize it, waiting for a
reply from
Nahu. He tapped his fingers nervously,
unable to understand why she was so
silent. Impatiently, he reached for his
phone once again to check if he had
somehow missed any
notifications. A colleague walked up to
him and asked what was going on with him
today, why he hadn't taken his eyes off
his phone since morning, as if someone
had borrowed money from him and was just
about to pay it back. But Mchel just
snorted and thought to himself, "Who
else here is waiting for someone?" He
stood up, grabbed his jacket, and headed
for the door, throwing over his shoulder
that nothing of the sort was happening
and that the man better mind his own
business. Meanwhile, during the break,
the men, as usual, discussed women
sharing their adventures, while the
female colleagues passing by thought to
themselves that such conversations were
simply disgusting. The elderly boss told
his subordinates that at the
marriageable age, one shouldn't waste
time on the wrong people and that it was
better to find a good match among mutual
acquaintances. The men laughed and asked
if he could introduce them to someone
from his social circle. But the boss
said he didn't have anyone in mind.
Suddenly, the security guard spoke up,
suggesting that the man should try
talking to someone among the colleagues
since the company had plenty of people.
Then he unexpectedly mentioned a woman
who had recently come by looking for
Mchel. Scratching his chin, the man said
that although Mchel had a terrible
personality, his taste in women was
excellent. She didn't exactly resemble
his relative, but she was very cute. She
had a beautiful figure, and judging by
her age, she seemed like a perfect
match. The man smirked and said that the
guy could ask Mchel to introduce them.
At that moment, Mchel appeared, lighting
a cigarette, and the men grinned, saying
that as soon as they mentioned the
devil, there he was. The security guard
turned to him and asked if he remembered
the woman who had come to the office
looking for him. Mitchell turned away
and pretended not to understand who he
was talking about, but the security
guard wouldn't let up, mentioning that
she had introduced herself as a member
of his family and that she was quite
cute. Menchel let out an irritated sigh.
Immediately, a barrage of questions came
at him about what she did and whether
she was single. He said she looked so
cute that Syang Huan couldn't take his
eyes off her. The men burst out laughing
while Mchel felt irritated and couldn't
understand what the hell was going on.
The men continued discussing Nahu,
tossing around suggestive remarks. And
one of them said that with such a figure
and a cute face, she could easily find
an older rich man and live comfortably.
For the first time in a long while,
Mchel felt a pang of jealousy. He
couldn't believe that someone as
ordinary as Nahu could attract anyone's
attention other than his own.
Immediately, a barrage of questions came
at him about what she did and whether
she was single. He said she looked so
cute that Xang Huan couldn't take his
eyes off her. The men burst out laughing
while Mchel felt irritated and couldn't
understand what the hell was going on.
The men continued discussing Nahu,
tossing around suggestive remarks, and
one of them said that with such a figure
and a cute face, she could easily find
an older rich man and live comfortably.
For the first time in a long while,
Mchel felt a pang of jealousy. He
couldn't believe that someone as
ordinary as Nahu could attract anyone's
attention other than his own. He threw
the cigarette butt on the ground and
asked the man if he was having fun. Then
he started approaching him and said that
his colleague was old and not very good
at his job. Moreover, despite all that,
he kept eyeing the young girls in the
office, especially the new ones.
Mitchell grabbed the man by the collar,
and the man shouted, asking what the
hell this bastard was talking about.
They were just talking, but Mchel
pressed him against the wall, continuing
to squeeze his throat. The man could
only gasp for air and demand to be let
go. Finally, other men nearby started
calming him down and asked what had
gotten into him. They were just having
guy talk and didn't mean to offend
anyone. But Mitchell seemed to see
nothing in front of him and asked why
they were saying such careless things
about a married woman. Were they out of
their minds? Why did she seem cute to
them? He remembered Nahisu, who always
looked cheap and pitiful in her worn out
clothes. She was always cold and lacked
even a drop of charm. Meanwhile, Xiang
Huan kept apologizing, saying he didn't
know she was married and begged to be
released. Mchel let go of him, and the
man collapsed to the ground, coughing
and gasping for air. Mchel looked like a
mad man and continued saying that he'd
better remember once and for all that
this woman wasn't interested in anyone
except her husband, and would never look
at anyone else. He remembered her and
thought she was like a withered flower
in his hands. She never even glanced
past him, and he was the only one who
could touch her. Finally, he shot a
threatening glance at the men and told
them not to even dare think about
Nahisu. Seong Juan, still sitting on the
ground, looked at him in shock and said
the man had clearly gone insane. His
friends helped him up while he kept
swearing and saying that all he did was
ask to be introduced to the woman, but
the guy acted like a complete
bastard. The men decided Mitchell just
didn't know how to behave in an office.
He turned to the boss and said the guy
had crazy eyes and almost choked him. He
asked if the boss was going to punish
him somehow, but the boss sighed and
said he'd leave him alone for now. The
boss said Mitchell was hired by a
decision from upper management. Siang
Juan was surprised and asked if he was
the CEO's son or something, but the boss
replied that he didn't know. He had
tried asking around, but never got any
answers. In any case, they should all
stay away from him. Meanwhile, Mchel
checked his phone. There was still no
reply from Nahu, and it made him very
anxious. He didn't like what was going
on. Biami was sprawled on the couch
trying to recover from a wild night. His
bodyguard gently tried to get his
attention. He mumbled that he felt sick
and told everyone to leave him alone.
But the man continued persistently
trying to get his attention. Eventually,
the guy yelled and asked how he dared
wake him up and why he was even there.
But when the bodyguard said he was there
on the chairman's orders, he immediately
opened his eyes and gave him his full
attention. Sometime later, Biami arrived
at a hotel owned by their family.
Smiling confidently, he was sure his
time had finally come and that his
father had finally decided to entrust
him with the business. He walked toward
the entrance with a relaxed and
confident stride, thinking it was
probably because his son, who had never
cared about the family business, had
finally gotten an education and learned
how to run a
hotel. He didn't like that he had to
start from scratch when all of it should
have been his by birthright. But what
could he do? The chairman was harsh with
his children. Byte he was in a great
mood also because his bastard brother
was a total noob compared to him. That
was the difference in their status. He
was already imagining how he'd inherit
everything and then deal with him. First
of all, he'd make sure his younger
brother was left with nothing. But
suddenly, something familiar caught his
eye. Biama was walking through the hotel
lobby accompanied by a staff member.
What was he doing here? The young people
had already entered the elevator and the
doors were just about to close. But
suddenly, someone's hand caught the
elevator door and stopped it. Biami
glared at his brother with hostility,
trying to hide his confusion with
sarcasm, saying, "Well, well, look who
we have here." Then he growled, asking
Biamha what he was doing there. Biamha
looked silently at his older brother.
His face showed no emotion and that
infuriated Biamai who shouted demanding
an answer. Then finally the guy gave a
slight smile and said that seeing him in
a place like this was unexpected asking
if he wasn't happy to see him here.
Enraged, Biami roughly grabbed the hotel
staff member standing next to his
brother by the arm. He squeezed her arm
tightly and asked why she was there. Had
the chairman assigned her to be with
Bayum Teha and train him. But then Baum
Taiha grabbed his hand and pulled it
away from the frightened girl saying he
should behave properly. The girl cowered
in the corner watching the confrontation
between the brothers. Meanwhile, the
younger man said that thanks to Biamhi's
reckless behavior, he also got the
chance to prove himself to the chairman.
Bom Taihi just laughed and insulted him
crudely. He said that even though Bum
Taiha was pretending to be the precious
son, he was just a lunatic who didn't
know his place. He stepped out of the
elevator, smirking. Then he gave him a
hostile, contemptuous look and promised
he would regret behaving like that. The
elevator doors were closing, but Bea
Tahha's expression remained unreadable.
And just a second before they closed, a
faint triumphant smirk appeared on his
face. Baom Tehei stood there, lowered
his head, and punched the wall hard,
shouting curses. He was only thinking
about how to get rid of that bastard.
Suddenly, hazy memories from the
previous night surfaced in his mind. A
club, a familiar girl, and her story
about seeing his brother with some
woman. Biami straightened up, and a plan
was already forming in his mind. Nahesu
had taken a bath and checked her phone
for the hundth time that day. Still no
reply from the guy. She was racking her
brain, wondering what could have
happened to him. As she was getting
ready for bed, she thought about how he
hadn't messaged or called her once all
day. She worried that something bad
might have happened or he was just too
busy. She was afraid he might have been
hurt again and she wouldn't even know.
He hadn't contacted her for just one day
and she was already on edge. It was
almost funny. Suddenly, she got a phone
notification. She immediately got up to
check if Baum Taiha had messaged her.
Maybe he had to work overtime today
because he'd spent all of yesterday with
her. But to her disappointment, it was
just spam offering an interestfree loan.
She gloomily put down her phone and lay
down next to it, still staring at it,
hoping he might message her. It was a
completely ordinary day, just as routine
as all the ones she had before Bum Tahha
appeared in her life. She sadly thought
about how she was waiting for a message
from him and drifted into memories of
life with Mitchell. She used to text him
often, but he rarely replied. When he
came home, he constantly scolded and
complained that she annoyed him with too
many messages. He said she needed to
stop being so clingy and turn off her
phone because he was getting sick of her
overwhelming presence in his life. She
sighed heavily and thought about how no
one had ever texted her or cared how she
was doing. So why was she waiting now?
Why was she acting so
strangely? The girl scolded herself for
her empty hopes. But suddenly the screen
of her phone lit up again. At that
moment Baum Taiha was standing holding
his phone sending her a message. When
Nah Su picked up her phone and saw that
the message was from him, tears of joy
sparkled in her eyes. Her hands trembled
in a whirlwind of thoughts raced through
her mind. He asked if they could see
each other if she wasn't asleep yet and
said he was outside her house. Her heart
was beating like crazy and throwing the
phone aside, she ran to the front door.
She rushed so fast she didn't feel the
floor beneath her feet pressing a hand
to her chest. Nahu knew he was tempting
her, and she gladly gave into it. even
though she knew how it would all end.
Approaching the door, she opened it
slightly and with an excited voice
called out his name, then carefully
peeked outside, sensing an unfamiliar
smell. The next second, a man's hand
wrapped around the back of her head and
pulled her close. The girl only managed
to let out a squeak of fear, but then
Biamonta's lips crashed onto hers, and
he held her tightly, kissing her. He
seemed starved for her and couldn't get
enough.
The girl froze, melting into the moment.
Thanks for watching. If you enjoyed the
recap, don't forget to like, share, and
subscribe for more epic stories. See you
in the next